what do you do when the sun turns wrong when light
which once represented life joy and warmth becomes
a symbol of death and destruction do you hide
inside shutter the windows keep out the light
by any means necessary do you Retreat underground
where the sun's Rays cannot penetrate burrowing
into the dark in the cold do you simply give
yourself to it accepting that there is no escaping
something so vast so far reaching as sunlight
itself and allow yourself to be lost in the end of
all things we've covered this possibility before
scp-001 when day breaks or SD Locke's proposal
it's difficult to know what any given person
might do in such harrowing circumstances after
all we have always learned to love the light and
fear the darkness it turns our very understanding
of reality upside down to have that Paradigm
shifted the dark becoming safety and the light
becoming death the source of all life on Earth of
all warmth transforming in an instant from the Sun
as we know it to an apollyon class SCP that melts
all living organisms that cross into its gaze but
what about a being that has always feared the
light something that prioritizes Solitude and
never ever wants to be seen how might it live out
those darkened days today we're taking a look at
what happens when Daybreak meets a familiar face
even if a constantly hidden one scp-096 scp-096
or the shy guy is something of a celebrity around
here it is a humanoid creature with long distended
arms pale skin and a jaw that can open four times
wider than an ordinary humans there is only one
thing above all else that this entity desires for
no one to see its face when someone views its face
it flies into an uncontrollable rage and seems to
have no other option but to destroy the person who
has seen it so it is unlikely that a creature
so intent on Solitude would be in much Danger
from the transformed sun in fact it might even be
a positive thing and for some time it was with so
many human beings gone reduced to gelatinous
masses with no desire but to Slither around in
the ghoulish sunlight and merge with one another
there were fewer people to observe his face than
ever he could stay inside and know with almost
complete certainty that no one would come to
bother him no one was coming to look at him and
there were no more visitors researchers poking
and prodding that might sneak a look at his face
and so he stayed there in the room that had served
as his containment unit before the world turned
upside down the masses of Flesh that once were
humans did not concern him as they never looked at
his face all he did was stay in his room and never
go outside the outside frightened him terribly
though he was not concerned with the deadly
sunlight or the possibility of it melting him as
it had so many others he was much more afraid that
someone some unlikely Survivor clinging to their
original life might look at him that they might
see his face that was simply too distressing
to risk he would much rather stay alone in his
old cell weeping softly in the shadows one day
though we couldn't say how many days after the
end of things it had been he was weeping alone
in his former cell the days blurred together
spent the same way and time had lost much of its
meaning through the echoing sound of his sobs and
the sloshing sounds of the creatures outside
a woman's voice cut through it was faint but
he could make out what she was saying she was
calling out for help asking if anyone had any
food or fresh water the sound was getting louder
closer accompanied by the disconcerting thump
of her footsteps she was coming down the hall as
much as it could be called a hall anymore she was
coming towards his room to disrupt his miserable
peace he heard her steps cross the threshold
of his room and her voice broke into a terrified
scream no doubt at the unexpected sight of a pale
naked creature weeping in the corner of what she
expected to be an empty room startled by the first
loud sound he'd heard in a long time in a world
that had mostly been silent since the initial
outpouring of agonized Screams had faded into
the soft slap of Flesh and slime on the ground he
turned around he shouldn't ordinarily he wouldn't
but he couldn't stop himself there he saw a woman
wide eyes filled with tears face streaked with
dirt a small child next to her holding her hand
and clinging to her leg just as he saw the woman
she saw him she saw saw his face anger boiled over
inside of him and he let out a scream wild Primal
and filled with inhuman rage she could not be
looking at him seeing his face he couldn't let her
the woman ran with a child in tow panicked by the
wild Roar in the sight of him standing up right
before her the anger faded as she left his sight
making her way down the hall into the stairs but
then he remembered she had seen his face he could
not let her leave it was time to do something
he never thought he'd have to do again hunt his
heightened senses picked up the sound of muffled
footsteps coming up through the floor below him
she was downstairs just beneath the floor where
he was standing his instincts kicked in and his
body moved almost of its own accord he lifted
his long long arms above his head and drove his
hands down into the floor it was weakened by the
RAV images of the elements and time and crumbled
under his unnatural strength he dug his claws
into the plaster tearing it apart and cracking
it into pieces he pushed his claws in deeper and
deeper until he could feel them breaking through
the other side he pulled the floor apart until the
hole was wide enough to fit through then dropped
down to the room below he spotted the woman's
back fleeing through the door just as he landed
she was getting away he tore after her ripping
through concrete and steel destroying everything
in his path in a Mad Dash for the object of
his rage he had to catch her she could not be
allowed to leave she looked over her shoulder at
him her face a mask of pure Terror she knew just
as he knew that there was no Escape in sight in
his single-minded obsession and her desperation
to escape from him neither of them noticed that
she had run so far and so carelessly that she was
now outside the building she he had crossed from
the Shadows into the harsh light of the Sun the
woman's eyes widened in Grim understanding of
her fate he could only watch helplessly as her
body began to succumb to the vicious Rays almost
instantly she began to melt as it was closest to
the Sun her head was the first to go her nose
drooped like hot wax dripping as it went until
it slumped off her face and landed on the ground
with a sickening Splash her eyes were next popping
out of their sockets and hanging loose and Limp
on her cheeks and dangling from sinewy strands
she tried in vain to stuff them back into place
but they squished in her hands like over ripe
fruit she attempted to run into the comparative
safety of the ruined building but her feet were
already beginning to spread out onto the street
melting into a sticky red smear on the pavement
her legs crumbled beneath her and she collapsed to
the ground her face leaving a trail of gelatinous
Flesh as it landed she tried uselessly to drag
herself along the ground back into the darkness
but her arms were melting into the dirt mixing
with it into a horrible red mud she let out a
last scream of Agony but the sound turned to a
thick gurgle as her lips fused together and her
mouth melted into nothingness he watched it all
sobbing and roaring in frustration she was gone
and he would never get the satisfaction of ending
her The Infernal son had stolen her from him now
she was nothing but a wet Shadow like the rest of
the humans had become long ago he heard the sound
of a soft SOB behind him a tiny human voice he
turned looking for the source there was the little
girl he had almost forgotten about her she was
calling out for her mother and crying and she was
looking right at him right at his face he waited
for the anger to overtake him but instead there
was nothing why wasn't he angry she was looking at
his face so why then he realized her eyes were on
him but she did not see him she was blind she
approached the creature her arms outstretched
following the sound of his crying she touched
his hand with her own tiny fingers so small and
fragile and asked Mommy then he felt something he
had never felt before tenderness care a desire to
protect this tiny innocent being it was the first
time he had ever felt warm ever felt anything but
sadness anger or fear overcome with his softness
he wrapped his arms around the child and hugged
her clothes she hugged him back tightly and
the room went quiet as they both stopped crying
from that day on they became a family of sorts
they lived together and he took care of her she
didn't know what he looked like and had no idea
he might something to fear to her he was safety
he was home for the first time in his long awful
life he felt like a Human Instead of a monster he
would scavenge food for her bring her fresh water
lay down stolen blankets and pillows so she would
have a soft place to rest he even found her a
ratty worn teddy bear amongst the rubble and
gave it to her as a gift she clutched it to her
chest and thanked him and for once his tears were
those of joy in this cursed World they had found
something like happiness in one another he knew
he would protect her no matter what then one day
everything changed the creature and the little
girl were playing in the abandoned sight making up
little games together when he took a break to look
out at the window and monitor their surroundings
outside the evil Red Sun waited when he turned
back the little girl was gone one of the shadowy
creatures once human was imitating voice to lure
her away he could hear it in the distance and her
tiny footsteps following it he chased after her
the only thing he had ever loved and saw her just
as she stepped out into the light she screamed as
one of her arms began to melt in the light and he
knew what he had to do he grabbed her and pulled
her back inside using his body to Shield her
from the horrible Rays as he wept over her his
tears stopped her body from melting any further
but his body continued to fall apart it was too
late for him he ran as far as he could once he
transformed he did not want to end up hurting
the girl he ran until his legs melted away and he
could not run anymore he had reached the shoreline
and stared out at the ocean unable to move anymore
he screamed a final time in agony in heartbreak in
mourning for the happiness he had finally found
and now would lose but least he knew as his eyes
melted away and he was nearly gone that the girl
would be safe and then he was gone and the world
was quiet think back to your childhood and ask
yourself what was the most pain you've ever felt
while growing up as we develop our understanding
of pain evolves according to our different
experiences the older we get the injuries we
suffered as children like a scraped knee or a bee
sting rarely cause us the same level of distress
as they used to of course when you are young and
unfamiliar with sensations of pain what you really
need in that moment straight after you've fallen
off your bike or tripped playing soccer is someone
to pick you back up and give your sore spot a kiss
perhaps you even need a bowl of warm soup
to comfort you luckily for you scp-348 is
exactly that while many of the anomalies held in
containment by the SCP Foundation have earned the
Euclid or inFAMOUS ketter class designate Nations
scp-348 is one of the few considered to be safe
both in the sense it poses no containment risk
and in that it wouldn't hurt a fly it is neither
an ancient Eldritch Abomination From Another
Dimension spreading its influence in our world
through memetic stimuli nor is it a recording
of a basketball game in which all the players
and Spectators are trapped inside it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile or a
towering winged being wielding a flaming sword and
guarding the entrance to the Garden of Eden to put
it simply scp-348 is a bowl a white ceramic Bowl
the kind you would find almost anywhere in the
world it may even look indistinguishable from the
one in your kitchen cabinet of course scp-348 is
hardly as ordinary as it outwardly appears to be
and it certainly isn't the only inanimate object
that the foundation keeps safely stored away the
key thing that differentiates scp-348 from most
other anomalies is how genuine really harmless it
is its anomalous properties do not cause injury to
any individual that interacts with it nor does
this bull have any adverse effects on the world
around it scp-348 cannot bend or reshape reality
it does not cause the person eating from it to
have premonitions of their own death and using
it certainly does not manifest a contract making
entity at the opposite side of the table so what
makes this bowl in any way anomalous what about it
categorizes it as an SCP and not just a harmless
piece of fine Crockery well why don't we start
with how scp-348 was first discovered some time
ago the SCP Foundation was made aware of rumors
surrounding the child living in an unknown part of
the world according to the intelligence gathered
by the foundation this child seemed to possess
some sort of healing ability or at least this is
what rumors suggested upon further investigation
the source of these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared to come
from a small small ceramic pole which we now know
as scp-348 this is not to say that the bowl has
any inherently Supernatural healing properties and
it doesn't impart any regenerative power to those
that eat from it either it does heal in a certain
sense but not in the way you're probably imagining
when the SCP Foundation recovered scp-348 there
were no markings on it indicating where the
bowl came from or who it was manufactured by
the only visually distinct details worthy of
note were flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand-painted around both the inside and outside of
scp-348 the ceramic surface also bore the Chinese
letters shangshini which translates to the phrase
thinking of you the child that first discovered it
found the ceramic Bowl in the Attic of their
home the child's parents were both full-time
workers and seemed to be somewhat neglectful of
their child although they refused to comment on
this but according to the findings of the SCP
Foundation the child had come to rely on scp-348
deciding to further investigate the anomalous
properties of scp-348 the foundation began testing
it given that the child who first discovered the
bowl had relied upon it tests involve Foundation
researchers presenting certain children to scp-348
and observing the results so was this bowl haunted
perhaps harboring some malicious Spirit or entity
that sought to corrupt these children maybe even
healing them in order to somehow use them as a
vessel to break into our world no and while may
have not healed in any overt or expected way
it did heal in at least a metaphorical sense
if presented with an injured child supporting
any form of minor ailments such as a cut or a
runny nose scp-348 fills with warm soup and yes
that's right we said soup what kind you may ask
well that seems to vary sometimes it is tomato
soup other times it might be chicken noodle soup
while the ingredients you used in the soups are
often different there are notable consistencies
to how scp-348 heals if anyone between the ages
of 4 years old and 18 years old sits down in front
of the blue flowered Bowl then scp-348 will fill
with soup numerous young test subjects brought in
by the foundation to eat from this particular bowl
of soup have reported that they enjoyed their meal
usually finishing the entire Bowl when permitted
to by research staff many of the injured children
that were tested have stated that the soup they
eat from scp-348 reminds them of their parents
cooking these children have expressed contentment
and feelings of comfort after acquiring their
various cuts and bruises some even claim that
even though they were in a room all alone they
didn't feel lonely when they were eating the soup
and all the anomalous properties don't end after
a child finishes the soup usually although not
always the bowl will leave the child a message
often some brief words of reassurance or Comfort
these messes just materialize on the inside rim of
the bowl and seem to be specifically tailored to
the subject that has just eaten the words will not
only be written in the child's first language
but are often linked to the child's home life
or relationship with their parents messages that
appear on scp-348 usually fade over time normally
disappearing after a few hours or when the bull
refills with more soup one test of scp-348 saw
a little girl age 8 and suffering from a sore
throat brought before the bowl according to a
background screening made by research Personnel
the girl lived with her biological parents and
apparently had a good relationship with both her
mother and her father when scp-348 filled with
superher the girl took almost half an hour to
finish eating and afterwards reported that she
felt her sore throat get better as she ain't by
the end of the meal this test subject remarked
that she felt completely normal in this instance
no message appeared within the bowl another child
was brought in to continue the testing of scp-348
this time a boy of 10. unlike the previous test
this boy was not on good terms with his parents
and often argued with them at the time of testing
the boy had sustained several minor bruises the
result of a small accident that occurred while
the boy had been out riding his bike much like
the little girl this subject ate the soup that
scp-348 presented him with this time though the
bull offered a message to the boy the lettering
found on the ceramic surface of scp-348 Simply
Red don't forget to brush messages also appeared
when an 11 year old boy with a slight cold ate
soup from the bowl this child had been adopted
by a foster family and after eating from scp-348
he saw the message I'm glad you're happy appear
another young test subject a boy aged six had a
similar experience in this instance the child had
several scrapes and scratches from playing with
his friends his parents had divorced and he he
was living with his mother at the time of testing
this time scp-348's message to this boy read I'm
sorry son a seven-year-old girl suffering from a
cough was brought in before scp-348 she had lost
her father to a traffic accident sometime before
testing commenced and received the message I
love you after finishing her soup further testing
conducted by the foundation revealed that anyone
over the age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from scp-348 experienced things slightly
differently unlike the children older subjects
mostly displayed a disinterest in finishing their
meal a common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something however in a
few isolated cases testing scp-348 on older
candidates still revealed messages although
the words seemed to be faded not the clear
hand-painted blue that appeared when the children
had finished their soup one woman aged 30 who
was suffering from a headache sat down in front
of scp3 348 much like it had done before the bowl
filled with soup and the woman ate as with some of
the younger subjects a key aspect of This Woman's
background seemed to be what triggered the message
to appear specifically she admitted to being on
bad terms with her mother and father the woman
explained that she had opted to live on her own
isolating herself from her family in fact she even
described having rejected an offer her father made
to her many years earlier refusing some Career
Training that he was willing to give in order to
help her secure a job when she finished the soup
one word appeared in the bowl why another woman
who was 40 years old was also brought in for the
scp-348 testing much like the previous subject she
had moved away from home and became estranged from
her parents over the years but unlike the previous
test this woman had taken it upon herself to not
only send money to her parents but also arranged
senior care for both as well prior to testing her
father had died peacefully of natural causes after
spend ending his last days in the care that this
woman had paid for as the woman ate the soup from
the bowl she remarked about its apparently bitter
taste but also described her meal as fulfilling
after she had finished the words thank you
appeared with an scp-348 one other adult subject
that produced a noticeable result from scp-348
was a 40 year old male the results of this test
appeared to be the most distinctly different from
any previous adult or Child by now researchers
working for the SCP Foundation had determined that
familial history seemed to play an important role
in the outcome of any interaction with scp-348
and this individual was certainly different to
most the man in question had murdered his father
roughly a year before the testing took place he
began the test with scp-348 while Afflicted with
aches in his back after one Taste of the soup that
appeared in the Bowl before him the murderer was
immediately repulsed he complained about the taste
refusing to eat any more from scp-348 shortly
after the man began to experience severe stomach
pain the potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of but scp-348 immediately filled with salt water
which took three hours to disappear from the bowl
despite conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and ailments the SCP Foundation
researchers have so far been unable to determine
the origins of the messages that sometimes appear
in scp-348 some have theorized because of the
family histories of some children and adults
tested that the words somehow come from the
father of whoever eats the soup since even when
a subject's father is alive or present in their
life the message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other researchers
claim that this is just the purpose of scp-348
to provide Comfort to small children dealing with
pain both inside and out after all is in providing
Comfort one a good bowl of soup anomalous or not
is best app they'd spend hours making the costume
the two young boys let's call them Johnny and Max
had always been on the creative side sometimes
they got teased for it at school but they didn't
care as long as they had each other they could
handle anything they were best friends maybe one
day they'd build great things together out of
concrete and steel but for now they worked with
cardboard prior projects had included building
a rocket out of cardboard in Johnny's backyard
like the kind that put a man on the moon they'd
also made a box Fort like no other more a box
Castle really the kind that would stand for a
hundred years as long as it didn't rain of course
but all that felt like nothing compared to the
tunnel monster to these two young friends it was
a thing of beauty a fully articulated cardboard
monster costume meticulously cobbled together from
boxes masking tape cardboard tubes for arms and
legs and a little twine to bring it all together
Frankenstein Dracula Freddy Krueger those Silver
Screen phonies were nothing compared to the tunnel
monster they even cut out eye holes in the head
and Drew the scariest snarling mouth that they
could write below the making was over and now they
were ready to play Johnny and Max took the costume
down to one of their favorite places in town the
abandoned Rector construction site to many would
seem like a strange and dangerous place for two
young children to play but for Johnny and Max it
was perfect after all they were the age where they
had more imagination than sense Max would be the
one wearing the costume Johnny helped him put it
on piece by piece using extra masking tape and
Twine where necessary to fasten all the pieces
together little by little Max became the tunnel
monster the transformation was complete and it
was finally time for the games to begin Johnny ran
wielding a stick as a defensive weapon while Max
gave Chase he could feel his own hot breath within
the cardboard mask it was oddly exhilarating he
gave a monstrous Roar and charged after his friend
chasing him into the child-sized pipes of An
Unfinished water drainage system it was more fun
than anything they could have imagined Max really
got into his role he lunged forwards grabbing
Johnny with his cardboard gauntlets and tried to
drag him back into the tunnel all while giving low
guttural growls Johnny laughed and swatted at Max
with his stick like a night-wielding a sword they
ran and crawled through the tunnels the best of
friends having the best of times making the kind
of memories that would last forever and in that
sense they were right something they made that day
would echo on forever but it wouldn't be something
they would look back upon fondly if they weren't
so busy running through the tunnels Max and Johnny
might have noticed that something was amiss they
might have seen that even though it was only 3 pm
on a Summer's Day the sky was beginning to darken
it may not have saved them but it might have given
them time to prepare for what was coming Max was
still chasing Johnny down a pipe still fully in
character as the tunnel monster his arms extended
to grab his fleeing friend while Johnny tripped
Max stopped to help him up but something was
wrong when Max helped Johnny stand up Johnny
instinctually pushed him away as though it wasn't
actually his friend anymore Max stumbled backwards
in shock and horror he could feel something
changing beneath the cardboard he suddenly
was in pain this terrible pain like it was being
pulled apart and put back together he started to
scream it was a horrible sound like nails on a
chalkboard Johnny had to hold his ears as the
screaming got louder and louder but Max couldn't
stop he was hurting too much to stop Johnny was
crying he didn't know what was happening
only that his friend was in terrible pain
and that there was seemingly nothing he could
do to stop it even Max didn't know much more
than that but he thought it might have something
to do with the suit it felt like it was full of
fire ants crawling and biting it felt like his
body was full of fire ants he needed to take the
suit off before it got any worse but he couldn't
the suit wouldn't come off he reached for the
cardboard mask and tried to tug it off his head
but it wouldn't budge he felt like he was tugging
at the skin of his own face he could suddenly feel
everything that brushed against the cardboard like
it was connected to his nerve endings the fear and
the Panic got worse and he kept screaming it was a
deafening ear splitting screen he didn't know
it but anything electrical within a 200 meter
radius was dying TVs shut off radios fizzled out
cars stopped running nobody who didn't work for
the SCP Foundation would ever know why it wasn't
even 3 30 PM but the sky above looked black and
Max was afraid but all he could do was cling to
the familiar he lunged forwards and grabbed Johnny
pulling him into his trembling Embrace is he
still Max now no he doesn't think so anymore he's
something else entirely has he held his friend
Max tried to dig his fingers into the mask and
tear it off they pierced through the cardboard
tearing holes into it it was agonizing but the
masks stayed put there was no Escape he closed his
eyes just for a moment maybe it was a bad dream
maybe he could make it disappear but it didn't
disappear only he did Max was no more there was
only the tunnel monster when Johnny woke up he was
disoriented and afraid he was in complete darkness
but he could feel the old metal of a rusty
railroad track beneath his feet he didn't remember
how he got there and he didn't remember Max either
not his face or even his name but that's all right
Max didn't remember him either when the terrified
Johnny eventually found his way out of the old
railway tunnel he'd somehow found himself
in he was rescued by emergency services and
treated for dehydration because of the incredibly
strange circumstances of his disappearance and
reappearance over 4 000 kilometers away it was
only natural for the SCP Foundation to check in
but seeing as Johnny had no memory of where he
was or who he was with prior to his mysterious
teleportation all they ever did was investigate
the tunnel he'd appear in of course they didn't
find a thing the case was closed shortly
afterwards written off as a kind of one-off
spatial anomaly Johnny was given amnesic treatment
and reintegrated back into his normal life he
would never remember his encounter with the tunnel
monster but many would for decades and decades to
come there would be stories and Scattered
witness accounts from all kinds of people
maintenance workers doing electrical repairs on
subway tunnels sewer workers cleaning up block
packages in pipes Road workers fixing the asphalt
and underpasses the challenge with being an SCP
Foundation field agent is often separating the
genuine leads from the urban legends and spooky
stories but the details here were all too similar
and specific after all it would be such a strange
thing to make up a moldy old pile of cardboard
boxes getting up and running towards you but
stranger still these incidents and encounters were
occurring all over the United States with the only
commonalities being that all of them happened in
tunnels or tunnel-like structures the foundation
didn't know if they were dealing with one entity
or many another peculiar Factor they observed was
that sometimes people who had encounters with the
tunnel monster then themselves appear in tunnels
extremely far away from the ones in which they
first encountered it as far as the foundation was
aware besides transporting them vast distances
it never actually harmed any of its Victor
but according to one Boston sewer worker Gus
segrelia when the tunnel monster laid its
cardboard hand on him he felt the most profound
sense of paranoia and Dread he described it as
feeling like a thousand eyes in the dark watching
you die then he blinked and he woke up in an
Arizona Viaduct roughly six hours later everyone
who reported a similar experience with the tunnel
monster was detained debriefed and given amnestics
by the foundation eventually they gathered enough
data on prior encounters to accurately predict
the next tunnel that the tunnel monster would
manifest inside a new mobile task force was formed
to secure the creature MTF new four also known as
the box cutters what they didn't expect was that
when they finally engaged the Beast was that it
was no larger than a human child it wasn't some
huge tunnel dwelling nightmare even after all
these decades the tunnel monster was little more
than a frightened lonely little boy he growled
attempt and failing to come off as intimidating to
these hardcore MTF members and referred to himself
as the tunnel monster when they didn't react
with fear and surprise like the others he became
subdued they were able to peacefully apprehend
him and take him back to site 54 for testing
and containment preliminary x-rays found that the
cardboard costume hadn't just fused with the boy
it had completely transformed him on the inside
he was filled with crude cardboard copies of all
the major internal organs with his blood vessels
and nerve endings made out of colored pieces of
string they couldn't find any information on who
the boy was if he had ever been a boy at all and
he was given the designation scp-3663 in order
to find out more one of the leading researchers
on the scp-3663 case researcher Doyle decided to
conduct an interview with the tunnel monster it
had been the only interview with the creature to
date due to the emotional distress it caused the
creature when asked about about its identity
it replied with only the tunnel monster when
asked why it attacked and teleported people
to different locations the creature replied
the tunnel monster captures people that's me
I'm the tunnel monster I capture people and
take them into the tunnels where I live in the
tunnels the pipes I'm the tunnel monster has
the interview progressed the tunnel monster became
increasingly upset until it began weeping through
its cardboard face finally culminating with its
crying out between sobs please I don't want to
play anymore scp-3663 only feels comfortable in
tunnels and will teleport away in distress if
confined anywhere else as such its containment
chamber is technically the maintenance tunnels
underneath site 54 Where it seems to have made
a home for itself occasionally if it experiences
fear damage or stress it may de-manifest and
appear in tunnels elsewhere at that point the
box cutters are deployed to collect 36 60 E3 once
again and bring him back to site 54. so far there
has only been one major Containment Breach with
scp-3663 but it was a little more deadly than you
might expect for a boy-sized creature made of
cardboard the tunnel monster escaped from the
site-54 tunnels and began wailing in pain it went
positively berserk attacking surrounding staff
and trashing parts of the facility anyone who
heard the whales of the tunnel monster reported
becoming extremely psychologically disturbed by
them during this four hour Rampage the monster
also tried multiple times to destroy itself with
various implements but was unsuccessful after
scp-3663 was recontained two deceased members of
personnel were recovered from the scene autopsies
showed the cause of death was a buildup of
paper residue and wood pulp in all of their
major blood vessels as well as sinuses ear tubes
and the majority of the digestive and respiratory
systems a number of other staff members were found
to have been affected to a lesser degree but are
expected to make full recoveries what triggered
this explosive and deadly Outburst not even the
tunnel monster itself knew the answer to this
question but we do at exactly the same time a
79 year old man passed away from natural causes
after what seemed like a thoroughly unremarkable
life that man's name was Johnny a man is sitting
in a chair inside a containment cell at the SCP
Foundation the man is dressed normally and he
isn't trying to escape or attack the researchers
who are observing him the only thing that makes
this man different from you or I is that he ages
right in front of us going from a teenager to an
old man in a matter of minutes at first glance
scp-1007 looks very normal just a corpse lying in
a standard coffin well the corpse of an old man in
a coffin being kept locked up in a containment
chamber is normal when compared to some of the
other strange anomalies that that are found
in the SCP foundation's archives inside the
coffin with scp-1007 is a small Metal Key and
this is quite literally the key to seeing what
makes this anomaly so special on scp-1007's back
between his shoulder blades is a small Keyhole
x-ray scans of 1007 have shown that the keyhole is
just an empty socket it's unconnected to anything
there's no internal Clockwork mechanisms or other
Machinery that should be able to be activated by a
key when the metal key that is kept in scp-1007's
coffin classified as scp-1007-1 is inserted into
the keyhole on 1007's back in turn something
truly incredible happens as the key is turned
scp-1007 undergoes a change unlike anything the
SCP Foundation has seen before with each turn of
the key the subject's physical age is reversed by
one full year Foundation researchers are able to
watch 1007 age in Reverse in real time even any
Decay that had set in on the corpse is completely
reversed and disappears as the key is wound in one
zero zero seven gets younger and younger as the
key is turned 1007 will continue to DH physically
compacting and shrinking down until it appears
to have the form of a newborn human child it's
unknown where the physical mass of 1007's body
goes to since this should defy the laws of physics
but those laws we assume to be a Bedrock of our
universe's reality are often more of a suggestion
when it comes to anomalies the SCP Foundation
deals with Once scp-1007 reaches the newborn baby
stage it will suddenly reactivate coming to life
immediately regardless of how long it has been
dead and lying in its coffin once 1007 is brought
back to life he will go through the entire human
life cycle within a 75 minute period experiencing
what looks to be approximately one year of normal
human growth and development for every minute that
passes that means that in the course of about
16 minutes researchers will see scp-1007 change
from a crying infant to a fully grown teenager as
you can imagine the subject has reported feeling
excruciating pain during these first few minutes
as his bones rapidly lengthen and expand and his
muscles develop and change shape dramatically
scp-1007 is able to watch with his young eyes
as his bones move and set themselves into place
lengthening and widening in seconds during growth
spurts that normally take months or years after
about five minutes provided his legs have grown
to the same length at the same time he's usually
able to prop himself up and stand at around 10
minutes the pain really starts the bones crack
and ache as they grow at their fastest for the
whole cycle hair will also grow on his face and
body and he can't help but feel some amount of
Shame and embarrassment at what's happening to
him in front of the foundation researchers who
are taking copious notes by 20 minutes he can
hardly think due to the pain at this point he
usually lies down and curls into a ball whispering
to himself that it will all be over soon that the
pain won't last forever after another 10 minutes
he's right the pain is almost stopped completely
by the 30-minute mark But now as wrinkles and
stretch marks start to set in a different kind
of pain reveals itself as scp-1007 realizes that
he must watch himself die 40 minutes in and he
starts to reflect on his past the life he was
forced to lead as a kind of Sideshow freak more
on that later though the physical Decay happens
faster now warts and moles and other marks of age
appearing on his skin after 50 minutes he is aware
that over half of his life has passed and he is
reaching the end his hair starts to fall out as do
his teeth which he's never actually been able to
use as he's never tasted food as the 60-minute
mark comes and goes he begins to feel grateful
for the coming end with the escape from Pain and
the rest it would bring his body has become very
wrinkled by this point and is covered with age
spots his eyes begin to Cloud severely limiting
his ability to see and his hearing gets weaker
and weaker until he can't comprehend anything
the researchers say at 75 minutes it's all over
scp-1007's body expires and he dies once again
he will remain as a corpse until the metal key
is inserted into his back and the whole process
starts once again just as there appears to be
no explanation for where the mass of scp-1007's
body goes as the key is wound during the reversal
process so too is there no explanation for where
the energy needed for his rapid growth comes
from this process should violate the first law
of thermodynamics and Foundation researchers are
very curious about the underlying process the one
constant that remains on scp-1007's body is a
small tattoo on his right calf where the words
Mr life and Mr death from Little misters by Dr
wondertainment appear this matches up with entry
number 11 on document scp-909 which lists
a total of 20 little misters scp-1007 was
recovered by task force Tau 6 during a raid on
a mansion in California along with several other
anomalous creatures and objects the owner of the
Mansion claimed that he acquired scp-1007 at an
auction hosted by Marshall Carter and dark Limited
Marshall Carter and dark limited is a club based
in London England that is famed for collecting
and selling what it would describe as rare and
obscure objects unfortunately this often includes
various anomalies that should be under the care of
the SCP Foundation and the club's mission to
provide its members with exclusive expensive
and rare experiences means that they're often in
conflict with the foundation and they have even
been responsible for several containment breaches
Marshall Carter and dark limited continues to be
a very secretive organization and the name of
the director and a list of its members have so
far been very difficult to obtain at the auction
they hosted where scp-1007 was offered for sale
there were apparently along with Mr life and
death at least four other misters for sale
though the identity of the other buyers and which
little misters they may have purchased is still
under investigation the fact that scp-1007 has the
name Mr life and Mr death seems to imply that he
may have originally been part of a set though this
counterpart little Mister has yet to be recovered
or even identified in interviews with scp-1007 he
has given his own personal theory that he embodies
both names and the designation is a reference
to the way he alternates between life and death
however the possibility Still Remains though that
he may have a twin of sorts and the foundation
continues to investigate its possible identity
and location scp-1007's brief 75-minute life
followed by a death that lasts until he
is rewound by a special key means that he
is easily contained and has been classified as
safe he is only to be activated during routine
testing and After experiencing death he is to
be placed back into his coffin along with the
key in keeping with current regulations for all
anomalies that have been designated as misters
scp-1007 is to be contained in Hall 8 of
site 13 for additional observation and study
some of the anomalies the SCP Foundation deals
with are dangerous with the most powerful able
to end all life and even reality as we know it
others pose no threat at all and seem content
to Simply exist still others are something
else entirely scp-49999 is a humanoid entity
though its appearance seems to fluctuate between
manifestations with the only unchanging detail
being that it always is dressed in dark Formal
Wear originally thought by many to be an urban
legend local Tales of scp-4999 are what initially
tipped the foundation off to its existence and
further Research indicates that there are accounts
that may be referring to the appearances of 49.99
throughout recorded history strangest of
all though is the consistency with which
it appears or rather the consistent situations
and types of people it appears to from the data
available it seems that scp-4999 only appears
to people in a very specific type of need as
you'll see in the case of a subject named Alex
hiriford and the Fateful Knight he experienced
the road was slippery and Alex was driving too
fast he knew this of course but it's a different
matter altogether to know a thing and to and
to care about it rain hammered on the front
windshield the weak headlights of his 2005 Honda
Civic barely punching into the thick black knight
ahead of him winding through the Mountainside
the road was mostly empty saved for the very
occasional twin beams of light blazing past him
due to his high speed it was hard to hear the
honking of angry horns over the heavy pounding of
the rain then it happened in a way Alex knew it
was inevitable his tread worn Wheels finally lost
contact with the ground thick layer of rain water
between them and asphalt betraying his speeding
Vehicles grip on the road and sending it careening
out of control he had expected fear but instead
felt nothing really a slight sense of anticipation
like wincing right before a punch lands in that
childhood game of hitting each other on the arm it
wasn't that the world had slowed down but perhaps
his brain was simply working at a much greater
velocity now recognizing its own impending
death his speed of thought seemed magnified
to the point of slowing his perception down he
heard of soldiers in war zones experiencing the
same phenomenon as they felt sure that in the next
few seconds they'd be dead Alex Wonder would he
smash into a tree go off a Cliff's Edge you could
hardly see the forest or the terrain Beyond in the
thick rain in the dark of the mountain though he
traveled this road a million times before he had
no idea where he actually was tonight he supposed
it wouldn't really matter which it was as usual
his thoughts turned to her or rather they had
simply run their course and return to the one
place they always did it wasn't like there were
many other people to think about in Alex's mostly
empty life there was and always had been since
the moment he'd met her mostly just her but even
Alex's heightened State of Mind couldn't delay
the inevitable for long it would be a cliff after
all Alex thought curiously catching a glimpse of
town lights far away and below the correspond 180
degrees out into empty air Then Came Crashing
Down with a horror Roar of shattered glass and
tearing metal as it tumbled down the hillside even
over the torrential downpour the noise of Alex's
crash was significant had anyone been around to
hear it finally after over a hundred feet down
a steep incline the car smashed into a single
thick oak tree bringing the disaster to an end
as if On Cue the rain began to let up slowly at
first then all of a sudden in that peculiar way
that Northwest torrential downpours tend to do as
if the sky had at last finished emptying itself
all at once inside the shattered vehicle Alex was
incredibly alive at least for the time being the
airbag deployment had spared his face the worst
of it and the sturdy aluminum frame of the vehicle
had given its all in protecting Alex's body from
the downhill crash but even post-modern vehicle
engineering had its limits his breath came in
slow ragged gasps difficult at first but gradually
steady not an Improvement in his condition but
rather his body dedicating the rapidly dwindling
resources at its disposal into keeping vital
functions going as long as possible opening his
eyes Alex was surprised to find himself right side
up less surprised to look down at the shattered
mess his Limbs and lower body had become gradually
Alex's thoughts clear his sense of self returning
after the bone jarring dropped down the Steep
incline and sudden stop at the end looking to
his right he could see the trunk of the tree that
had stopped his out-of-control Temple despite
himself Alex laugh a weak gurgling chuckle so
it was the cliff and a tree after all he focused
on breathing letting the waves of pain wash over
him until his brain eventually canceled them out
by injecting his broken body with adrenaline and
chemicals everything was quiet and still after the
crash and the rain but to his surprise he could
hear something it was faint at first just a soft
crunch of footsteps on grab but the sound grew
louder and louder until at last it came to a stop
outside Alex's window with every ounce of effort
Alex turned his head towards the sound a rescuer
now impossible nobody was up on this mountain
and nobody could possibly have reached him here
so quickly even if there had been he supposed
he should have been surprised yet almost from
the moment that his eyes fell on the tall handsome
figure with the Casual yet fashionably cut black
suit Alex accepted him for what he was there was
no shock no confusion for the second time tonight
just a calm sense of acceptance the man probably
somewhere in his mid-30s leaned down to peer in
through the window he said nothing as he casually
observed the extent of Alex's injuries satisfied
he laid a hand on Alex's shoulder the grip was
firm but not painfully so just strong enough
to communicate I am here with you things will
be all right after a slight squeeze the figure
reached inside his jacket and produced a pack of
cigarettes packing the tobacco with swift Taps
against his palm before removing two cigarettes
and offering one to Alex Alex nodded his head a
very small motion that exploded pain across his
shattered body now thank you but that stuff will
kill you Alex smiled the man paused for a moment
the ghost of a smile showing on his face for just
a moment before disappearing returning the offered
cigarette the man took his own and lit it giving
Alex a good look at his face in the light of his
cigarette lighter Alex had been right the man
appeared to be somewhere in his mid to late 30s
handsome but not cover model so just pleasing to
the eyes he sported short hair carefully combed
and perfectly knee completely unaffected by the
slight drizzle that still fell the more Alex
looked at him though the less he could remember
about the man's exact features wasn't that they
changed in any way but rather that he simply
couldn't hold on to any details for more than a
few seconds I'm dying aren't I the figure didn't
speak nor did it not or make any form of verbal
or bodily communication he simply looked and Alex
understood Alex had never been particularly
religious or spiritual but in that look he
understood that there was a world Beyond and will
very quickly be entering into it was as if for the
first time in his life he was able to probe that
world reality peeling away just enough to Glimpse
what was beyond twisting paths through planes of
Shadow and light both shuffling figures along each
and at the very center of it all a light now
a feeling love pulsing forth like the Beating
Heart of it all the saints had their Angels the
wicked their demons but everyone else in between
the two they had him a guide someone to watch over
them on their final Journey Alex coughed it was
ending soon the man took a drag from his cigarette
and removed the handkerchief from another hidden
Pocket carefully dabbing away the blood around
Alex's chin then returned to his silent smoking
his vision was beginning to dim around the edges
the noises of the forest growing more and more
distant Alex knew it wouldn't be long now but he
had just one final thing to do as he always knew
they would his thoughts returned to her here at
the end once more he turned his head towards the
passenger side sea pain exploding across his body
with the motion there just on the far edge of the
seat as his phone having miraculously survived the
crash it was no good though even if he'd been able
to move his shattered right arm he could never
reach it with his fading strength the smoking
man took one final pull of his cigarette putting
it out on the side of the vehicle and pocketing
the stump then he reached through the broken
driver's side window Alex catching a slight whiff
of cigarette smoke blended with an unrecognizable
but Pleasant cologne the man reached across Alex
and grabbed the phone pulling back and looking
down at Alex's shattered right hand after a moment
he reached down once more and put the phone in
Alex's left hand thank you the words were barely
a whisper he had to concentrate now willing the
pressing Darkness to part just long enough for
one final task the man once more placed his hand
reassuring Lee on Alex's shoulder and the Darkness
parted slightly just enough for what Alex needed
to do he worked the phone awkwardly with his left
hand gritting his teeth through the pain of broken
fingers opening a new message he scrolled down his
contacts G H I J finally K he found her name at
last then began typing out a message I still think
about you every time it rains he moved his thumb
to press send but that's when Alex's body failed
him at last the phone tumbling out of his cross
but the man was there to catch it moving blindly
fast he snatched the falling phone up and held it
carefully to Alex's eyes before pressing send he
held the phone there for Alex to see through
his fading Vision until at last message sent
confirmed successful delivery the rain began once
more temperamental as it always is in the Pacific
Northwest fat heavy raindrops fell on the scene
of a terrible the victims seemingly having died on
impact on his lap thou lay his phone and somewhere
far away and Far Below this dark Mountainside a
message notification chirped on a distant phone
scp-4999 manifests to only one person at a time
and only when they are alone all subjects to
date have been in the final stages of a terminal
illness suffering from a life-threatening
injury or otherwise on their deathbed it
also appears that all subjects have personalities
and lives that could be described as non-descript
insignificant or otherwise unremarkable no testing
of scp-49999 has been authorized by the foundation
due to both the difficulty in predicting where it
will appear as well as the fact that observation
seems to prevent the anomaly from appearing
there are also ethical concerns since many in
the foundation feel that scp-4999 is providing
an important service to humanity even if it is
only for those on the margins of society and it
is debated whether this should be one anomalous
creature that is allowed to continue its existence
and its work without interference it goes without
saying that the SCP Foundation archives are
filled with some terrifying monsters even the
deadliest creatures can in theory be defeated
or at least soundly avoided after all they're
just flesh and blood or in some cases metal or
concrete but what if reality as you know it one
day just broke or worse you were transported
to a reality so frightening and alien to our
own that death seemed like the only Escape but you
couldn't even give yourself that this brings us to
today's topic the terrifying alternate reality of
scp-3001 the foundation is no stranger to freaky
alternate Dimensions but what was experienced
by joint lead researcher Dr Robert Scranton at
site 120 is a truly unique nightmare co-managed
by his wife Dr Anna Lang site 120 is a facility
largely designated for Research into scps with
dangerous reality warping capabilities in order
to mitigate future containment breaches reality
warpers are among some of the more perplexing and
dangerous scps from the pocket Dimension creating
scp-106 to the SCP creating Dr wondertainment and
everything in between Scranton and Lang's
goal to further study such entities was an
admirable one if a little over ambitious and
on January 2nd 2000 during the testing of a
new technology created by the foundation's
leading power couple disaster finally struck
Scranton and Lang had already been the brains
behind one of the foundation's most valuable tools
in the fight against reality bending scps the
Scranton reality anchors their follow-up the Lang
Scranton stabilizer or LSS likely would have been
an even more advanced variant of their earlier
invention and should have been a huge success
for the team but things didn't turn out that
way Dr Scranton and several other researchers were
gathered in reality lab a performing routine tests
on the LSS prototypes while other technicians ran
Diagnostics tests Scranton stood at the control
panel the blinking red light above the console
confirming that everything was going according to
plan but as anyone who's Fallen victim to one of
the foundation's many anomalies will tell you just
because you've done everything correctly doesn't
mean you're safe Scranton began operating the
machine not knowing that something was rumbling
up towards him from below without warning a sudden
unexpected burst of seismic activity rocked the
entire base researchers grabbed on to whatever
was closest as the world shook around them in this
Panic Dr Scranton clung to the LSS control panel
as the seismic blast fried the circuits and kicked
it into overdrive there was a blast of magnificent
blinding light and when the rumbling stopped Not
only was the doctor gone he had been erased from
reality as we know it the earthquake had caused
a deadly malfunction in the machine meant to
stabilize reality and instead tore a rift in it
dragging the unfortunate doctor and the control
panel into Oblivion his wife Dr Lang and the many
researchers who idolized him were devastated by
his unexpected demise at the hand of what should
have been his crowning achievement the one silver
lining was that this reality ripping event had
almost definitely eliminated the doctor quickly
and painlessly as far as the foundation and his
loved ones were concerned Scranton's death had
been immediate and complete a luxury afforded to
few Foundation employees who die anomalous deaths
but sadly that isn't how Dr Scranton's story or
the story of scp-3001 ends no this is where it
all begins how do we know all this in the hellish
new place where Scranton had been transported the
control panel from the LSS that he'd been clinging
to for dear life had been transported with him and
continued to record audio data from this anomalous
location not that Dr Scranton realized it not at
first anyway as far as he knew he'd suddenly
been transported into a pitch black location
no sights no sounds no sound true nothingness at
first the doctor was confused one second he was
testing out his new technology and the next he was
quite literally nowhere in spite of his current
situation the doctor was still an intelligent and
rational man he took a moment to compose himself
hoping that in time his eyes would adjust to the
new Darkness around him but that moment never came
the darkness remained perfectly absolute much
like the darkness in another reality-defying SCP
the deadly endless staircase known as scp-087 the
dark seemed thick almost like you could touch it
the doctor not wanting to give himself to Despair
and die in this impossible place and with no other
options seemingly available began walking either
he'd find his way out or the foundation would
find him no need to panic it may have altered
the doctor's temperament if he knew that the
foundation already assumed he was dead and that
no search party was going to come looking for him
still logic dictates that if a person walks for
long enough they're bound to find something the
problem Scranton was about to face was
that scp-3001 doesn't run by any kind of
conventional logic he walked and walked and
walked but he didn't seem to get any nearer
to or farther from anything but how could he even
know after all in total darkness there aren't any
landmarks to assist in navigation the doctor
walked and paced and screamed for days on end
but he made no progress he was alone in an empty
world he had no choice though so he kept walking
and walking and walking for 11 days during that
time he felt his hunger and thirst grow he was
in terrible pain from a mix of starvation and
dehydration but the release of death didn't seem
to come for him he was going to have to learn the
rules of this new place the hard way and it grimly
dawned on Dr Scranton dying in this place might
not even be the worst possible outcome he paced
and repeated facts to himself hoping to ground
himself in the moment and avoid the Panic that
could so easily set in name Robert Scranton age
39 birthday September 19 1961 favorite color blue
favorite song Living on a Prayer wife Anna little
by little the words seem to turn to nonsense in
his mouth as the terror grew just as he felt
like he was about to lose his mind he noticed
something a small Oasis in the endless darkness
of scp-3001 the glowing red light on the LSS
control panel where had it come from and how was
it still recording the doctor had no idea but he
was grateful for any kind of familiarity in this
strange Darkness around him perhaps the LSS could
be the key to saving him or at least figuring out
what on Earth was going on here whatever the case
there was no denying that having the panel here
was better than nothing at least when it was
found if it was ever found then people would know
what had happened to him as the days passed and he
continued to mysteriously survive Dr Scranton
deduced that one didn't need food or water to
survive continually in scp-3001 the location
had an anomalous effect on its inhabitants
as the days passed and turned to weeks
of wandering in the darkness Dr Scranton
further deduced that he was no longer in his home
Dimension this was an entirely separate pocket
Dimension much like the one possessed by scp-106
but featureless a perfect self-contained void
now dimly illuminated by the red light of the
panel Dr Scranton explored further into the void
around him he traveled for months on end the pain
of his deficiencies growing by the day but found
he was getting nowhere All Things Considered he
wasn't even sure he was moving or whether reality
and darkness were swirling around him like a
thick liquid rather than walking on a single flat
surface he was moving in all directions across a
three-dimensional plane the space-time Continuum
appeared to be entirely broken here where movement
is more defined by the conscious intention to move
than any real geographical repositioning Dr
Scranton knew that this place broke every
single one of cajel's laws of reality parameters
and from his years working with a plethora of
reality warpers in sight 120 he had a theory for
why this pocket Dimension was so strange it had an
extraordinarily weak Hume field before we get back
to Dr Scranton's semi-living nightmare we need a
quick primer on Hume Theory and why having a weak
Hume field is such a problem a Hume is a unit of
measurement for the strength and amount of reality
in a given location or being in an area with an
incredibly low Hume field relative to our world
such as scp-3001 Universe breaches and anomalous
incidents rise significantly at the time is being
trapped there scp-3001 had the lowest number
of Humes in any recorded environment making it a
phenomenally anomalous Zone it was for this reason
that starvation and dehydration never took hold of
him despite causing him great pain and the worst
by far was Yet to Come Dr Scranton wasn't trapped
in this dimension for weeks or even months he was
trapped in the darkness for years and it took a
nightmarish toll on his body and mind the small
flashing red light on his LSS control panel became
his only friend and as the years Drew on he would
hold entire conversations with his only source of
Illumination he knew that his days were numbered
if he didn't escape the dimension within around
three years the Hume field would defuse further
and he would be left in a truly horrific state
but based on how little Headway he'd made in the
time he'd been there he didn't feel optimistic he
kept speaking into the recorder if only to break
the silence and prevent him from going completely
insane but even that would only hold it off for
so long alone and talking to himself endlessly
in the darkness Dr Scranton could feel his mind
slipping as the confines of the pocket Dimension
constricted and his body began to change the low
Hume field slowly diffused his physical matter
destroying the physical Integrity of his body
but never being merciful enough to actually let
him die in his haunting audio logs the doctor
described his hands as diffusing and thinning
out like spider webs over time there was less
and less of him and what was left wasn't entirely
human as Scranton's Hume level lowered to equalize
with that of scp-3001 the lines between his body
and the LSS control console began to blur in a
Twisted marriage of warped flesh and machine
the Lang Scranton stabilizer was anything but
stable before his mind and body became something
else entirely the doctor still had the presence
of mind to finally realize how he'd come to be in
this terrible place the LSS had opened a wormhole
known as a Class C broken entry into a paradoxical
pocket Dimension between layers of reality and
taken him through it he'd slipped through a crack
in reality into absolute darkness and now he was
stuck with a fate far worse than death how do
we know any of this much like the event in the
first place it's a total accident testing Superior
reality bending technology almost six years after
The Disappearance caused the sudden Return of the
missing LSS to site-120's reality labs the only
trace of Dr Scranton that it brought back with it
was the blood and viscera that coded the console
much to the abject horror of his still-grieving
wife Dr Anna Lang to this day Dr Scranton formerly
one of the foundation's brightest Minds remains
trapped in the nightmare of scp-3001. his current
condition whether the doctor is still alive after
20 years of being warped by the low Hume field of
3001's dark and confines is still unknown but for
the doctor's own sake we hope he's been dead for
quite some time because few things on Earth are
as horrifying as the alternative in the office
of SCP Foundation researcher yoshihiro takanaka
there sits a small containment capsule filled
with Ash all that's left of a neutralized
scp-1762 these ashes don't pose any harm
they won't bite burn or assume control of your
mind but few can hear the sad story of scp-1762
and not be haunted by its tragic and mysterious
tale it weighs heavily on the hearts and minds
of all who came into contact with it during its
ultimately brief time in the foundation's hands
and to think it all started with a simple
little box with an even simpler message
here be dragons the box to look at it was
really nothing special a simple cardboard box
32 centimeters by 20 centimeters by 26 centimeters
spray painted silver inside and out short message
scrawled across the lid in Black permanent marker
it appeared on the doorstep of foundation agent
Scott Thomas who after determining it wasn't a
bomb Anthrax or a deadlier kind of anomaly turned
it into his superiors that's when it became
yoshihiro takanaka's Little Pet Project SAFE
class scps are rare treats for any overworked
Foundation scientists the Box itself known as
scp-1762-1 is certainly important but what's
really interesting is what resides within the Box
if you'd open the box yourself you'd find that
it's empty however when the Box chooses to open
itself it's an entirely different story The Box
would sometimes open and emit great plumes of
thick black smoke that would quickly dissipate
around 20 seconds after this an scp-1762-2 would
emerge from the darkness of the box 1762-2 is
the collective names given to all the beings
that exit 1762-1 which are as you may have guessed
dragons eastern western big small and presenting
in a rainbow of colors these dragons appear
to be living origami sculptures made from Kami
paper and have been known to fly together in large
groups and interact playfully with nearby humans
these little paper dragons would then swoop around
their containment chamber delighting all who were
fortunate enough to see them for up to three hours
at which point smoke would begin pulling out of
the box once more and the dragons would return
home they'd fly through the smoke disappearing
past the rim of the box and then the lid would
close once more the dates on which the box would
open were seemingly random and indeterminable
and didn't appear to work by any kind of external
logic and what's more the box would sometimes act
as a hub of communication between this world and
another known simply as fantasy messages written
or carved into various materials would appear
on the lid of the Box mostly after instances of
1762-2 emerging this communication though would
always be one way attempts to pass messages back
through the box never resulted in success the
foundation staff could only be observers of the
Strange World of fantasy never active participants
so why is this particular SCP considered so
tragic we're going to answer that question
right now but just know that what is learned
cannot be unlearned as much as you might wish
you could forget if you're ready then it's time
to learn about a period of time that lasted just
under a year during which a strange and sad series
of events took place now known as the Jabberwocky
event an event that took hereby dragons from
safe to neutralize you've seen that scp-1762
would communicate with Foundation staff via
written messages after each instance of the
box opening the very first message the Box gave up
after arriving at the sight red you have found us
thank you it has been so long since we last saw
each other friends the piece has been upheld the
Giants and Behemoth have kept their word and have
not caused any trouble since you last came and
gave the order we missed your company how has
your family been do you know how to work your
room you're welcome to visit anytime later it gave
another message expressing confusion and concern
on behalf of fantasy's inhabitants it's strange
to see how much your world has changed it is even
stranger to see how we now appear in this place in
fantasy we are much bigger or maybe you've grown
taller fantasy is still the same we hope you can
visit us like you used to though our room is as
Grand as ever it appears yours has shrunken we
do not understand the rooms were supposed to be
maintained as was our agreement please restore the
belief things got worse during the next stage of
the event the Box opened and only 20 Paper Dragons
exited this time though they did not fly and
instead walked slowly across the ground this was
the message that accompanied this sorry parade of
dragons friends we apologize for a few numbers we
have had to remain in fantasy for quite some time
the others are growing patient we are trying to
keep the peace but please for all of our happiness
repair the room quickly we know you are trying
your family is the most imaginative of us all
naturally Foundation scientists were concerned
they weren't sure what exactly the messages
were referring to or how they could possibly help
the inhabitants of fantasy of course things only
got worse only 10 dragons appeared the next
time along with a few balls of crumpled up
construction paper That Shook violently
before stopping all movement entirely
this message accompanied it the Giants were
foolish your room was not ready to accept them yet
we're sorry friends we hope that we can still see
you but time is growing short for our happiness
and sadly this message spoke the truth as the
next time the Box opened only five dragons exited
they were carrying the following message and flew
straight back into the box after depositing It On
The Ground dungeons are rising fantasy is becoming
darker we the serpents and the hybrids are
furiously trying to hold them back but the Giants
and elves wish to strike and make an entrance
they say that your family has grown stupid and
ignorant we hope this is untrue it would send us
all greatly to know that you have forgotten it
seemed clear that fantasy was speeding towards
some kind of terrible conflict and it was perhaps
too late to do anything about it the next attempt
at communication came from a single dragon with a
crumpled wounded body collapsed to the ground and
appeared to die its body unfolding into a small
piece of paper that brore a single heartbreaking
message [__] goodbye friends but two hours after
this message was delivered something happened the
lid opened again only this time the Box let out a
huge jet of white hot flame reaching temperatures
of 1700 degrees Celsius the terrified and Confused
researchers heard roaring and the sounds of an
intense battle from within the darkness of the
Box many of the observing staff found themselves
overcome with emotion afraid that they were
perhaps witnessing the death of fantasy play
out in front of them an even hardened Foundation
researchers and guards were moved by the event
at 8pm that night the Box ejected a huge quality
of paper the majority of it was either torn burnt
shredded or crumpled into balls and all instances
of 1762-2 were announced deceased upon official
examination it seemed that fantasy's Bloody War
truly was taking its toll and even the forces of
the foundation one of the most powerful and
resourceful groups the world has ever known
powerless to do anything to help all they could
do was sit wait and see what the result would be
of this paper-crafted war the Box continued to
open and close sporadically over the next six
weeks as the war raged on it would often emit more
spouts of deadly fire and vomit out more piles of
ruined paper the researchers noticed that each
time it released less and less paper even more
disturbing matter resembling muscle and tissue was
ejected from the box with increased frequency it
was clear that whatever was left of fantasy was in
great Peril and the researchers were desperate to
know what was going on but the box would remain
closed and inactive for the next seven months
when the Box did finally become active once
more it wasn't in a way that the researchers
were familiar with the Box opened but not a
single Dragon accident not even a crumbled piece
of paper came out instead researchers found what
appeared to be an ancient and desiccated Scroll of
parchment the words written on it were smudged and
some were stained with blood it made clear that
things had fallen further into darkness than they
had ever before the message read are you still out
there friends we miss you dearly fantasy is no
longer safe our Haven your beautiful creation
is gone the Giants are dead the centaurs are dead
the birds have fled we are going to bury your room
we cannot risk hurting you this is our goodbye
maybe one day your family can build another room
this may be a hollow hope but we will cherish this
thought an hour later the Box began to convulse
violently and let out more plumes of thick black
smoke for a moment the researchers entertain the
hope that it might be the return of the dragons
the no such luck the Vox began to Sag tear and
collapse as though it was on fire on the inside
parts of the Box began to char and small holes
were burned through the silver paint perhaps
the status of all the words here be Dragons
Were burned from the box not long after one more
message appeared Inside the Box it was a Papyrus
scroll depicting a hand-drawn image of a beautiful
mountainous landscape with huge trees and
waterfalls in the distance a dragon appears to fly
away for the last time a message written on the
back read as follows Master says that we won't see
you again we are sad so are the remaining others
we once filled each other's heads with dreams
and Gauls it is so sad that we cannot share them
any longer Master says we have to go he says that
he will make us a new fantasy he says you cannot
be a part of it we are sad we love you we will
not forget you we are scared will you forget us
when this document was removed streams
of salt water began to leak from the box
healing its burn scars a few minutes later the
box was returned to its original state save for
one big difference the tech scrawled on the lid no
longer red here be dragons now it said here were
dragons the Jabberwocky event was over the box
now neutralized with sit in yoshihiro takanaka's
office for commemorative purposes never to release
another message or so we thought in 2015 scp-1762
spoke to us one more time the Box Shook and
began emitting great plumes of purple smoke
before it fell to the ground there it ejected
two objects a purple Crystal later identified
as an amethyst and a large leather-bound book
The Box continued emitting smoke for another
40 minutes before finally disintegrating upon
further inspection there was a single message
carved into the amethyst one last time then what
about the book consider the greatest fear of the
inhabitants of fantasy that they would one day be
forgotten forgotten and left behind by us the book
was sent to help prevent that it's an extensive
catalog of the creatures of fantasy their strange
and wonderful ways and their strange and wonderful
world even if they're gone they won't be forgotten
and perhaps one day we'll tell you those stories
too but that's a tale for another day Joseph and
Frank were two lifelong squatchers no that isn't
an insult that's a self-given title for bigfoot
enthusiasts who are willing to head out into the
woods and search for the legendary Sasquatch first
hand while most Watchers will go their whole lives
without ever encountering one Joseph and Frank
were about to get lucky they just didn't know what
kind of luck during a journey through the forests
of the Pacific Northwest Frank spotted something
moving in the distance a huge ape-like creature
with grayish fur and human-like movements Frank
thought he was finally laying eyes on the mighty
Bigfoot after Decades of searching what he didn't
know was that he just made a deadly mistake he had
looked directly at scp-1000 and there would be
terrible consequences Frank was excited he just
achieved the life goal of any squatcher he tapped
Joseph on the shoulder and directed him to look
in the direction of the creature Joseph followed
Frank's Direction and stared into the distance
when his eyes finally came into focus on the ape
Beast he froze his brain just short-circuited one
second he was about to encounter the Holy Grail of
his Hobby and the next he was literally brain dead
Joseph collapsed in the distance the ape-like
creature disappeared back into the woods not
that Frank even noticed he was too busy trying to
wake Joseph but it was no use Joseph was gone and
Frank had no idea why the headlines read Bigfoot
killed my friend most people either ignored it
or laughed it off just a couple of cranks
goofing off in a forest and one of them had
dropped dead who cares well one organization
cared the SCP Foundation mobile task force
Zeta 1000 the foundation's specialized scp-1000
detail were alerted to the reports they sprang
into action tracking down and detaining Frank for
questioning they process a million Looney Bigfoot
lovers every year and usually find nothing
but the death of Frank's friend made it all
too clear they hadn't encountered a Bigfoot but a
real genuine example of scp-1000 scp-1000 rarely
ranks among the scariest or most dangerous scps
but underestimating the creature is a terrible
mistake because just looking at it gives you a
two percent chance of dropping dead on the spot
Frank despite losing his friend was one of the
lucky ones the foundation debriefed him before
administering amnestics and making sure that he'd
never Venture back into those mysterious forests
in the Pacific Northwest region director Jones
the site director charged with the management of
scp-1000 populations was given the information on
this latest case of an scp-1000 related fatality
it was a story he heard many times before for
director Jones they all seem to bleed into one
another so what exactly is scp-1000 and how did it
leave poor Joseph dead in the woods scp-1000 is a
whole species of large hominid ape-like creatures
they're largely nocturnal but sightings of the
creature during the day aren't unheard of they're
omnivorous mostly seeming to consume plants and
insects and their fur is usually gray brown brown
black red or occasionally White the creatures have
large eyes capable of impressive Vision nestled
underneath a pronounced neanderthal-like brow
another defining feature is the ridge of bone
on the forehead much like that of a gorilla
that is present in both sexes according to
Foundation studies the creatures exhibit a
level of Intelligence on par with that of the
common chimpanzee but nowhere near that of us
humans what they lack in intelligence though they
make up for in size the adults can be as large as
10 feet tall and weigh up to 600 pounds despite
their great size and impressive strength the
creatures are neither aggressive nor territorial
in fact they seem to instinctively avoid humans
mostly residing deep in the force of the American
Pacific Northwest and in the Himalayan Alps there
have been sightings of scp-1000 on every
continent though the foundation has taken
pains to exterminate all scp-1000 populations
situated near human population centers to prevent
a potential disaster considering the two percent
chance of instantaneous death upon visual contact
that brings us to to our second question what is
it that makes these seemingly harmless creatures
so dangerous sadly for both these unfortunate
creatures and US humans the danger is beyond
the control of scp-1000 according to Foundation
research scp-1000 likely evolved alongside us
Homo sapiens until a tragedy occurred between 10
and 15 000 years ago a mysterious Extinction event
eliminated the vast majority of their species
leaving only one to five percent alive in the
aftermath what happened it's believed that around
this time scp-1000 contracted what the foundation
refers to as an anomalous pseudo-disease meet
scp-1000 F1 a disease that is passed along at the
genetic level and is so durable that it persists
in the species to this day the tiny fraction of
the population that are immune to its effects
managed to survive but the majority who aren't
immune die shortly after birth this is why the
overall population remains relatively low to this
day it's a disease that only appears to affect
hominids including humans chimpanzees bonobos
and non-immune instances of scp-1000 any hominid
that lays eyes on a carrier of the disease has a
two percent chance of experiencing immediate brain
death while a two percent chance of instant death
may not seem all that threatening at least when
compared to some other nightmare-inducing scps
the truly scary part is that the percentage is
cumulative in other words the longer one observes
a carrier of scp-1000f1 the higher that percentage
Rises the greater your chance of experiencing an
Abrupt death according to Foundation studies the
percentage Rises by around one percent every 20
minutes and the percentage also varies between
specimens with some exhibiting a terrifyingly
high death chance of 90 upon viewing this death
chance continues to occur in dead specimens if
they carry the anomalous pseudovirus while alive
though thankfully the risk doesn't appear to apply
to small fur or tissue samples the foundation's
true concern actually goes far beyond scp-1000
themselves because of the species close relation
to Homo sapiens there's a worry that scp-1000f1
could transmit to humans causing our own
species to meet a similar or faith if humans
did indeed become carriers of scp-1000f1 it's
extremely likely that Humanity would undergo
an unprecedented Extinction event with billions
across the globe dropping dead as brain death sets
in on mass while full extermination of the entire
species has been deemed unlikely this existential
threat they pose to humanity more than justifies
the occasional culling of scp-1000 populations
that was a lot to take in right first the creature
we thought was Bigfoot was actually a new species
of SCP out in the wild and second these creatures
could end human life as we know it if they made it
into a population Center but what you're about to
hear next a dark secret only available to people
with level 3 SCP Foundation clearance is the
most shocking scp-1000 fact of all are you ready
the true secret of scp-1000 is that what you've
just heard is a lie there is no anomalous pseudo
disease and scp-1000 poses no pathogenic threat to
humanity whatsoever who would spread such a thing
the SCP Foundation of course strictly speaking
the foundation has disseminated two direct lies
about the nature of scp-1000 the first is that of
the disease which does not exist nor has it ever
existed the second lie is about the creature's
intelligence level they're far smarter than
the average Chimp in fact they're every bit as
intelligent as human beings these were all lies
formulated by director Jones and the foundation
as was the very existence of the Bigfoot myth
the foundation has been spreading information that
makes the very concept of the Sasquatch out to be
a joke for decades all to discredit and further
push the very concept of scp-1000 into the Shadows
but why the foundation is no stranger to
coming up with cover stories but why would
they put intentional lies into their own files
to anyone below a level 3 clearance well that
all comes down to the horrifying truth behind
the origins of today's scp-1000 population the
creatures were first brought to the attention of
the foundation by Outcast members of the Serpent's
hand an organization dedicated to Defying the
foundation's activities these members known as
The Children Of The Sun told them the secret
history of scp-1000 while at First Foundation
Personnel like director Jones didn't want to
believe what they were hearing they soon came
to terms with the horrifying truth humans and
scp-1000 did evolve alongside each other with
humans occupying the day and scp-1000 the
night however while humans were still basic
hunter-gatherers scp-1000 were undergoing vast
intellectual and societal development they were
able to create tools weapons agriculture
stable settlements domesticated animals
and event eventually even fully developed cities
it was like nothing the world had ever seen and
wouldn't see for thousands of years to come their
numbers swelled into the tens of billions as they
created culture and Technology hitherto unimagined
including weapons of devastating power meanwhile
Humanity was pushed to the brink of Destruction by
their competitors rapid and seemingly Unstoppable
growth it looked as though the human species had
lost the evolutionary arms race and would have to
bow out but according to the Children Of The Sun
a trickster Forest God smiled upon humanity and
gave them the power to use scp-1000's weapons
and Technology against them seventy percent
of scp-1000's population were wiped out in a
single horrific day known to the Children Of
The Sun as the day of the flowers as every flower
supposedly bloomed that day during the massacre
Humanity destroyed the entire civilization and
with the same technology they stole from these
unfortunate creatures the vengeful humans drove
the Apes mad their higher consciousnesses were
blocked out reducing them back into the states
of mere animals once the massacre was done and
everything that was built had been destroyed we
the human race used the scp-1000 weapons to wipe
any memory of the atrocity from our own minds the
advanced civilization of scp-1000 had been wiped
from history humans returned to their plotting
path of evolution none the wiser for thousands
of years all the way up until today this time
remained a mystery to us so again why did the
foundation lie to us what did they have to gain
by convincing us all that it was dangerous to even
look at these creatures while as the frequency
of sightings and the attempts of communication
increased people like director Jones became
aware of a frightening possibility what if the
pendulum was swinging back what if the Apes were
regaining their lost in intelligence and worse
still harbored feelings of Revenge for what we did
to their species thousands of years ago the mere
possibility that they could do to us what we once
did to them is a chance that the foundation simply
cannot take and thus limiting contact between
humans and scp-1000 at all costs is an absolute
must however in spite of the foundation's fears
one intercepted message from the Apes suggests
that their paranoia may be misplaced this message
translated from an attempt at communicating with
Foundation Personnel reads simply as follows we
forgive you given choice for now not forever let
us back in it's enough to make you wonder what
species the foundation should really be keeping
tabs on here after all when it comes to netting
out violence and death Humanity has a track record
to rival the worst creatures in the foundation
containment cells and few examples illustrate
that better than the tragic case of scp-1000
there's no doubt that the SCP Foundation has come
across some dangerous anomalies over the years if
you had to guess what would you say is the most
dangerous SCP they have in containment a lot of
people might immediately think of scp-682 the hard
to destroy reptile and perhaps they might be right
after all we're talking about a gigantic lizard
that can regenerate almost all forms of damage
and harbors a burning hatred for any and all other
forms of life then there's the various Eldritch
entities the foundation has come into contact with
beings that could easily rewrite all of reality
out of pure anger or just to torment us for their
own Amusement but the most dangerous SCP might
well be something completely unassuming instead
of a zombie producing plague doctor or an actual
plague of flesh-eating zombies imagine if there
was just a man one seemingly ordinary human man
nothing about him that looks unusual no mimetic
or anomalous superpower and yet one look at him
tells you that he's the most dangerous man you've
ever seen someone who should be locked up forever
for all the horrible things he's done welcome to
the story of Frasier melbrook the most dangerous
person also known as scp-3017 to anyone that knew
him Frasier was just an ordinary man although
at 25 years of age he had not exactly lived a
Charmed Life people would look at him and could
almost tell there was something unsavory about
Frasier's character it was as if one glance could
somehow tell you that he was trouble it was this
unshakable feeling that he gave people that led
to Frazier melbrook being arrested and arrested
and arrested some more over the course of his
adult life he was placed under arrest a total of
23 times Frazier was suspected of having committed
a number of different crimes ranging from robbery
and assault all the way up to accusations of
murder interestingly he was never formally
indicted for any of this judge crimes meaning
he was only ever arrested and held as a suspect
but never once was he confirmed to have been
guilty there was never any evidence nothing to
prove Beyond reasonable doubt that Frasier was in
fact a criminal instead every arrest boiled down
to the way he made people in his presence feel
unfortunately even though he was never proven to
be guilty or even capable of committing the crimes
he was accused of Frazier Mel Brooks multiple
arrests garnered him a notable criminal record and
soon drew the attention of the SCP Foundation when
he was transferred into Foundation containment
and designated as scp-3017 it was believed that
Frasier had some form of connection to a number of
groups of Interest these are various organizations
that the foundation monitors viewing them as
causes for concern and sometimes outright threats
this list includes the Church of the broken God a
cult of religious zealots that worship an entity
that that combines a number of scps as well as
the global occult Coalition a gunhow organization
policing the Paranormal that shares an uneasy
history with the foundation however no member
of staff could explain exactly why they thought
Frasier melbrook had any connection to these
groups there was no evidence that he was but still
they had a hunch and so testing began hours upon
hours of rigorous interviews and experimentation
trying to understand what it was that made people
want to keep this seemingly ordinary man locked
up after extensive research was conducted by
Foundation Personnel they were able to determine
why scp-3017 had been arrested so many times
before and what had drawn the foundation to him
in the first place Frasier melbrook was suffering
from a Cognito Hazard this was a condition that
did not so much have a direct adverse effect on
him but rather influenced those around him anyone
that stood close enough to scp-3017 or made an
attempt to engage him directly in conversation
even those that just looked at him all reacted
the same way Frazier gave people the overwhelming
belief that he needed to be placed in custody even
if he'd not sat or done anything to give them a
reason to anyone that looked at spoke to or even
stood near him became spontaneously aware that
scp-3017 was some sort of dangerous criminal the
Cognito Hazard didn't give people knowledge of
his exact crimes it more just made them believe
that Frasier had a violent disposition and that
he needed to be locked away any person staying
within the vicinity of scp-3017 for an hour
or longer would experience further effects of
Frasier's Cognito Hazard Beyond just knowing there
is something untowards about him those who spent
extended time around scp-3017 would actively try
to restrain him and then after an hour they would
exhibit violent Behavior towards him they would
start obsessively trying to ensure that he was
incarcerated almost like the thought of him being
free was so horrifying that they couldn't help but
try to arrest him themselves luckily these effects
of longer exposure to Frasier were not permanent
and often the subject's Tendencies to try to
restrain him could be cured through amnestics the
effects of Frasier Mel Brooks Cognito hazardous
conditions seemed to change relative to the amount
of time he remained incarcerated after continuous
exposure to scp-37 team the effects of his Cognito
Hazard would appear to fade meaning that those who
had previously been compelled to incarcerate him
would later become indifferent or even release him
freely this caused a problem for the foundation
and raised a very important question how do
you contain someone that you later feel the
urge to set free the answer was designated
as scp-3017-1 a list of individuals with a
connection to Fraser melbrook all all of whom had
seemingly become immune to the outward effects of
his condition not one of these people could be
convinced that Frasier was a violent criminal
that everyone else saw among the list of names
were Fraser's parents Vivian and Beck along with
his siblings grandmother former classmates and
romantic partners and his fiancee Nadia but you
might be wondering how did the SCP Foundation use
nothing more than a list of names to keep scp-3017
caged by threatening them of course researchers
who interviewed Frasier found that they could
greatly decrease the secondary effect of his
condition making them far less compelled to free
him all it took was them to tell Frasier that his
family friends fiance would be captured tortured
or even killed if he tried to escape containment
according to the foundation this didn't stop
Frasier from trying to escape though his file
states that he actively made several attempts to
breach Containment all of which failed the truth
however was that just about any move that Frasier
made was misinterpreted as an attempted Escape
in one instance while trying just to use the
bathroom scp-3017 was tackled and restrained by
a foundation guard you see Frazier knew that just
like with his previous arrests he'd done nothing
to deserve being locked up and interrogated by the
SCP Foundation but to the eyes of everyone around
him he was a dangerous threat the researchers and
guards treated him like a monster because as far
as they saw he was one by manipulating information
about the current health of his loved ones like
telling him his grandmother had developed lung
cancer the foundation kept Frazier under lock and
key hearing threats against his friends and family
or bad news about their current state quickly
put an end to scp-3017's attempts at Escape
even though he was frustrated with the foundation
he was without hope and had little choice in the
matter so Frazier did his best to comply with his
captors and offer the SCP Foundation information
on groups of Interest he thought they wanted to
hear even though he had no affiliation with any
of them by bringing Frazier's fiancee Nadia into
containment and showing him a live video feed
of the her foundation researcher Dr Kiran hoped
to coax a wealth of valuable information out of
scp-3017 afraid for his partner's life Frazier did
his best to answer their questions and Nadia was
later freed and given amnestics to forget the
incident but Foundation researcher Ryland was
quick to realize that the information Dr Kiran
had extracted from scp-317 didn't seem to add
up Frasier of course had no knowledge about any
groups of interest and had to improvise to protect
his fiancee researcher Ryland picked up on this
remarking that scp-3017's information could not
be considered reliable but she was unsure if
Frasier was hiding something or simply didn't
know anything during another interrogation
Frazier's brother a former classmate and
two former romantic Partners were brought into
the foundation and sedated in an adjacent room
Frazier was threatened by Dr Kiran with a handgun
and made sure to answer for their questions every
time he did it the doctor threatened to shoot one
of Fraser's loved ones it was after this incident
that researcher Ryland once again reassessed the
information given by scp-3017 finally she came to
realize that there was no evidence of Frasier's
criminal history nor was there anything tying
him to groups of Interest everything that the
foundation had thought of him was just a result
of scp-317's condition and he genuinely had none
of the information they'd been seeking he was only
answering their questions to protect the lives
of people he cared for realizing the huge ethical
mistake the foundation had made essentially
psychologically torturing Frazier for information
he simply didn't have researcher Ryland begged
her superiors that scp-3017 be released the
request was denied and instead Rylan was contained
believed to be a new instance of scp-3017-1 with
the help of security officer Rudolph Cartier who
had guarded Frazier Rylan escaped her own cell
pair of them triggered a containment alarm in the
ensuing confusion Rylan and cardiad freed scp-3017
from his incarceration and she and Frasier escaped
the containment facility where officer cardiad was
captured and contained by security Personnel Rylan
brought Frasier to what she thought was safety of
his family's home but neither of them expected to
see what awaited them the house had been burned
to the ground with almost all Frazier's family
inside his parents siblings grandmother fiance
and even neighbor had all perished in a fire
that had engulfed the one place in the world
that Frasier hadn't been held against his will
it is still unclear if the fire was intentionally
started by a member of the SCP Foundation to drive
as cp3017 back into containment or had merely been
an unfortunate accident but notably Dr Kiran had
been strangely absent during scp-3017 and ryland's
escape from the foundation overwhelmed with grief
and despair Frasier was last seen on a bridge not
far from his childhood home and researcher Ryland
was recaptured without resistance by Foundation
Personnel near the same spot with scp-3017 gone
along with his Cognito hazardous effects both her
and security officer cardiad were reinstated
back to full employment with the foundation
the foundation then reclassified as cp3017 is
neutralized quietly avoiding the truth of their
mistake all records of his supposed criminal
activity and links to anomalous groups were
stricken from the record as unsubstantiated he
had been innocent all along just a man who had
never done anything he was accused of and didn't
deserve to be locked away the SCP Foundation had
tortured Frasier asking him questions he didn't
have the answers to using the love he and for
those closest to him as a way to try and goat
him into giving the foundation what they wanted
and in the end may have been responsible for
multiple innocent people being murdered perhaps
it was easier for them to stamp neutralize on his
file than to actually face up what they'd done to
him the foundation has spent at least a century
containing anomalies and monsters but the hardest
monsters to contain are often the ones that emerge
within us and nothing better illustrates that than
the foundation's Monstrous treatment of scp-317
on the 13th of October 1989 the town of Danner
Wisconsin was shaken by a seismic event unlike
anything they'd ever experienced this might have
been written off as an earthquake Where not for
one disturbing Factor the ground shaking event was
accompanied by a huge Spike of radioactivity with
the strange phenomenon happening a month before
the Berlin Wall was torn down during a period of
the Cold War that has historians call the year of
Crisis it's easy to understand why the people of
Danner immediately assumed the worst but the huge
eruption they felt wasn't the result of a nuclear
bomb going off the SCP Foundation was alerted to
the event in Danner when they picked up a series
of radio Transmissions coming from just outside
the town when they arrived they found something
incredible like something out of a sci-fi movie
standing at the quake's epicenter was a creature
that looked to be from another world standing two
meters tall and weighing almost 300 kilograms
the being was green and brown in color with a
bulky humanoid body its head was a different story
though and resembled a gigantic housefly with a
proboscis and huge stereoscopic eyes surprisingly
the strange creature did not immediately go on a
rampage instead the being designated scp-2273
appeared to be exhausted injured and extremely
malnourished it offered no no resistance at all
to the foundation containment team and it was
taken to site 17 without conflict while the SCP
Foundation is no stranger to visitors from other
worlds there was something especially unusual
about the supposed alien Invader the doctors
who examined the creature and treated its injuries
found an appendage that seemed to function as an
organic radio transmitter and large open wounds
on its shoulder blades and forearms where further
appendages had been ripped off additionally while
its insect-like exoskeleton was mostly a uniform
green and brown pattern the creature's upper arms
and torso were dotted with a variety of scars and
markings that on closer inspection looked like
military badges was this some kind of wounded
Intergalactic soldier who had been stranded
on Earth if it was then how were the organic
badges on this aliens exoskeleton a near perfect
match to military badges worn by soldiers in the
Soviet Union even if they did reference a unit
that didn't officially exist within the Soviet
Army the scientists were sure this alien wasn't
an alien at all underneath its exoskeleton was
a non-anomalous human being if that was true
then this was even more terrifying than an
extraterrestrial visitor the scientists were sure
that the USSR had developed a new kind of organic
armor and this anomaly showing up in Wisconsin
was the result of a test on U.S soil that had
gone wrong if that was the case then there was
no telling how many more of these exoskeletons
were out there and would need to be contained
the foundation had to act quickly and find out
more while scp-2273 was recovering they called
in Dr Friedrich an on-site psychologist who
could speak several languages including Russian Dr
Friedrich would be tasked with interrogating the
SCP on his Origins and the nature of the suit
the interview was conducted via AM radio from
a separate observation chamber as the biological
transmitter seemed to be scp-22 73's only method
of communication the interview began with Dr
Friedrich speaking to scp-2273 in Russian only
for 2273 to respond that Dr friedrich's accent was
atrocious and requesting he used German instead
scp-2273 who according to the organic military
patches on his body was named Major Alexi belotrov
initially resisted being interviewed he believed
that he was a prisoner of war being held by the
American Military according to him he had been
in the middle of battle and that the Americans
had killed his men and left him for dead in
the wilderness nothing that Dr Friedrich told
him that there was no war or that the foundation
was not affiliated with the U.S government could
convince him otherwise and he refused to talk
further before a second interview was conducted
velotrov was given an old copy of the level one
researcher General debrief as a way of helping him
further understand the nature of the foundation
and his containment belatrave was more Cooperative
after that though the realization that he would
most likely be kept in containment for the rest
of his life caused him great distress and he was
unwilling to speak to Dr Friedrich for another
three days Dr Friedrich didn't give up though and
when belatrop finally opened up to the doctor he
began to tell him more and more bellatrop told the
doctor that when he was a child Russia was hit by
an American nuclear warhead and that the Soviet
Union immediately retaliated the resulting nuclear
conflict which belatrop called the war to end the
world caused massive Devastation and left most of
the planet dangerously irradiated that is why he
had the exoskeleton it was to Shield him from the
radiation and allow him to survive above ground
unfortunately velotrov knew very little about
how the suit was made or how it worked saying
that it was built by the engineers and that it
grew naturally over a period of several years but
bellatrov hadn't made the decision himself it was
his parents who had volunteered him as a test
subject for the exoskeleton suit program when
he was still young hoping it would give him a
better chance at survival the process of bonding
the exoskeleton to the human body was extremely
painful but according to balatrov its advantages
far outweighed the pain the suit not only helped
him survive in a nuclear Wasteland but made him
a better Soldier the suit allowed him to lift and
carry up to 1200 kilograms gave him stereoscopic
vision and the organic radio transmitter allowed
him to communicate with other soldiers across long
distances as well as listen in on encrypted enemy
Transmissions the wounds on his shoulders and
arms where it looked like appendages had been
ripped down were where his weapons and Supply
packs had previously been mounted velotrov had
been stationed with his men in the area he was
discovered when they were attacked by American
soldiers the soldiers had ripped off bellatrop's
weapons and Supply pack and did the same to
all his men as well they were all shocked with
belatrop being Bear for the moment only because
the Americans had identified him as the commanding
officer suddenly there was a bright flash of light
and the American soldiers vanished not only that
but the landscape changed where there had been
a post-nuclear wasteland before now there were
lush green trees injured and disoriented belatrop
began sending distress signals only to have those
signals intercepted by the SCP Foundation the most
interesting part of belatron's story as far as the
foundation was concerned came during his fourth
interview when Dr Friedrich asked him about the
engineers who had designed the exoskeleton
suit in belladrov's own words they weren't
truly known to man until the years of the Great
War and the revolution the French found them in
buried cities where the Western allies were
digging their trenches eventually they were
made to build weapons for the war by both sides
by his description these Engineers didn't sound
human but they were by no means unknown to
the SC EP Foundation bellatrov described the
engineers as humanoid nocturnal covered in fur
and possessing technology and intelligence far
beyond that of any human those familiar with
the foundation's history might already know
the engineers by their Foundation designation
of scp-1000 or their more commonly known name
Bigfoot a quick rundown scp-1000 are a species of
intelligent humanoid primates that lived alongside
Humanity in highly advanced cities until their
own technology was turned against them not only
were there cities wiped off the face of the Earth
but 70 of their population was slaughtered and the
survivors were driven mad to the point that their
mental faculties were no higher than those of a
chimpanzee or gorilla the SCP Foundation is tasked
with keeping them away from Human contact in
fear of what the creatures would be able to do to
humanity if they ever regained their memories and
full mental function and rumors have been spread
about them possessing deadly anomalous properties
but evidently the destruction of the scp-1000
species never occurred in bellatrop's universe
or if it did it wasn't nearly as complete in that
timeline Humanity regained contact with scp-1000
after discovering their underground cities
sometime during World War one after this discovery
both Allied and Axis Powers began recruiting them
to build weapons and their weapons played a role
in both the Russian Revolution and the second
world war it was because of these technological
advantages that the Cold War escalated into
what would become the war to end all wars both
sides were armed with not only nuclear warheads
but highly Advanced radiation-proof exoskeleton
armor that allowed the conflict to continue even
after the total Destruction of the planet while
the humans fought above ground life continued as
normal for scp-1000 in their underground cities
as velotrov noted they never wore the armor
themselves as they had no need to venture
above ground only soldiers wear armor and this
is not their War bellatrov continued to adjust
to life in containment and sitting for regular
interviews with Dr Friedrich he was given the
rations provided for humanoid anomalies but
in much larger quantities as the suit required
him to eat around 8 000 calories a day to keep it
functioning bellatrov also began taking advantage
of his ability to access the foundation's library
he would often read or listen to classical music
particularly by the Russian composer Tchaikovsky
he seemed especially fond of reading The Time
Machine by H.G Wells no surprise given he was able
to directly relate to the experience of living
through an apocalypse and being transported
to a strange timeline with no way to return
home but with little else to occupy his time
bellatrov began to display symptoms consistent
with post-traumatic stress disorder reporting
in his now regular interviews with Dr Friedrich
that he was constantly reliving memories of the
battles he'd fought and the lives he had taken
in combat the suit was making the problems worse
too it seemed it was as if he could never forget
as one of its features was an ability to store
and replay memories this feature was intended
as a strategic Aid that would allow commanding
officers to more effectively gather and process
information about their surroundings but outside
of combat this only served to force balatrov into
reliving his most painful memories again and again
every night as he tried to sleep he would see the
faces of his men their weapons torn from their
exoskeletons laying in the dirt after being gunned
down by the enemy like many veterans bellatrov was
being hit all at once with the harsh realities of
War now that his brain wasn't solely focused on
keeping him alive it had time to process all the
horrors he'd experienced he told Dr Friedrich I
trained alongside these men for years before they
put us back on the surface since we were all young
children we brothers and I gave them the order to
surrender and got them killed I should have died
with them while the story of scp-2273 ends here
the story of Alexi bellatrov scp-2273-1 continues
in 2018 bellatrobe was allowed passage to volugrad
Russia as part of an anomaly reintegration
program while he was unable to secure employment
within the Russian government as he had hoped
he eventually was taken in by a monastery and
continued to write letters to Dr Friedrich until
friedrich's eventual death from lymphoma-related
complications there's plenty more on the
monastery the anomaly reintegration program and
what happened to Major belatrav when he returned
to Russia but that will have to be a story for
another day the SCP Foundation is an organization
that polices the abnormal in all its forms whether
it's a multi-dimensional chaos God a big scaly
monster or a very effective coffee machine the
foundation takes appointed interest in pretty
much anything outside the norm so you're probably
wondering what would they want with Mr Smith a
man who was about as normal and average as could
be Mr Smith was a 47 year old African-American
construction worker with a wife and daughter he
lived a modest but contented life he had a close
circle of friends a happy family and was well
liked among his co-workers but Mr Smith had no
idea about the anomalous nightmare barreling down
the tracks towards him Mr Smith wasn't just about
to have his life destroyed by an anomaly he was
about to become one it seemed like a normal day
at work on the construction site when he received
a phone call it was the police informing him that
his wife and young daughter had been involved in a
terrible car accident while this is anyone's worst
nightmare it was only the start of the horrifying
things that were about to happen to poor poor Mr
Smith that night when Mr Smith went to sleep he
fell victim to a strange phenomenon he started
to disappear while it would be easy to write
off as the result of mental illness like a kind
of stressed-induced mental breakdown Mr Smith
wasn't the only one who noticed or rather
didn't notice his co-workers would slowly
begin to forget details about him even obvious
things that you could glean from simply looking
at a person like clothes height or skin color it
seemed that little by little ever since his family
died Mr Smith was becoming an unperson this led to
increasing levels of fear paranoia and distress as
people whom he'd thought of as his closest friends
could barely recognize him anymore thankfully Mr
Smith wasn't just going to slip into non-existence
without a fight he realized early on that his new
conditions seemed to abide by certain rules the
effects got worse in the night when he was alone
but seemed to lessen somewhat during the day when
he was interacting with people it seemed that he
disappeared just that little bit more whenever
he wasn't being interacted with and perhaps he
hadn't developed this condition upon the death of
his wife and child maybe he'd had it for a while
but it was the constant presence of his family
that kept the effects from worsening but now that
he'd properly identified the problem Mr Smith
could begin devising some solutions if nobody
else was there to interact with him at night he'd
keep his position in reality stable by interacting
with himself Mr Smith would repeat his own name
to himself regularly reaffirming his existence
to himself he'd often check his own pulse to feel
the rhythm of his heartbeat he'd write detailed
descriptions of himself either on his own body or
a surrounding surface and in one particular stroke
of Genius he devised a method of recording his own
voice talking to himself and playing it back while
he was asleep to Stave off reality Decay during
the day while at work or just existing socially in
the world you do everything he could to constantly
interact with people that way they could keep
reaffirming his presence and therefore continuing
his existence the symptoms of Mr Smith's condition
are somewhat similar to a rare mental illness
known as the kotar delusion in which a patient
believes they are dead dying or don't even exist
except in Mr Smith's unfortunate case the delusion
was becoming a reality and this was a reality
that Mr Smith could only hold off for so long
little by little the coping mechanisms he'd built
to manage his new life began to collapse people in
his inner circle truly began to forget him his
company no longer recognized him as an employee
to the people who barely knew him he was little
more than a ghost a kind of palpable absence this
was the point when the SCP Foundation finally got
involved they swooped in and apprehended Mr Smith
redesignating him as SCP 1467 it was one of the
rare occasions that the foundation didn't need to
apply any amnestic treatment to bystanders because
due to the nature of Mr Smith's anomalous activity
almost everyone who knew him was already in the
process of forgetting him when the foundation
interviewed a man that Mr Smith referred to as a
close friend he couldn't even recall Mr Smith's
basic physical traits with any reliability because
of Mr Smith's condition the foundation had real
difficulty verifying elements of his backstory Mr
Smith told the foundation researchers everything
about himself about his family and his life before
but field agents were stumped whenever they tried
to follow up on the information first there were
issues with the existence and fate of his supposed
wife and child no records were ever found of
either of these people existing and there was no
existing documentation to prove that Mr Smith was
ever married the foundation also looked into the
deaths of Mrs Smith and her child there were no
records of a car crash in the area that Mr Smith
directed them to but that's not all there were
also no death records nor any Graves ever found
the construction company that Mr Smith claimed
to work for had no records of his employment
they couldn't find any of Mr Smith's supposed
extended family either the only proof that he
had ever existed was his physical body locked
in a foundation humanoid containment cell and
Mr Smith's own words if you think this sounds
like a living nightmare then Mr Smith would
wholeheartedly agree with you the effects of
his anomalous nature traumatized Mr Smith he was
diagnosed by Foundation therapists as suffering
from bipolar depression as well as chronic sleep
deprivation though if you disappeared a little
more every time you slept you'd probably lose
a lot of sleep too the unpredictable nature of
Mr Smith's anomalous trades could have equally
unpredictable effects on the nature of of his
containment so he was classified as Euclid Mr
Smith is one of the few anomalies that is referred
to by his real name at least to his face when
referred to as scp-1467 Mr Smith enters a state of
rage and panic and this mistake has caused several
injuries for foundation Personnel during attempts
to restrain him after using his SCP number around
him Mr Smith is contained in a foam padded cell
to prevent self-destructive Behavior along with
three audio recording devices though these
were installed at his own request in order
to continue his habit of recording his own voice
to play back to himself while asleep this served
the dual purpose of not only mitigating his fading
from reality but also keeping him calm and docile
during containment and these devices are kept
in good working order in order to avoid creating
hostility between Mr Smith and foundation's staff
while it may seem that the anomalous effects of Mr
Smith purely serve to create a personal hell for
him and him alone the foundation wasn't so sure
the fact no records could be found of his wife
daughter or extended family was concerning it
raised one frightening question are the effects of
Mr Smith's condition contagious if so he could be
putting a lot of people in grave danger Foundation
scientists headed by senior researcher Dr Thorne
devised a series of experiments to better
understand Mr Smith's mysterious condition there
were 22 experiments in total but things began
to get interesting at around experiment 16. for
this experiment Mr Smith was forcibly restrained
and brought into a research chamber with research
assistants Rainier and Dieter they were told
to Simply observe Mr Smith without interacting
with him and record what happened in the process
while Dr Thorne supervised at 10 minutes and 12
seconds the researchers were unable to recognize
the subject as Mr Smith at 14 minutes and 32
seconds there were able to recognize the clothes
of Mr Smith less than 10 minutes later they were
unable to identify his Reigns five minutes after
that they couldn't identify what Mr Smith was
currently doing ten minutes later they couldn't
even identify how Mr Smith was sitting at almost
40 minutes the research assistants weren't able
to identify anything of Mr Smith save for the fact
that there was some kind of humanoid creature
in the room at this point research assistant
deodor started a recording instructing Mr Smith
to describe himself on record as this happened
Smith returned to a describable State curled
up in a fetal position on the floor there was
no sign of the restraints or the chair in which
Smith had been placed subsequent tests showed
similar results with minor variations in timing
just by being in physical contact with Mr Smith
the chair and the restraints had literally
faded out of existence evidence was really
pointing towards Mr Smith's anomalous effects
being potential detrimental to the people and
objects around him but the experiments continued
they had to know more before there was nothing
left to know the next series of experiments were
performed with d-classes and led Dr Thorne and
his team of researchers to a number of frightening
conclusions two d-classes locked in with Mr Smith
as he slipped out of existence began experiencing
extreme states of Terror and distress even when
they could no longer see him they could still feel
the presence of an entity in the room when the 2D
classes tried to escape one of them was almost
mistaken for Mr Smith himself he too was now
starting to slip out of existence both d-classes
were summarily terminated and Dr Thorne began to
wonder whether Mr Smith's condition was contagious
or if he was instead somehow able to lash out at
others in his vicinity in a more localized fashion
only two other experiments were ever performed
on Mr Smith before further experimentation into
his case was permanently suspended in the first
a non-violent d-class was placed in Mr Smith's
cell and ordered to ignore him Mr Smith didn't
take this well he began attacking the d-class who
fought back breaking Mr Smith's nose ironically
this physical attack was actually beneficial to Mr
Smith as the violence helped ground him in reality
and secured his existence just that little bit
more in the final experiment Mr Smith was given
a cellmate a female d-class who was allowed
to acknowledge Him the two appeared to become
close and their time helped Stave off Mr Smith's
fading just a little bit longer it's unknown if
she contracted his fading condition or somehow
was able to escape but one day while Mr Smith
slept she simply disappeared Mr Smith fell into
a state of almost catatonic silence soon after
he began to speak again only to repeat I don't
want to go again and again and again experiments
concluded for good not long after because of his
delicate mental state Mr Smith is allowed a visit
from a therapist every week and before any future
experiments are performed on Mr Smith researchers
are required to seek permission from his active
therapist because of his effects on the minds
of people aware of him Foundation protocol is to
terminate Mr Smith immediately if he ever breaches
containment the site director has also appended
a memo to Smith's file instructing Personnel to
refer to Mr Smith as scp-1467 whenever he's out
of earshot doing otherwise will incur severe
punishments records on Mr Smith are backed up
in six separate copies and stored in different
locations in hopes that this will prevent
the information from decaying like Mr Smith's
existence Mr Smith's story is one of pain tragedy
and existential horror there's no shortage of scps
that can cause XK Class end of the world scenarios
but sometimes the terror of these anomalies pales
in comparison to scps that can bring one person's
World crashing down around them according to all
the SCP Foundation studies it's likely that Mr
Smith will disappear sometime soon regardless of
their intervention hour one there is only one
news story on every website newspaper and TV
screen the flowers are blooming everywhere all
across the globe every country every land mass
the bitter cold of the Antarctic gives way to
a glowing rainbow of petals the Sahara Desert
and Death Valley become beacons of thriving
Technicolor plant life the highest mountains
the lowest valleys the darkest caves the flowers
even burst free from the concrete of cities as if
reminding us that really it was never our world
we were only borrowing it and today our lease is
up this is scp-001 object class unnecessary it was
foretold by Tales from other dimensions a distant
future coming down the tracks towards us and
today the train has reached the station nobody's
reporting on how the economy or the stock market
is doing today no point celebrity scandals have
faded away into nothingness greedy businessmen
lying politicians brutal tyrants none of them are
making the headlines today the very last headlines
the world gone beautiful and what a shame it takes
the end of it all to make us realize what really
matters to us that's right you're looking at the
end of the world but it's okay don't panic take
a deep breath in and out it was bound to happen
eventually so no point worrying now even the
foundation knows that this just isn't something
they can stop so instead of asking things like how
can we prevent this or do we have any final Tricks
Up Our Sleeve let's ask a different question
entirely what would you do if you knew that
you only had 24 hours until all life on Earth ends
think hard after all even if you never live to see
the flowers bloom a final day will still come
for you just as it does for us all hour six a
d-class sits alone in the cell when he sees the
flowers growing out of the ground normally he'd
assumed that this meant he was in some kind of
foundation experiment but not today everyone on
Earth had an innate sense that the time is now a
kind of gallows calm spreads out over everyone and
everything it's over and that's okay we all knew
it was going to happen eventually right he Sighs
and gives a slight smile those flowers sure are
beautiful that's when he hears footsteps outside
his this cell approaching a key slides into his
cell door and opens there stands Dr gears holding
a bottle of wine and two glasses anyone who knows
him might think he's been replaced by some kind
of shape-shifting anomaly or had his mind taken
over by a powerful Cognito Hazard but no it's him
the famously called Dr Charles Ogden gears Dr gear
says come on it's a lovely day out there it'd be a
terrible waste to spend the whole thing cooped up
in here it'd feel like a trick on any day but this
the d-class nods and follows the doctor out the
normally oh so stoic Foundation senior researcher
pours himself in the d-class each a glass of wine
and asks What's Your Name by the way I don't think
I ever checked the d-class replies that his name
is Harold the two smile and shout as they exit the
now empty d-class containment Wing everyone
else is outside already researchers guards
administrative staff and d-classes all rubbing
elbows and enjoying the beautiful sun on their
last day together Elsewhere on site a flock of
scp-514 is released just as identical flocks
are being released from every containment site
all over the world they've prepared it all for
this very day scp-514 is a special breed of homing
pigeons created by the Mana charitable Foundation
which have the power to suppress aggression for
those within their field of anomalous influence
and now millions of them are flying all over the
world after all there's no point fighting on a
day like this there is no future left to secure
people always told them there would forever be
hope until the flowers bloomed no situation was
ever truly over until the World Went beautiful but
in the absence of Hope there was something even
more inviting total absolute calm the site-19
Personnel sit together and watch the flowers bloom
hour 12 all militaries call a global ceasefire
soldiers from opposing sides hug and shake hands
in Flowery fields that once seemed choked by death
and blood borders fade bitter rivalries turn to
dust Korea unifies all is quiet in the Middle
East gangsters and drug cartels drop their weapons
and return home to their families and friends as
flocks of scp-514 Fly Above what good is all
the blood money in the world on a day like
this wardens walk cell to cell through all the
world's prisons granting people their freedom
again sometimes after lifetimes of not having it
they taste the Aragon feel the sun on their face
they close their eyes drink it in and walk among
the flowers free men locations of Marshall Carter
and dark limited close their doors and shudder
their Windows worldwide for the first time in as
long as any of them can remember they turn their
signs to closed they've earned a day off everyone
has the chaos Insurgency rolls up their plans and
burns them they drop their weapons and throw away
their tactical gear as they do so they can't help
but question themselves what was it all for in the
end what was any of it for all the fighting and
bloodshed and death we did a day after day only
to do it again the next day what silly reasons
we killed and died for what silly reasons indeed
the global cult Coalition dismisses its staff
thanking them for their service and telling
them to go spend their last hours with the ones
they love like the foundation they accept that
this is the one true Final End no ritual to stop
no monster to fight no evil extra dimensional
entity to thwart just go outside and smell the
flowers while you still can the Serpent's hand
are similar they decide after decades fighting
a losing battle they'll spend their last day
in The Wanderers library reading some of their
favorite volumes all these 1 wonderful stories now
left for other Earths to read their own stories
would be counted among them in the end and they
take great comfort in that in a sense everyone
will live forever in the pages of the books in
The Wanderers Library Hermann Fuller's circus
of the disquieting releases all of its Freaks
and clowns from their Twisted grasp to go and live
out whatever small dreams and Tiny Pleasures they
could find over their last hours they have no
Foundation of fear anymore nobody Minds their
strange appearances and odd behaviors why would
anyone waste such a beautiful day judging others
on the last day on Earth there's nothing left to
prove sarcasists dropped their ancient flesh-bound
tomes and acolytes of the broken God put down
their gilded blades on the slopes of Siberia the
jungles of Peru and the most isolated beaches of
Mexico Twisted flesh finally touched living metal
in the spirit of husbandry their Eternal war is
at its own in the face of the blooming World they
didn't seem so different after all the Agents of
the doctor wondertainment Corporation predictably
chose to spend their last hour sitting around
and playing with toys together time well spent
if you ask us in a highly secretive location
perhaps the most heavily secured place in the
entire world the 13 members of the legendary
o5 Council decide to just sit and talk anyone
who knows anything about this secretive cabal can
tell you the o5 council has spent a considerable
portion of their very very long lives trying to
figure out ways to dodge and cheat death but now
facing a death they can't Dodge the same calm
washing over the rest of the world has finally
reached them too all they can really think this
time is well played reaper well played as they
chat about the kind of a name casual things that
they haven't had time to discuss in years 05-3
suggests inviting the Ethics Committee over to
join nobody disagrees hour 16. it isn't just
the D classes all Sapient and non-aggressive
scps have been released from containment free
to spend the last of their time as they wish tens
of thousands of anomalous individuals are released
from containment sites all over the globe it'd be
the greatest victory that the Serpent's hand could
ever ask for if they weren't all too busy reading
to notice scp-105 Iris Thompson finally returns to
her parents the foundation had fed them the lie
that their daughter had died many years before
but as Iris had a tendency to do she was ready
to work a miracle her parents Embrace her with
open arms they'll spend their last hours together
catching up on what's happened since they parted
ways and making up for lost time they couldn't be
happier scp-1867 Lord Blackwood the Fantastical
sea snail is delivered into a warm Rock pool
near the site where he was being contained there
he might finally have one more Grand Adventure
before all is said and done though afterward he
may not have the time to tell anyone about it a
terrible shame really because nobody spins a yarn
like Lord Blackwood the non-aggressive little
misters Run free Mr Fish eagerly returns to his
native Boston Massachusetts where he enjoys
one more Lobster sandwich before the end of
the world Mr headless decides to go hat shopping
because he wants to look good for the apocalypse
Mr lost finally settles down for the afternoon
deciding that just this once he's earned himself
a rest scp-2800 Cactus men returns to Edinburgh
to spend his last days picking up litter and
helping old ladies cross the street scp-3663 the
tunnel monster walks the streets of his hometown
searching for an old friend hoping to reunite
before it all ends scp-073 Kane decides to take
a walk outside for the first time in thousands
of years he can can't help but Smile as the
bright colorful life beneath his feet is growing
faster than his presence can kill it what a truly
beautiful day knowing that there's no longer
time for Cults to form and bother him scp-2662
Cthulhu decides to take a break from his intense
Minecraft session and go take a walk outside it
feels so good to have the sun on his tentacles
once more and to feel the lush green grass under
his suction cups he shakes his head thinking
once again about the irritating Cults that
had been pestering him for decades what kind of
idiot would want him to destroy a world like this
scp-343 also known as God size and looks over all
his creation for what he knows to be the last time
his mouth curls into a smile as he thinks well
we had a pretty good run still in a Cell scp-049
the plague doctor puts his feet up and decides
to relax the pestilence will soon be taken care
care of on some animalistic level below thought
below even Instinct scp-096 feels grateful that
no gaze will ever fall upon it again somewhere
fizzling in a vat of acid within a highly secure
containment chamber scp-682 is feeling for the
first time in its hellish existence a sense of
profound relief the pain the hate the rage the
constant termination attempts it all be over soon
hour 23 people Gather in the streets they laugh
and dance and sing as the moon shines fat and
white far above deep in their hearts they quietly
contemplate the end of all of this but why worry
why spoil the fun there's no future left to worry
about strangers become as close as family in the
end human or otherwise anomalous or non-anomalous
chaos Insurgency agents have last suppers with
ex-serpants hands and GOC operatives there is no
hate left no violence No Malice no cruelty the
greatest tragedy in all of this is that it took
the ultimate end to bring it out in people but
why worry why worry seconds pass then minutes the
world buzzes it hums trillions of creatures doing
everything they'd wanted even though it won't
last in the face of the true end the world has
never been more alive hour 24 silence forever and
ever and ever good night we'll end this video the
way it began by putting a question to you how
would you spend your last 24 hours on Earth let
us know down in the comments because it'll happen
to all of us eventually what is your favorite word
think about it for a moment think real hard write
it down in the comments posted for everyone else
to see how many letters does it have how many
syllables say it aloud how does it sound how
does it feel on your tongue really really think
about it now make sure you keep that word in mind
it's important and we'll come back to it later for
now it's time to talk about scp-3449 look there's
really nothing any special about this one it
wasn't even important enough to be mentioned with
the other info hazards it's not an evil talking
toaster that's for sure scp-3449 appears to
just be a standard spiral notebook not book it's
supposed to be notebook right anyway it's just a
standard spiral notebook with a dark blue cover
it's safe class and it's stored in the standard
standard containment Locker in site 19. there
aren't any other containment requires but testing
is currently underway to determined um I think
it's meant to be determined long-term containment
requirements this is a mess anyway this item and
its anomalous power is actually considered so
inconsequential that researchers have explored
the possibility of putting it on the anomalous
items log a place where items too useless to warn
to full file ends up geez how do you misspell
up that badly it's two letters supposed to be
two letters how did you work Z into that they
aren't even close to each other on keyboard man
anyway the notebook contains mostly blank pages
some are torn and only six contain actual writing
but due to the formatting of the ridding the text
consisting mainly of diary entries is almost
unreadable this is due to synactical errors
random capitalization and rampant imp this
spellings great You misspelled misspelling
how cute apparently all attempts to correct these
misspellings fail or even lead to additional
misspellings this anomalous effect extends
to anyone attempting to write yep that was
spelled r-i-g-h-t anyone attempting to write
about scp-3449 including the script for this
video apparently there are no further notable
Anonymous properties tests are ongoing though
those with any inquiries about testing scp-3449
should contact lead researcher Nick Lowe gerdinell
The Notebook which was misspelled even worse this
time impressive was first recovered by MTF Epsilon
6 also known as The Village idiots after a series
of info hazardous and Cognito hazardous phenomenon
were discovered in the Pittsburgh Metroid area
The Source seemed to be a storage unit filled with
anomalous items and scp-3449 was a mogus I think
that's meant to be among them the storage unit was
registered to a man by the name of Edward salzbro
currently designated as porpoise of Interest 4335
that's the end of that thanks for watching the
video folks now go check out oh wait there's
more phenomenal let's keep going apparently that
version of the file was an older one let's check
the next one and see if that's any more useful
oh oh oh my it appears that the updates here
are actually quite extensive okay let's give this
another try scp-3449 is a Euclid class SPC kept in
the humanid containment cells of site 19. items
affected by it are kept in standard store eggs
lockers for safe class anomalous objects at the
same site the primary reason for the shift is that
scp-3449 has changed its object of designation
it is no longer the spiral notebook it is now a
34 year old Caucasian man known as Edward salzbro
formerly known as Person of Interest 4335 he is
believed to be the creator of the notebook as well
as other objects found in the storage looker in
Pittsburgh Foundation Personnel are now trying to
locate and contain any other objects created by Mr
sellsberg though success has been limited on this
front that was cute scp-3449's analogous abilities
manifest onto both Edward himself and all the
objects created by Him ridding about him or any
of these objects will result in synaptical errors
arbitrary capitalization and Rampart imp smellings
attempts to revise or correct the writing will
either fail to remove the errors or create new
errors it appears that the anomaloninous effects
of scp-3449 proper are more severe than that of
the ones caused by his anomalous objects MTF
Epsilon 6 also known as The Village idiots
apprehended as cp3449 in his apartment just
outside of Pittsburgh he appeared to be in an
advanced state of disorientation and dehydration
records collected by the mobile task force found
that Mr selberg had not left his apartment in
over 10 days which would account for his dire
health conditions Salzburg did not communicate
with mambas of the mobile task force but did
not reset arrest and subsequent containment either
okay okay these spellings are rough but I'm going
to try and power through I am a professional and
we're almost there the following is the full lug
of items obtained from scp-3449 Storage look
car that also exhibit his anomalous effects The
Notebook as already discussed the pages are either
blank torn or illegible salzberg's computer files
saved on this device include spreadsheets dealing
personal finances ideals for products and an
unfinished horror novel that is almost unratable
due to the poor quality of its writing grocery
list had only two written items Booter was spelled
with only one t and medication which was spelled
medication a planner last entry was dated two
weeks before containment and believed to contain
reminders to perform various chores however a
mixture of poor or handwriting and word choice
allows for other interpretations and finally
Mr salzberg's cell phone Foundation researchers
were also able to collect the call logs in hopes
of further tracking salzburg's pre-containment
activities the last three calls which were all
made on the same day two weeks before contentment
dialed different numbers only one of which was in
use the foundation made contact with the receiver
of said call who had no knowledge of scp-3449
and claimed that they did not answer the call
lead researcher Nick Lowe gerdinell conduced the
first in interview with scp-3449 shortly after his
capture when he entered the interview chambri he
found that scp-3449 was just sitting in the corner
which with his had in his hands rocking back and
forth in what appeared to be apparent distress he
then begun looking down into his lap in twiddling
his thumbs like a child Nick Lowe engaged him in a
calm and polite tone addressing him as scp-3449
the autumnly made eye contact with Dr gerdinell
but he didn't respond and instead continues
starring at him as guernanell axed further
Quest Tunes Salzburg simply didn't answer or would
at the very most acknowledge the questions with
simple gestures girdnell asked whether Salzburg
was making products for his business to which he
smiled and shuck his head gurnell then asked
Salzburg whether he could speak or not or if
it was merely a choose on his part unsurprisingly
Salzburg offered no explanation and the interview
came to a close shortly afterwards tests are
still ongoing to find out if salzburg's inability
to spack or communicate come as a result of
his anomalous traits or if this is simply a
result of epiphonia a uncommon but non-anomalous
condition that renders its victims unable to
Spike tests have confirmed that sellsburg does
have all the organs required for vocalization
but s appears to not use them for the tests are
required alright there we have it that was a
complete nightmare to read thanks to scp-3449's
anomalous effects but at least it's over now
go check out wait there's more another
update to the file good okay all right
let's go take a look oh I see this is
a lot more dangerous than I thought I
suppose I better read on scp-3449 Hayes
Ben upgraded to ketter class anomal
scp-3449-a the new designation for Edward
salzburger is to be kept in a high security
Hazmat containment in site 19. the inanimate
anomalous possessions of Edward Salzburg are to be
keeped in standard object containment any reports
written on scp-3449 must be rotten by Popple who
have been exposed to it for less than seven days
in order to keep the files raidable to prevent
this infectious info hasmart from spread further
the number of people allowed to interact with this
anomaly is kept relatively small and consists
of those that have already been exposed at some
point or another this includes 05-8 MTF Epsilon
6. Dr teller's research team some additional
Personnel selected for xpc-3449 research and
Personnel chosen to update scp-3449 documentation
some additional Personnel selected for xpc
3449 research and Personnel chosen to update
scp-3449 documentation while Edward sellsberg
and his personal effects are crudily locked up
scp-3449 is not currently considered contained
Research into the sprod of scp-3449's effects
the vectors for transmission and any potential
recremities for its degenerative effects are
now taupe priority for all in love before this
whole thing gets out of hand further research
has taught the foundation that not only are
Salzburg and his items powerful info hazards
their anomalous of effects appear to be able
to infect these who experience them permanently
initially it will a prayer that writing quality
only degrades when the subject is actually writing
about scp-3449 itself but over time they'll
come to the frightening realization that it
actually affects their riffing as a whole the
effect also progresses in its similarity over
time eventually rendering the victim's ability
to write legible sentences completely displayed
the initial anomalous effects of scp-3449 were
discovered when MTF Epsilon 6 writes their field
reports on the Mater and found it littered
with synaptical error random capitalization
and rampant in plillings similar errors appearing
in the initial fail about scp-3449 only serve to
reaffirm this observation however researcher only
began to notice true extent of scp-3449 effects
when the village idiots field reports concerning
other solomonies came in with equally atrocious
writing attempts to correct this writing simply
led to more mustaches and frustration on part of
Team soon after a Reese stretcher named Dr Teller
who'd since track and ove were the scp-3449 case
and his team found that they were experienced
to timbler issues they couldn't just make the
blurreds happen no matter how hard they constraint
traded they forgot spellings they couldn't make
hand move in the manner they waited to in order
to form the wards even the most intelligent and
articulate members of the team came across as
extremely young children on page but didn't
stop there wasn't long before researchers who'd
never worked on the scp-3449 case started to
exhibit these same suspicious errors in own
writing the foundation didn't know how but
this through likeness was starting to spread with
people's abilities to write degrading across the
entire Foundation that's when a foundation
web trawler picked up same thing even more
distrobbing Global literacies seemed to be taking
a dive The Telltale synaptical error random to
capitalization and rampant illing misspellings
tickling up everywhere and for everyone and the
end of writing would be one thing but scp-3449
doesn't stop there now that's just the beginning
Morse code go next then pictograms not long
for sign language become hopeless scrambled
communication breaks down little by little people
can't draw anymore can't move right hands Gall
goes calls codes Lasko his voice talking gets her
remember favorite word think about it say it loud
when scp-3449 done when everyone infected you'll
never say again nobody will ever say again yeah
imagine for a moment that you are a teenager
according to our viewership analytics some of
you watching this won't have to imagine very hard
but some of you will have to really stretch your
mind to remember what that time was like either
way put yourself in the shoes of an adolescent for
a little while you're anxious and uncomfortable
in your body desperately trying to juggle your
responsibilities at school your burgeoning sense
of young adulthood your social life the looming
Specter of the future and a dozen other things
that might make you stress sweat through your
hoodie somehow in between the classes and
extracurriculars the standardized tests and
missed party invites you found someone who wants
to go out with you you're not sure what they see
in you but they must see something several months
into the relationship you decide to try and take
things to the next level you wait for your parents
to leave town you pick out the perfect Netflix and
chill material dim the lights and cozy up together
on the couch you go in for the kiss and shockingly
it it goes over well then just when things are
starting to heat up something doesn't feel quite
right you feel an overwhelming pain wash over your
body there's a flash of blinding bright light that
burns into your retinas and everything goes
black when you finally wake up your partner is
gone only a grisly smear of dark blood remaining
staining the couch where they sat like some kind
of gory Chalk Outline somehow you know they're
gone they're never coming back and it is all
your fault it sounds like the opening scene of
a horror film but for one unfortunate young man
known as scp-213 it was all too real scp-213
was recovered by the SCP Foundation in Palo
Alto California after his arrest the local police
department brought him in on charges of homicide
after he accidentally vaporized his girlfriend
they were undercover Foundation agents in the Palo
Alto Police Department who recognizing this case
as evidence of an anomaly made a report and were
ordered to bring the boy in for containment during
the initial attempts to apprehend 213 he vaporized
the agents as soon as they made physical contact
with him four agents were lost before 213 could be
successfully brought into a foundation facility
whereas anomalous properties could be better
studied scp-213 is able to sever the bonds between
atoms in any solid matter he comes into physical
contact with during this process there is a bright
flash of light and scp-213 experiences extreme
pain often to the point of passing out like most
sentient beings in containment he is considered a
euclid-class SCP scp-213 was initially contained
within a high security cell in site-77 the cell
is surrounded by a 10 meter wide Zone pumped full
of gases that are corrosive to humans skin scp-213
was informed of the nature of his containment
outside of the containment unit two armed guards
were stationed with high pressured hoses pepper
spray and polymer web grenades in case of any
Escape however over containment of 213 soon proved
difficult thanks to the nature of his seemingly
uncontrollable ability 213 made Seven Escape
attempts before one was eventually successful
he requested an interview with the researcher
assigned to his case knowing that when she
entered his containment facility the containment
procedures would be temporarily disengaged he
vaporized the remaining containment measures and
escaped from his holding cell the head researcher
attempted to grab him by the arm but was promptly
vaporized dissolving into a pile of Blood and
Tissue two more agents who try to block 213's
path without touching him met similar Fates after
making his way into the Hall 213 quickly became
disoriented his mind muddled from a mixture of
pain panic and lack of familiarity with the layout
of the facility he was unable to find an exit and
was cornered in the staff break room the door
barricaded with a chair where he was attempting
to vaporize a portion of the floor at this point
he was too exhausted to disintegrate any more
matter and collapse from exhaust question just as
a group of Agents broke down the door he was with
a great deal of care and the use of a gurney to
avoid any unnecessary physical contact returned
to his original containment cell several weeks
later scp-213 breached containment again however
this time it was completely unintentional security
camera footage from 3 15 am on the day in question
showed 213's bed and a portion of the floor
vaporized in a flash of light after which he fell
through the opening in the floor and landed in the
basement this incident made it clear that 213 had
far less control over his ability than previously
believed rather than a purposely destructive
entity he was simply a kid who destroyed what he
touched and could not do anything about it if it
could happen accidentally this time when else
could it happen could he potentially someday
vaporize himself without meaning to following this
Containment Breach and some time to recuperate
from the injuries he sustained from his fall 213
offered to be more Cooperative with the research
into his condition Mission he agreed to comply
with a series of experiments as well as routine
physical examinations and whatever else it might
take to unlock the secrets of the vaporization
effect just like the foundation he wanted to
know why he caused this destruction and how he
could stop it from happening during one of the
agreed-upon physical examinations the research
team discovered something concerning there were
smooth nodules growths of abnormal tissue on 213's
back placed in the shape of a perfect square
with exactly 15 centimeters between each one
the nodules were determined not to be tumors or
cancerous in any way they did not seem to cause
the subject any pain and he could not remember
how long they had been there perhaps they had
been there his entire life nothing resembling the
nodules or their precise placement could be found
in any public medical records or research journals
it became clear that the strange spots on 213's
back were likely somehow related to his anomalous
ability medical personnel were assigned to monitor
213 in his containment and watch for any changes
and follow-up examinations were scheduled to keep
an eye on the nodules and any other potential
physical symptoms a week after the discovery of
the first four nodules 213 was brought back into
the examination room for a follow-up inspection
there was nothing new found on the subject's back
the original nodules remaining in their place and
exhibiting no change in size or shape however
upon inspection of his hands the research team
discovered two more nodules when asked if he
was experiencing any pain or discomfort as a
result of these nodules 213 insisted that he only
felt some mild itching and irritation on the skin
around them a doctor pressed gently on one of the
nodules with his fingertips and it did not budge
with the appearance of these additional lumps on
213's hands the research team opted to perform a
biopsy on one of them and extract a sample a local
anesthetic was administered to 213's left hand and
the doctor attempted to slice into the surface of
the nodule with a scalpel as soon as the scalpel's
blade came into contact with his skin there was
a sizzling sound a blinding Flash and when the
attending researchers had regained Clear Vision
of the room the scalpel had disappeared scp-213
insisted that he had not deliberately vaporized
the scalpel and offered to try again the second
scalpel met the same fate as the first as did the
third and then a fourth scalpel after the fifth
scalpel disappeared the testing was suspended for
the day and 213 was sent back to his containment
chamber to rest for the next day's testing from
that day on 213's demeanor changed he was less
enthusiastic about continuing to research his
condition complaining of a pervasive sense of
exhaustion no matter how much he slept ate or
hydrated he complained of extreme pain in his back
and stomach which did not respond to treatment
with physical therapy or painkillers in spite
of 213's Newfound apathy the research team was
determined to persist they had come this far in
their quest to uncover the mysteries of scp-213
and they were not about to let their subjects
discomfort comfort and a few lost scalpels stop
them now the plan for another follow-up exam and
a new attempt to perform a biopsy were cut short
when 213 was spotted via security camera having
a seizure in his containment cell he was moved
to intensive care and kept there for further
observation over the course of the previous 48
Hours 10 more nodules had appeared on his back
each separated by a distance of five centimeters
the nodules form no discernible pattern one
stabilized 213 was returned to a cell where more
medical personnel were stationed alongside the
guards in order to monitor his condition and watch
for any further seizures or other adverse effects
one week later everything would change and the
true nature of scp-213 would finally be revealed
213 requested his next physical exam claiming
that he had noticed something wrong with him
while taking a shower while washing his back he
was shocked to find the skin suddenly smoothed
and unblemished the nodules had disappeared
seemingly overnight however he was more concerned
than relieved he could not shake the feeling that
even though he could not see it something worse
had replaced them a cursory examination could not
identify anything in place of the nodules however
a closer inspection revealed that there was indeed
something there where there had one spin lumps of
tissue there were now thin Cuts Like surgical
incisions less than one millimeter in width
guards rushed to the examination room where the
sound of a terrified scream echoed through the
Halls they found the medical examiner white as a
sheet and trembling while she had been examining
the incisions on 213 skin the one on his left palm
had opened to reveal an eye though she could not
explain how she knew that the eye was watching her
that it could see what she was doing and wanted to
understand it 213 was permanently transferred to
a medical wing of the facility and placed under
constant observation the appearance of this eye
sparked a new hypothesis among the research team
scp-213's anomalous properties are not his own
indeed his body is not his own either some sort
of parasite is residing within him watching his
surroundings through eyes buried beneath the skin
it is vaporizing matter in an attempt to protect
itself from harm and possibly as a means of
feeding itself when the eye first appeared and the
Parasite Hypothesis was introduced scp-213 began
to panic he begged the research team to remove the
parasite from his body to cut him open and extract
it by any means necessary they refused and 213 had
to be sedated in order to keep him from attacking
any of the medical staff whatever is living inside
of 213 it does not show up on medical scans it
cannot or will not communicate with the research
team about its nature or what it might want the
more the medical team tests on it the larger it
seems to grow with more and more tiny incisions
appearing on 213's body through which the entity
can look scp-213 had been placed in a medically
induced coma until the parasitic entity can be
better understood and perhaps even removed from
his body in the meantime Perhaps it is better for
him and every living thing around him if he just
stays asleep ever since we took those first steps
out of the primordial soup mankind has long since
looked to the night sky and dreamed of setting Out
Among the Stars space is as it has been said the
final frontier the vast Inky void that for all its
perils still holds a sense of wonder and calls us
to venture out and explore the cosmos the earliest
missions of the Space Race during the 50s and 60s
showed the people of Earth that while it wasn't
easy the dream of achieving space travel was
possible and that dream the willingness to chase
it is all you really need to get there well that
plus a couple of friends and a Volkswagen Microbus
for William that dream of travel away from Earth
and up to the starry Skies was inescapable at 21
he was a guy like many others growing up in the
50s his friends and family all thought of him
as a bit of a beatnik who was in deep with a
lot of hip counterculture types William had even
dabbled in a few alternative religious groups as
well most notably practices like the action
of Transcendental Meditation as well as the
teachings of meher Baba an Indian spiritual leader
who claimed to be God in human form in other words
William would have been a full-blown hippie in
the 60s if he'd only lived long enough to see them
even now the idea of taking a summer road trip
with a small group of close friends is an unheard
of and that's almost exactly what William had in
mind during the summer of 1958 but with a few key
differences for one this was said to be a one-way
road trip with zero plans for a return journey and
why you guessed it it was because William and his
Pals wanted to go to outer space more specifically
they wanted to drive to space to Leave the World
Behind and cruise all the way out into the shining
lights of the solar system in March William
bought a brand new Microbus a Volkswagen Type 2
Samba bus after pulling money for a down payment
with his three friends Jerry Sam and Susan ask
anyone nowadays to picture an old school Minivan
and they'd probably end up describing the exact
same type of bus what had spurred them to buy
a bus in the hopes of traveling off world in it
while the three had recently been excommunicated
from the fifth Church a highly secretive New Age
religion members of the church or fithists
are all about Conformity and control you may
remember these eccentric folks from our video on
scp-3512 the more you know but William's intention
of traveling to space seemed to conflict with the
fifth Church's beliefs most likely on account of
his free Spirit defying a group whose two Main
Hobbies were obsessing over patterns and mind
control the young man believed there was magic up
there among the stars and refused to work a boring
nine to five waiting for that magic to come down
to earth so with the help of Jerry he began to
work on modifying the bus heaven was up there and
according to William it was waiting for its Angels
it took about two months but Jerry came through
the engine compartment and cabin of the Microbus
were now airtight with the section near the rear
doors transformed into an airlock the windows were
replaced with shatterproof acrylic the outer
surface treated to withstand any space debris
the gas tank had been replaced with technology
decades ahead of its time but the steering wheel
gear shift handbrake and pedals all functioned
exactly the same one look at the outer panels of
the Microbus would have told you what it was and
where it was heading the word Starmobile was spray
painted on one side side and the other Alpha
Centauri or Bust the 4th of July rolled around
and their Starmobile took flight William keeping a
diary of their Journey referred to himself and his
friends as the only four people in the universe
who were truly free careening upwards at 82 miles
per hour without any police to stop them no longer
restricted by mundane life on Earth the group
traveled higher and higher in their Microbus their
plan was to travel straight to Alpha Centauri the
closest star and planetary system to our own solar
system thinking their Journey would only last
a few short weeks William and his friends waved
farewell to Earth the bus had everything on board
that these Intergalactic Travelers could possibly
need from bedrolls and pillows to sleep on to
enough dehydrated food to feed the four of them
for three whole months in space there was even
room aboard the Microbus for Susan's cat Millie as
well as all the Comforts of Home William and his
friends packed Bongos a guitar and countless books
but this road trip wasn't just an aimless Joyride
out into the cosmos the Intrepid group had enough
supplies with them and enough ambition to set up
the first off-world human Colony they'd practice
seed bank containing hundreds if not thousands
of varying seeds from a number of common domestic
plants from Earth on top of that there were even
Frozen egg cells of domestic animals like cats and
dogs and livestocks such as cows and pigs these
embryos were all ready to be unfrozen and allowed
to grow once the gang reached their destination
however it didn't take long for problems to
start arising for one the group quickly ran
out of Libations within the first five days of
leaving Earth Spirits were naturally dampened by
the absence of spirits but William tried to remain
optimistic hoping to grow barley and concoct
some homemade Brew once they arrived at Alpha
Centauri but while the lack of Ale and lager was
an inconvenience there was worse on the horizon
during a group sing-along something collided with
the Starmobile naturally All Aboard were rattled
and it was Jerry who stepped up to calm everyone
stating it was likely just space dust or debris
he opted to take a look outside and see if there
had been any damage to the Microbus donning a
homemade spacesuit Jerry left via the airlock
at the rear of the bus and examined finding no
significant harm had been done but as he was
about to make his way back inside something struck
the Starmobile again the force of it caused Jerry
to lose his grip sending him drifting out into
space William was the only one at the wheel of
the bus but had never learned to drive eventually
he was able to turn the samba bus around but it
was too late Jerry was dead adrift in the cold
vacuum the loss overwhelmed the group but hit
Susan worst of all she and Jerry had wanted to get
married the moment they arrived at Alpha Centauri
William had even obtained a Minister's license
so he could officiate his friend's wedding that
would now never happen three days later Sam and
William awoke to find Susan dead on the floor of
the bus the grief and sorrow had gotten too much
for her according to William's diary she died of
a broken heart drawing up his guitar and strumming
Amazing Grace for his second dead friend William
watched as Sam let Susan's body drift out of the
airlock he wrote In This Journal that he hoped
she would find Jerry out there in space and at
least they would be together by now it had been
well over 50 days since the Starmobile had left
the safe confines of planet Earth the group had
suffered two tragic heartbreaking casualties
already one by accident and one as a result of
the first and yet William and Sam the survivors
were still traveling even deeper into the Dark
Void above plotting their chorus to Alpha Centauri
as best they could with the hand-drawn Star Charts
they had brought with Femme so far their journey
into space had begun with promise and optimism
and was now fraught with dangers and obstacles and
these were far from over slowly William began to
realize that it was taking much longer to reach
their destination than he and Jerry had first
anticipated Alpha centauri's roughly four and a
half light years from Earth bear in mind that a
single light year is equivalent to roughly
6 trillion miles William was unsure if the
Microbus had been traveling in the right direction
or if it had even managed to miss the Terminus of
the journey the charts Jerry had drawn were of
little help he had been the expert the one who
planned the trip and modified the Volkswagen Type
2 Samba bus for space travel William was out of
his depth hurtling through the Galaxy with Little
Help from his passenger to make matters worse
both William and Sam had started feeling unwell
not just travel sick as you might expect after
spending a long ride in the Microbus trundling
through space their illness wasn't even caused by
being trapped in the cramped space for such a long
duration of time blotches had begun to appear all
over their skin and Sam had been having trouble
eating at random even a tooth spontaneously fell
out of his mouth these aren't symptoms typical
of space travel though due to a severe lack of
vitamin C in the food they had packed the pair
of them had developed scurvy just as it seemed
like a trip to Alpha Centauri couldn't have been a
bigger disaster William awoke to see something out
of the Microbus window something he had probably
seen hundreds of times in his lifetime but seeing
it now filled him with dread it was the moon as
in Earth's Moon they were barely close to Alpha
Centauri quickly realizing that they would never
reach their destination on their current course
due to their Grievous errors in calculation
William did the only thing he could he closed
the curtains so that Sam couldn't see how big of
a mistake they had made eventually Millie crawled
behind the sofa and died meanwhile Sam stopped
being able to keep his food down towards the end
he could barely so much as see or even sit every
time he asked his friend if they had arrived yet
William would tell him that they would be there
tomorrow he couldn't bring himself to tell Sam
the truth finally Sam asked William to read to him
a poem by Dylan Thomas called and Death Shall Have
No Dominion he was dead before William finished
reading saddened and filled with remorse William
pushed the last of his friends out of the airlock
realizing that no one would be left to push him
out whenever he eventually died the final thought
he recorded in his diary came after two whole
months spent isolated and alone in space before
William's death the last thing he wrote was that
the Stars looked so beautiful against the dark
backdrop of the universe in spite of the tragedy
of his situation so few others especially from his
time would ever truly see them like this today the
bus is still drifting quietly through space now
known as scp-1958 it rests in the orbit of Mars
the withered remains of its driver still sitting
at the wheel William and his friends never made it
to Alpha Centauri in fact it would have taken them
almost 40 million years to reach it they never
saw their dream come to the ending that they had
planned instead William Jerry Sam Susan and Millie
the cat all died Among the Stars driving their
magic bus their Starmobile out into the unknown
for them space that final frontier had a lot more
finality to it water the Wellspring of Life we've
dealt with a number of anomalous water sources on
this channel like scp-006 the much sought after
Fountain of Youth or the terrifying scp-3280
where murderous water threatens to destroy the
entire world but we've never seen anomalous water
that behaves quite like this before in many of the
legends of King Arthur the sword of Excalibur is
presented to him by the mystical Lady of the Lake
this lady emerges from the depths of the water
gifting Arthur with the enchanted sword it's an
incredible if impossible image a woman appearing
from within the lake rising up from the bottom and
breaking through the surface it's safe to say
that none of us have ever seen anything quite
like it well at least most of us haven't in a
small unnamed English Village there was a young
woman who set out on a particularly lovely warm
spring day to take a swim in a nearby lake while
waiting in the water enjoying the sunlight and the
gentle breeze on her skin she saw a strange Ripple
ghost across the surface she stopped her swimming
staring at the motion she expected to spot a fish
or some other aquatic creature instead the water
itself began to rise up Gathering and forming
into a shape before her eyes it was impossible and
yet here it was happening she pinched herself and
found that she was definitely awake as the water
transformed into the shape of a human woman it
turned to look at her shimmering eyes finding hers
and liquid lips forming into a warm inviting smile
though this being was shocking to see it clearly
meant her no harm it raised a translucent arm and
gave her a small wave as if to welcome her to
its home the young woman approached this Lady
of the Lake reaching out her own hand of Flesh
and bone to touch this Impossible Creature just
as her fingertips reached the water woman's own
the figure dissolved back into the lake with a
splash the young woman ran home telling anyone
who would listen about the incredible thing she
had seen that day of course no one believed her
that is until word of her sighting reached the
only people who might take her claim seriously the
SCP Foundation they sent operatives to the lake
where they managed to capture the shape-shifting
entity dwelling there scp-054 also known as the
water nymph is a being made up entirely of water
with an average volume of 90 liters when it is
out of a body of water the being tends to adopt
the appearance of a humanoid woman though it is
capable of taking on a variety of other shapes
including other humanoids animals and various
inanimate objects The Entity is also capable of
shedding its form and effectively disappearing
into a given body of water in order to avoid
shrinking or possibly disappearing entirely
from evaporation scp-054 is required to return
to a larger body of water studies of samples
taken from the entity's body or its version of
a body revealed that it is made up of ordinary
water there is no apparent reason for its ability
to move and no thermal electromagnetic biological
or Supernatural anomalies where were detected the
research team could not determine what might make
this water alive and sentient and the nature of
its unusual properties is uncertain to this day
when scp-054 was first brought into containment
at site-08 it displayed surprisingly congenial
and curious Behavior often walking around outside
of the water and taking turns mimicking the shapes
of various staff and scientists that spoke to it
its demeanor began to shift towards suspicion and
aggression however following a series of
experiments and an incident involving the
research staff the first experiment conducted on
scp-054 sought to determine what would happen if
the entity was denied access to any fresh
water water was drained from the fountain
holding it leaving only enough water for it to
form a humanoid shape but no additional water
in the base and to compensate for the effects
of evaporation over time scp-054 became visibly
frustrated as the water was being drained
out of its enclosure for the next few days
it enthusiastically greeted anyone who entered
its contain attainment facility attempting to
use a report and sense of familiarity to convince
the person to provide it with more water after it
realized that this approach had no impact on
the amount of water in its Fountain it became
distant and even cold to anyone who attempted
to speak to it 054 only became friendly again
once the water in its Fountain was restored to a
pre-experiment level next the research team opted
to test scp-054's reaction to extreme temperatures
particularly extreme cold the temperature of the
containment facility was slowly dropped until the
room fell below the freezing point of water as
the temperature dropped 054 became sluggish and
exhausted it lost its ability to shift between
forms remaining locked in its preferred humanoid
female shape its movement slowed more and more
as the room grew colder until the entity was
completely frozen solid portions of the ice were
chipped off and studied revealing the crystals
were identical to those of ordinary ice after
the Sub-Zero testing the re research team decided
to take things to the other end of the spectrum
and test the effects of heat on scp-054 the
subject was placed in a tank outfitted with
heating equipment and its temperature was slowly
raised over the course of several minutes when the
water reached a temperature of 95 degrees
the entity's behavior became frenetic and
aggressive it pounded on the glass walls of the
tank and attempted to break through the lid in a
desperate bid for escape until the temperature was
returned to a comfortable level after the extreme
temperature experiments the previous column
and Cooperative nature of scp-054 was nowhere
to be found this subject displayed increased
suspicion of the research team and would fight
back whenever it was removed from its Fountain
and taken to a lab for experimentation in spite
of this newfound resistance the team decided to
continue their experiments as planned hoping that
the entity would return to its formerly docile
self over time next Dr seskel the acting head
of the research team conducted a study involving
scp-054's memory and ability to be conditioned
The Entity was presented with a series of
increasingly complex mazes and puzzles when
it failed to comply with the experiment or solved
a puzzle incorrectly The Entity was punished with
an electrical shock or the release of silica
gel into its body both of these options seem
to cause it a great deal of pain and distress
and it was eager to avoid further exposure to
them scp-054 displayed impressive learning
and problem-solving capabilities revealing
it is likely much more intelligent than it
was first presumed to be Dr seskel observing
the experiments and with the effectiveness of
his somewhat unsavory motivational techniques
quipped to his research assistant that they would
have it trained to fetch in no time after several
days of these experiments and repeated use of
both the silica gel and electrical shocks the
entity's progress slowed down considerably and
it became visibly exhausted it was removed from
the lab for a 48-hour rest period before
experimentation was resumed yet again this
Time Dr seskel planned to expose scp-054's water
source to various levels of acids and bases
in order to test its homeostatic capabilities
beginning with a 0.5 M solution of hydrochloric
acid prior to conducting the experiment Dr seskel
noted I have no idea what will happen but if this
thing incorporates homeostatic mechanisms like
I suspect then we should get some insight into
how it maintains its form he also noted that
scp-054's behavior was becoming increasingly
erratic but made the decision to continue with
the experiment as planned scp-054 displayed
a now familiar reluctance when it was removed
from its containment chamber and taken to the
lab it thrashed around in the fountain splashing
researchers with water and retreated from them
as they approached in spite of its efforts
however it was removed from its Fountain and
placed in the experimental tank the solution of
hydrochloric acid was then dripped into the tank
and then all hell broke loose as soon as the
acid touched the surface of its water scp-054
became incredibly distressed it Formed into the
shape of a human face eyes wide mouth open in
a Silent Scream Of Rage and pain the water
churned so aggressively that the lid of the
tank was shaken loose allowing it to escape the
boundaries of its containment the water formed
into two large hands which shot out of the tank
and grabbed the two nearest researchers pulling
them into the water and exposing their skin to
the acid now present there as the men scrambled
to drag themselves back out of the tank and their
colleagues were busy helping them scp-054 took on
its usual humanoid form and ran for the door
it then collapsed into a puddle slipped under
the crack in the bottom of the door and made its
way down the hall it was apprehended roughly 10
minutes after its Escape by a team of guards who
froze it using canisters of liquid nitrogen and
then carried its icy body back to the containment
facility the two researchers who had been pulled
into the tank experienced chemical burns on their
skin as well as significant mental distress they
were given immediate medical attention and placed
on a leave of absence and all experimentation on
scp-054 was suspended until further notice at the
recommendation of Dr Siskel 054's object class was
changed to Euclid scp-054 is currently contained
in a watertight isolation room fitted with climate
control equipment a beautiful intricately designed
Fountain has been placed in the center of the
containment room filled with fresh spring water
in order to accommodate the entity's environmental
needs all maintenance workers assigned to the
area must wear NBC suits while inside and must
spend 10 minutes isolated in a drying room After
exiting before they are permitted to return to the
rest of the facility if 054 breaches containment
the area must be evacuated and the containment
chamber will be filled with liquid nitrogen in
order to freeze its water solid as the entity
is highly sensitive to the conditions of the
water that houses it chemical levels and volume
of the water in the fountain must be monitored
on a regular basis a and kept at optimal levels
for the health of scp-054 during the course of
its containment following the incident around
the acid-base incorporation experiment 054 has
developed a distrust of men as the researchers
handling that experiment were primarily male in
order to prevent future incidents and keep scp-054
calm no male staff are to be assigned to the team
monitoring its containment unit because five years
have passed since the last incident involving
scp-054 its object class has been changed from
Euclid to safe on the recommendation of the lead
researcher assigned to its case of course caution
should still be exercised while interacting with
the entity this is the SCP Foundation after all
and just because a moderate amount of water is
good for you doesn't mean you can't still drown
experimentation on scp-054 has resumed though
this time its boundaries are being honored and
it is allowed adequate time to rest and recuperate
between experiments all use of punishment in order
to motivate the in entity has been suspended as
it has shown itself to be more than willing to
cooperate if it is treated with respect like
all of us it responds far better to kindness
than it does to fear and intimidation it doesn't
just take on the appearance of a person it has
thoughts feelings and the urge to defend itself
when threatened so think twice next time you find
yourself swimming in a random body of water
you should be mindful of what might be living
in there not just of the fish the algae and the
tiny water bugs but of the invisible intelligent
impossible creatures that might be swimming in
there with you or even make up the very water
itself what is it that makes a person a hero is
it a trait that you're born with something that
you can inherit passed down from generation
to generation is someone still a hero if they
never save a life but improve the lives of the
people that matter to them do you really need
a magic hammer an enchanted suit of armor or a
tragic origin story in order to become a hero
or can you still be heroic as an ordinary everyday
person through the simplest of kind Deeds maybe it
only takes a few moments in a lifetime to be
a hero moments when you are given the chance
to overcome adversity or conquer a personal
flaw perhaps learning how to deal with defeat
and get back up after rather than learning how
to never be defeated is the essence of heroism
we can all be heroes every single one of us and
in a way we already are everyone is the hero of
Their Own Story and if you want any further proof
of that then maybe you should take a look inside
scp-1230 an unassuming book is presented to you
its hardcover is dark green but other than that
there is absolutely nothing remarkable about it
that you can notice but little do you know this
book that you hold in your hands is none other
than scp-1230 so what's inside surely it must
be an important anomalous artifact if the SCP
Foundation has an interest in it perhaps it's
filled with ancient spells or a mathematical
formula to calculate the exact mass of the
fabric of reality now if you're expecting every
page to be full you'd be disappointed in fact
only the first page you open in the book will have
anything written on it the rest will appear blank
and this can change depending on which page you
open first resetting every time the book is closed
again however the phrase you will find written on
that page will always stay the same when opening
scp-1230 you will see the words a hero is born
what happens after you read these words well
not much at least not right away in fact you
won't notice any active effects after reading
scp-1230 for quite some time until that is you
fall asleep and as you sleep you begin to dream
now most streams are pretty disjointed sometimes
fragments of memories or your deepest most random
thoughts of course other times it's a fear a
long-held and deep-rooted phobia or manifestation
of anxiety brought to the surface for a while
in the form of a nightmare only to be forgotten
by the time you've woken off perhaps that's why
so many people look for the deeper meaning to
their dreams to get a better understanding of
themselves but this dream is different far more
Vivid and memorable with a meaning that is a lot
easier to discern in this stream you find yourself
as the hero of your own story the protagonist of
a Fantastical Adventure it's more than an ordinary
dream it looks sounds smells feels as real as the
Ordinary World you know you will find yourself at
the center of a fantasy world where you are the
hero destined to Aid this troubled land to bring
peace and save the world the fantasy you find
yourself in is different depending on who you
are it's a Dreamscape that has been tailor-made
for your enjoyment and your Epic Quest awaits on
the path laid out in front of you but where do
these bespoke fantasy Adventures come from does
the scp-1230 book itself bestow these dreams on a
reader or is there some other Force at play that
creates worlds where the dreamer is the hero
well actually yes there is and his name is the
bookkeeper or scp-1230-1 he looks exactly as you
would imagine him too an old man adorned in a dark
green cloak with a long beard sometimes appearing
to dreamers in order to guide them picture Gandalf
from The Lord of the Rings books but instead of
the gray or the white the bookkeeper is Gandalf
the Green in every dream caused by scp-1230 the
bookkeeper appears as the personification of
the book itself often aiding dreamers willingly
offering them counsel guidance and help on their
Fantastical quests in an experiment to test the
range of scp-1230s anomalous properties an SCP
Foundation researcher opened the book token and
boarded a domestic flight spending the night in
a hotel in his hometown even miles away from
the book The researchers still experienced
a Fantastical dream and during this dream he was
approached by scp-1230-1 the bookkeeper was happy
to explain the workings of the book describing
how scp-1230 implanted a dream in the reader's
subconscious mind from the moment they saw the
phrase a hero is born on the page he claimed
that he was the sole being with the ability to
manipulate what he described as fantasy Scapes and
that he enjoyed doing this aiming to sculpt these
Fantastical dreams in such a way that the dreamer
experiencing them would get the most enjoyment out
of being the hero of Their Own Story thanks to the
bookkeeper the length of the dreams vary they
could be quick only lasting 45 seconds or seemed
to last as long as 200 years from the dreamer's
point of view however in the real world the person
experiencing the bookkeeper's fantasy Escape would
only actually be asleep for an average duration of
time scp-1230 only takes effect on living beings
with the capacity for imagination in other words
only human beings are affected by the book and are
able to enter their own bespoke fantasy when the
SCP Foundation attempted to use a mechanical arm
to open scp-1230 the pages remain blank leading
the bookkeeper to explain to a subsequent dreamer
that only beings who can dream may find the phrase
a hero is born within most animals or any machines
that view the book will not experience its effects
at all so what can a person do within the fantasy
escapes of these dreams is it an open sandbox to
do anything and everything you can think of or do
these Fantastical Realms have their own rules well
for a start they do seem to be completely safe
spaces during testing the foundation conducted
a number of experiments that involve getting
members of d-class personnel to read scp-1230
and test the limitation nations of the dream
Worlds the bookkeeper created for them why use
d-class Personnel to test out something seemingly
as harmless as scp-1230 because the foundation
wanted to know if a person could die in one of
these streams one test involved ordering a d-class
to immediately find a way to terminate himself
once he found himself inside the dream world he
awakened after only 45 seconds of being asleep and
described being at the peak of a volcano called
the Ashen Spire apparently within the dream the
test subject had been sent on a quest to recover
a sword known as caledus The Blessed blade he
said these names had come to him as if he had
known them all along following the foundation's
orders the d-class attempted to throw himself into
the volcano before him only to wake up moments
later after feeling intense heat but suffering
no adverse effects in the real world during the
following experiment another d-class was told to
try and injure himself in the fantasy Escape but
not a fatal injury the subject to Wellcare after
six hours of sleep feeling a numbed pain in the
same place he had attempted to harm himself but
this sensation was never intense in fact it was
barely noticeable in his dream the d-class said
that he had conversed with the bookkeeper who had
shown concern that the man was trying to cause
himself injury but thanked him for not terminating
himself immediately like the other rude fellow
that had preceded him so all of this sounds pretty
great right a book that lets someone live out a
fantasy Adventure in which they are the hero
of Their Own bespoke Story what could possibly
be the downside well the downside is this what if
someone preferred their fantasy to the real world
now comes the unfortunate story of a professor
working for the SCP Foundation a lifelong fan of
tabletop role-playing games like Dungeons and
Dragons the professor filled the request for
access to scp-1230 and it was granted he was
apparently shaking with pure excitement after
reading a hero is born in the book he didn't even
wait until later to go to sleep instead opting to
doze off right then and there at the desk where
he had read it after the professor had spent
15 entire hours of sleep concern had begun to
spread among the other researchers he remained
sleeping living out his own fantasy adventure for
a further nine hours spending a total of 24 hours
in the dream world that the bookkeeper had made
for him when the professor awoke he appeared to
look around the room confused unsure of where he
was when approached by the foundation's security
Personnel medical staff examined him and explained
where he was after which the professor seemed to
regain his memory after being reminded who
he was the professor excused himself to the
restroom he didn't emerge and 15 minutes later a
member of the medical team went to check on him
sadly the professor was dead scribbled on the
nearby bathroom wall was one simple phrase his
last words I can't go back to this attempting
to immediately use scp-1230 in May make contact
with the bookkeeper another doctor tried to find
the a hero is born phrase within the pages of the
book however instead the pages were soaking wet
and on every single page the same message I am
so sorry I never intended for this to happen I
just wanted to make people happy for three weeks
the book stayed like this until the same doctor
placed a sticky note inside scp-1230 that said
I'd like to talk to you if that's all right that
night the doctor fell asleep and dreamed of being
in a Dark Void there was only one source of light
in the endless Darkness a Street Lamp under which
he found the bookkeeper sat in a puddle the old
bearded man was sobbing uncontrollably his cloak
soaking wet with his tears he explained through
his overwhelming sadness what had happened to
the professor he had such an active imagination I
was able to create a vast and beautiful Universe
for him and it was obvious that he wanted a
life like that for so long he God could foul
beasts and rescued princesses he built kingdoms
and even raised a family but he never wanted to
leave he delved so far into his fantasy world
and I soon realized he preferred his dream over
the real world I reminded him that this was all
merely an illusion but he wouldn't listen to me
he stated that if he was ever forced to leave he
would immediately end his life I tried to keep
him happy for as long as I could the bookkeeper
revealed that from the professor's point of view
the fantasy life he had lived lasted 200 years as
much as the old man had tried to hold on and keep
the professor happy for as long as possible
eventually he had to release him from the
fantasy escape and as a result the professor had
ended his own life rather than return to reality
scp-1230 resumed its normal function a few days
later after the doctor left another note between
the pages offering some friendly advice to the
bookkeeper now it sits quietly on a bookshelf in
the site-12 library surrounded by fictional
novels the perfect material to inspire more
fantasy Scapes in the future we all like to dream
that we're the heroes of our own stories but to
quote the bookkeeper himself how sweet his dreams
may be eventually we all have to wake up drip drip
drip if you see The Telltale black mucus dripping
from the wall behind you splattering down from the
ceiling then it is already too late for you the
plaster will start to split the wood will warp
and rot metal will Rust you should try to run
attempt to hide but know that he is coming for
you the old man limping along relentlessly never
stopping to rest to eat to catch his breath he
has no need for such human things anymore
you can't fight him you can't reason with
and you can't kill what might as well already be
dead just when you think you've found a safe place
to hide you'll hear a creaking from the floor
below you a blinding pain is something sharp
slashes through your Achilles tendon is the last
thing you will feel before the decrepit nightmare
Vision drags you to his lair never to return even
if you could Escape now the sickness is already in
you skin already slackening and muscles beginning
to liquefy he is rot he is death he is the
disintegration of all hope and light and he has
made you his prey we've covered scp-106 or the old
man before we've talked about his abilities his
hunting patterns an incident in which he escaped
and a variety of theories regarding his origin
it is unknown for sure where exactly the old man
came from there are three major theories as to his
true origin which created one of the most fearsome
anomalies the SCP Foundation has ever come across
perhaps he was a deeply Disturbed World War one
soldier who gazed too long into something better
left untouched perhaps he was never human at all
but instead a Divergent humanoid species
that preyed on early prehistoric mankind
today we're focusing on the third possibility and
arguably the most tragic of the three it begins
with another man we've covered on the channel
before named Dr Robert Scranton and his wife Dr
Anna Lang you probably know them for two things
the Scranton reality anchor and The Accidental
discovery of scp-3001 or the red reality in case
you haven't seen our video on the subject here's
a brief recap of the whole unfortunate affair
on January 2nd 2000 at site 120 Robert and
Anna were hard at work as the head researchers
developing an experimental device known as The
Lang Scranton stabilizer the LSS was intended to
work as a reality anchor but it was in its early
stages and still unstable a seismic event rocked
the research site damaging several LSS units and
creating a wormhole that transported Dr Scranton
to the pocket Dimension Hereafter referred to
as scp-3001 this little pocket of space this
impossible world just adjacent to ours has some
unusual properties it causes matter within it to
deteriorate as its Hume level approaches that of
the environment Humes being the measurement unit
for reality stability Robert Scranton was trapped
there in the red reality alive for a terrifyingly
long time five years 11 months and 21 days before
the logs he kept ended there he struggled to hold
on to himself he grasped desperately at shreds of
his Humanity his memories even as the world around
him slowly ate them away finally only one thing
remained Anna wife he could just barely remember
her name remember that he wanted to get back to
her there was a brief moment of Hope on December
23 2005 when the LSS control panel reappeared in
a Testing Lab at site 120. Dr Anna Lang arrived
to monitor the situation a massive bloody organic
matter appeared alongside it and as Anna called
out for her lost love something clattered to the
floor and broke her heart her husband's wedding
ring stained with unidentified organic matter
smelling of black blood and spoiled meat she
collapsed under the weight of the possibility that
her husband was no longer lost in a physical sense
but in another sense entirely that this mass of
Flesh unrecognizable as human might be the man she
once loved tying his favorite tie for him on date
nights dancing drunkenly to Living on a Prayer
collapsing on the couch together breathless with
laughter and the sheer Joy of one another that he
could be both here here at last but Gone Forever
Dr Anna Lang was taken to the medical Bay and
treated for shock years passed after Ana's last
encounter with her husband she carried the ring
with her in her pocket every day for the first few
after five years she threaded the chain through it
wearing it around her neck under her clothes after
10 more years she stopped noticing it was even
on anymore it had become a part of her engraved
on her heart with the memories of the man she had
loved lost and grieved with nothing to go home to
at the end of the day no one to share her time off
with Anna began to pour herself deeper into her
work she would never remarry she knew that Robert
had been the only man for her now there was only
her commitment to the foundation and the research
she did there and the silent promise she made to
herself that she would never let anything like the
events of January 2nd 2000 happen again but will
they with no reason to go home honest nights at
the lab grew later and later her colleagues often
joke that she might as well sleep there since that
was the only thing she went home to do the sadness
behind her eyes tended to cut their jokes short
soon after making them though Anna liked the late
night work the lab was still almost Serene she
could disappear into the research the calculations
let them take over and quiet the noise in her
mind the lights were dimmed no one was asking
her a name questions or bustling around while
she'd tried to focus there was nothing but her
notes and textbooks the light of her lone desk
lamp glowing softly in the dark and the work it
was one of these late nights buried in a mountain
of paperwork that Anna began to hear a strange
sound she didn't notice it at first absorbed as
she was in a sea of calculations but soon it began
to permeate the room breaking through her focus
a rustling sound a crackling of sorts quietly
murmuring into her ears though she was vaguely
aware of it the way you might be aware of the wind
rustling through the trees outside your bedroom
window she didn't truly hear it until she smelled
something faint but foul it was no matter how
muted the unmistakable scent of rot she stepped
down from her lab stool her joints creaking
with effort as she worked out the stiffness
in her muscles she adjusted her glasses peering
into the shadows for the source of the sound but
saw nothing of note she took a step forward into
the dark then another and then another behind her
the desk lamp flickered then cut out entirely she
stopped blinking in the sudden complete darkness
and sudden silence the noise had stopped the only
sound was her breathing quickened with fear she
pulled the phone from her pocket and turned on
its flashlight using its weak beam to light her
way she turned back to her desk looking for the
issue that caused the light to cut out perhaps a
short in the wire or a bulb that needed changing
before she could take a look at the lamp however
something else caught her eye there was something
slick and red on her stack of papers dripping onto
the clean white surface and staining it with Gore
a closer look revealed what it was and a shiver
ran down her spine a kidney fresh and human she
couldn't bring herself to touch it but somehow
knew that if she did it would be warm her heart
pounding and her suddenly tightening chest as the
noise resumed behind her wet slapping louder than
before her feet moved on their own accord as she
walked toward the sound holding the flashlight in
front of her in a shaking hand the black wall of
the lab illuminated by the light was smeared with
something dark and strange slick like oil but with
a rotten smell a closer look revealed that the
wall itself was beginning to change drooping
limply like wet cardboard she froze watching
helplessly as the wall bubbled crumbling to Pieces
suddenly a hand emerged from the wall gray skin
slick with black fluid its fingers surprisingly
strong gripped her arm she tore it away scrambling
back and saw that pieces of her lab coat had come
off melting into the gray skin of the alien hand
as the arm reached for her again she stumbled and
dropped her phone on the floor casting its light
against the wall and the figure warming its way
out there it was an old man naked and gray with
slimy decaying skin coming off in pieces its
throat was shredded an open wound and it grinned
at her with stiff shriveled lips stretched over
blackened teeth its eyes were the worst part
even admits the rest of the Walking Corpse
they were almost like a man's they were correct
in shape and placement but they were wrong they
were empty clouded over and void of any warmth
or Mercy as he stood there the ground beneath
him began to dissipate melting into an oily puddle
that enveloped her phone and stuffed out its light
there was only one thing left for Anna to do and
so she ran she turned and made a break for the
lab doors lungs burn learning from the effort
she cried out for the guard on night Duty Frank
her voice was shrill and pleading he appeared from
around the corner gun already drawn eyes wide and
alert at the Panic he must have heard in her voice
as Frank tried to calm her down and she tried
desperately to explain what she had seen the old
man forced his way through the lab doors leaving
a trail of corrosive black slime in his wake
Frank fired his gun hitting the old man in the
chest twice he collapsed sinking into the floor
as his excretion broke away the tiles beneath him
as Anna and Frank debated what to do next a drip
of black mucus landed on Frank's radio from above
another drop fell Landing directly in his eye he
screamed in agony the mucus dissolving his eyeball
on contact next the empty grin appeared through
the ceiling and the old man fell on top of Frank
tearing out his throat with its bare hands Anna
knew that she had to escape but where could she
go she couldn't think couldn't plan she just knew
she had to run she ran until her feet suddenly
stopped obeying she was stuck she was sinking
into the ground and then she was falling down
down into a moldy Dusty hallway dark except for a
nauseating greenish gray glow she had been pulled
into some new nightmarish world she ran through
a nearby door and found herself shockingly in
her old apartment how had she gotten here how did
the old man know this place there was her bed her
desk her closet she flung open the closet door
to find a pile of rotten corpses that poured out
and slopped onto the floor she covered her mouth
to choke back a scream turned and fled then she
was back in the hall this time she recognized it
it was a twisted warped version of sight 120. in
front of her there he was the old man had found
her again and now she was in his territory he
stared at her with those Hollow eyes and for
the first time spoke he growled she stopped in
her tracks Frozen to the spot what he said next
turned her stomach and brought tears to her eyes
he knew her name again he repeated
he reached out to her with a hand that had a tan
line where a wedding ring had one spin the same
ring burning against her skin under her shirt
he cupped her cheek and she felt the skin sting
and blister he kissed her her teeth melting
infusing tongue turning to Mush but dribbled
down her throat and choked her her last thought
through the fear and despair was the Egg of love
her husband was not lost he was found and he had
found her too now they would be together forever
not all heroes wear capes some of them wear
Pokemon t-shirts and a baseball cap you might
think you've heard of every superhero out there
with Marvel and DC dominating the box office and
the incredible cactus man fighting crime on the
Mean Streets of Edinburgh but there is one tiny
aspiring hero you'd likely never heard of in a
world filled with danger and evildoers one young
boy armed with a a pure heart and some telekinetic
Powers dared to step up and save the day a woman
was being abducted at gunpoint when seven-year-old
Cameron spotted the struggle he saw the weapon in
the man's hand the fear in the woman's eyes as she
looked for a way out and he knew that he had to
act he concentrated with all his might reaching
out with his mind and threw the gun out of the
man's grasp and into some nearby bushes the woman
ran as fast as she could from there but not before
catching a glimpse of the child that had saved
her life somehow she knew that he had been her
hero unfortunately for Cameron but fortunately
for the SCP Foundation the woman reported what
had happened to a nearby police officer who just
so happened to be an undercover agent for the
foundation before Cameron could leave the scene he
was being approached by a team of armed guards and
brought to a strange new place filled with men
in lab coats who kept calling him as scp-2241
Cameron sat for a very long time in a white room
wondering whether he was in trouble when a new man
in a lab coat entered he introduced himself as
researcher Valdez and told Cameron he was going
to ask him some questions he asked why Cameron
had helped the woman instead of running away and
getting an adult to help he said Superheroes have
to help people I can move things without touching
them and other people can't so I should have used
that to help them he went on to explain that he
had practiced his ability in the woods and kept
it a secret from everyone Valdez asked what sort
of things Cameron could do and he explained I can
move stuff without touching it but not if it's too
far away or if it's too big only like a cup across
the room or a person's arm or something sometimes
I it can sort of change as well when prompted he
elaborated sometimes when I'm moving something it
changes to something I want like one time when
I was moving a stone it changed to look like
a toy I lost but it changed back after a while
before I even got home Cameron became distressed
during the interview but Valdez promised him
that he would be okay here he asked Cameron
what his superhero name would be and he told
him Cameron the Crusader Valdez explained that
Cameron would be staying at the SCP Foundation
for a while so they could learn more about his
powers and help him become a better superhero
researcher Valdez concluded his interview with
this closing statement scp-2241 appears to trust
me and believes that the foundation is attempting
to help him as much as possible scp-2241's account
is consistent with the early stages of humanoid
developing a reality bending ability scp-2241 may
have experienced abuse at the hands of its parents
leading to early development of set ability in the
event that a more developed ability is required
for research similar emotional stress can be
applied by Foundation staff scp-2241 is kept
in a standard humanoid containment chamber he is
given access to television vision and comic books
though this access can be cut off as punishment
for bad behavior he has fed three balanced meals
a day with additional treats such as chocolate
or ice cream provided after testing especially
if the testing goes on for a particularly long
time or is exceptionally stressful all Personnel
that interact with scp-2241 are to call him by
his name Cameron when interacting with him only
Cameron's assigned psychologist and specifically
designated Personnel such as Valdez are allowed
to develop a friendly relationship with him if he
becomes attached to an unapproved person they are
required to discourage this however they can after
containment procedures were established Valdez and
his team set to work putting together tests that
would use Cameron's emotions and desires to save
people in order to develop and strengthen his
abilities for the first test they deliberately
exposed Cameron to a d-class that believed him
to be a valuable hostage one that he could use
to escape from the foundation the d-class
abducted Cameron at knife point but Cameron
quickly used his reality bending ability to
turn the knife into chocolate and escape the
knife remained chocolate and did not turn back
to metal indicating his powers had grown stronger
details of events that followed this test have
been redacted from the official file but a note
from a member of the OverWatch Council provides
a peek into what might have happened scp-2241
has stated that it intends to grow stronger to
stop more people from dying and this will help
both it and Us in this aim killing a man with a
teleported bullet was a stroke of tactical genius
from the SCP object MTF Theta 17 will be ready to
respond during all further rounds of testing as a
precaution following a series of tests Each of
which included heightened emotional Stakes such
as threatening the lives of innocent bystanders
or treasured items belonging to scp-2241 his
abilities developed even further in one test a
series of armed drones were made to artificially
malfunction posing an apparent threat to
Foundation Personnel around the boy he responded
by using his telekinesis to turn the drones on
each other crashing them into one another while
only one drone remained he teleported its Weaponry
to a nearby Field leaving a harmless shell behind
in another test a bomb was detonated near a
member of d-class personnel the boy somehow
absorbed the energy of the bomb as it exploded
transforming its kinetic energy and saving the
man's life another bomb related test featured man
with a bomb strapped to him attacking a d-class
in this test it was ordered that the bomber be
taken alive Cameron responded by teleporting
the bomb vest into an explosion-proof containment
chamber and knocking the bomber unconscious with
a single punch though his tiny fish should not
have been capable of delivering such a strong
blow in another test a third bomb was placed in
scp-2241's chamber among his personal belongings
including some stuffed animals and comic books he
was very upset at this discovery and teleported
the bomb high up into the sky where it detonated
harmlessly he remained upset for a while after
repeating no one can take my things it's not fair
I'm strong I'm the Crusader moving on from bombs
the research team tasked the boy with stealing
a box from a foundation bank vault which had
been modified for extra security he teleported
himself into the Vault picked up the box and
then made a mistake he tripped the sensors
inside however he somehow slowed the sensors
down and was able to teleport himself back out
of the Vault before the alarm could sound this
was the first task given to Cameron that could
be perceived as morally gray or even villainous
but he performed it without question and this
was recorded as a notable development next a
surprised long-range attack was performed on the
foundation Side by a foundation-owned robotic
mortar 2241 became angry catching the bomb and
throwing it toward the launcher at a speed that
appeared to be approximately 1.4 times the speed
of sound it was noted that his abilities were less
focused and his demeanor more violent when he
was angry he turned to an observing researcher
and said I hate them I'm a foundation Avenger and
I hate the bad guys and I'm gonna fight them all
for the final test in this series 2D classes
were described to 2241 as civilians were held
at gunpoint in rooms with bulletproof glass
windows he was told that the guns could not
be affected by his powers the hostages needed
physical contact to be teleported to safety
and he needed to rescue them both before they
were killed shocking the research team he split
into two versions of himself each teleporting a
hostage to safety before returning to the crime
scene to subdue the bad guys he reported feeling
a bit sick afterwards but had no other adverse
effects from splitting himself into two people
by the time this series of tests were completed
he was able to teleport objects as well as his
own body duplicate himself see a few seconds
into the future and move or transform objects
within a distance of 12 meters he was excited
about these improvements referring to them as
leveling up following these tests Valdez planned
to pause the psychiatric treatment of scp-2241
in favor of a more Hands-On approach the plan was
to begin neurological testing using a surgically
implanted chip that would monitor the boy's brain
activity during combat the Ethics Committee caught
wind of this and immediately intervened they
temporarily revoked valdez's security clearance
and placed him under investigation they submitted
an official report on this decision which
read implanting a monitoring chip into a child
this young cannot be done without significant
developmental damage in later years this will
cause catastrophic problems for both the child
and long-term containment given his well-developed
capabilities additionally deploying a child in
combat even under testing conditions violates all
moral Norms Personnel involved in sweeping the
previous rapid fire our tests under the rug are
under review the testing and research surrounding
scp-2241 did not only draw the attention of the
Ethics Committee but it also caused Discord within
the OverWatch Council itself following the Ethics
Committee intervention 05-3 ordered that testing
be resumed writing these tests are more important
than one SCP regardless of essay it looks like
ankinda long-term containment and observation
is no longer a priority given the utility of
data we have collected via intensive testing
in the short term the risk of the SCP breaching
containment is minimal given its loyalty we now
know which parts of the brain deal with certain
anomalous abilities with small detail we can
see how we may even learn how to induce these
abilities and we will definitely learn how to
neutralize them to other members of the council
were horrified by this statement believing that
it won against decency and morality in a way that
could not be justified o5-4 submitted a statement
this is too far we cannot let this stand as
president this is but one step removed from Child
soldiers and even less removed from militarizing
an SCP level object an emergency council meeting
was called to address this internal disagreement
and the majority voted in favor of reinstating
testing and exonerating Valdez of all ethics
violations I believe the results will Justify both
the risks and the means we're closer than ever to
understanding the mechanism by which human brains
interact with extra normal phenomena the emotional
and eventual neurological damage to scp-2241 is
unfortunate but it is also necessary for the
advancement of our understanding in addition
due to the new modification of the monitoring
Hardware 2241 can be neutralized quickly should
it become a threat at any time after the surgery
and so the protests of the Ethics Committee were
ignored the concerned members of the OverWatch
Council overruled and Valdez was allowed to
resume his plan for test testing and preparing to
craft a super powered child into a weapon and all
the while a little boy named Cameron remained the
test subject of the SCP Foundation still dreaming
of the day when he might have a chance to save
the world the SCP Foundation is responsible for
containing some of the most dangerous forces in
the world without them we'd be at the mercy of
the plague doctor walking through the world and
killing with a touch anyone could be snapped up
by scp-106 and dragged to a painful death in his
pocket Dimension Lair there would be no one to
stop as cp682 from devouring all living things in
sight and no one to hold back the dreaded Scarlet
King from breaching our world and destroying
Life as we know it we owe them a lot for sure
and they've earned at least a thank you card and
an Edible Arrangement but containing the anomalies
of the world comes at a pretty steep cost they're
essentially fighting a war against a whole host
of world-ending entities and when you're at War
there are bound to be casualties for some people
and creatures out there the most terrifying
monster isn't 096 just trying to swallow them
whole for looking at its face or 173 just waiting
for them to turn their backs so it can snap their
neck for the unfortunates that find themselves
in the wrong place at the wrong time the scariest
monster in the world is the SCP Foundation itself
a decade ago the SCP Foundation was attempting to
recapture scp-682 which had breached containment
and was tearing its way through the southern Congo
region unable to contain the monster by other
means and desperate to stop it from killing any
more civilians the foundation decided to implement
some rather Extreme Measures they deployed a
variety of chemical agents and poisonous gases
in an attempt to slow the creature down but they
had no effect as the enormous reptile stomped
its way toward a nearby River with a highly
populated Village waiting on the other side the
foundation made the decision to take things up
a notch they launched an aerial strike deploying
several aircrafts to drop explosives on the area
around the river they destroyed large portions
of the riverbank but the environmental impact was
considered to be a necessary evil When the Smoke
finally cleared and the deafening Roars of the
Beast had gone quiet they stopped their bombing
campaign and dispatched Foundation operatives
to the scene there they found the bones of scp-682
which were quickly brought into custody before the
creature could begin to heal itself the mission
was considered a success and they were ready to
pull out all of their staff and head back to
the nearest Foundation site when one officer
spotted something floating in the nearby River it
looked like a group of human corpses face down in
the water their bodies badly burned concerned
that civilians from a nearby Village had been
inadvertently present for the bombing campaign a
team of officers was sent to investigate the river
closely what they found was not a group of dead
humans but something else entirely they were all
along the riverbank and floating in the water
approximately 212 specimens of a previously
unknown humanoid species the bodies were clustered
in groups of three to five appearing to belong to
the same family unit or social group many of them
were frozen in positions of fear or attempt to
defend themselves with some observing Personnel
comparing them to the victims of the Pompeii
eruption stuck in their final terrified moments
what appeared to be parents and children held on
to each other some covered their faces others lay
in a fetal position it seemed that they had known
something was coming to kill them but they did not
have the time or the understanding necessary to
escape it several of the bodies were removed from
the river for autopsy and examination in order to
understand more about this new possibly already
extinct species they were humanoid organisms with
an indeterminable genus and species they resume
humbled tall thin humans with absolutely no body
hair and elongated limbs the most unusual aspect
of the creatures was in their mouths their teeth
were serrated and sharp resembling those of
a crocodile in spite of these monstrous teeth
an autopsy revealed that there was no human flesh
present in any of the creature's stomachs instead
suggesting a diet of fish livestock and whatever
else they could peacefully scavenge every last
corpse was removed from the area and incinerated
to prevent any civilians from coming across them
and asking questions just when the foundation
Personnel were finally packing up and getting
ready to leave the river once and for all they
heard something it was a mournful sound something
between a man bellowing and a wild animal yelping
in pain something nearby was still very much alive
and it was screaming the officers followed the
sound and spotted one surviving specimen of the
crocodile people lying along the bank the River it
was holding its face in its hands curled up into
a ball near the water and it was wailing in agony
there were no visible injuries on the creature's
body but it was clearly extremely distressed one
officer attempted to approach the creature calling
out to it that he meant no harm and wanted to
get it some medical attention and looked up
at the officer with wide eyes and its cries went
quiet the officer grabbed his weapon afraid that
the creature might suddenly Rush him but instead
it ran into the river he jumped into the water
plunging beneath the surface and began thrashing
around after a moment of watching its struggle the
officer realized what was happening the creature
was trying to drown itself the abandoned protocol
completely at that moment diving into the water
and pulling the struggling creature back to shore
it coughed up water for several minutes all the
while trying to crawl back into the water when the
creature had finally calmed down it was brought
into Foundation custody with no further resistance
it appeared to be the last Living member
of whatever strange human crocodile hybrid
species was living in that River and it was
designated scp-6415 since it was brought into
Foundation custody scp-6415's Behavior has been
largely very consistent some scps are constantly
attempting to escape from their containment or
killing an endless revolving door of d-class
personnel but 6415 is not one of those anomalies
it is not aggressive in spite of its crocodilian
characteristics and it's content to eat the food
provided by the foundation it is fed a diet of raw
meat mostly beef and goat which is provided fresh
daily the foundation was curious to see if the
creature could be pushed to be aggressive if its
circumstances were made a little less comfortable
they deprived it of food for several days but it
did not seem to notice or even care much aside
from occasionally looking at the door to see if
new food had come they tried sleep deprivation
next blaring a loud siren sound over for the
speakers in the containment chamber anytime the
creature was observed lying down or closing its
eyes it became listless and visibly exhausted but
did not act out violently at this either after
this testing its ordinary feeding and sleep
schedule was resumed for the most part all that
scp-6415 does is eat and sleep there is however
one notable exception at random intervals scp-6415
will begin to cry sobbing intensely and appearing
to be in a state of overwhelming distress its
cries are so loud that they can be heard from
several Halls away and have caused hearing damage
and Personnel in the room with it there is no
way to stop the Creature From Crying once it has
started though providing it with a hot cup of tea
a soft blanket or a hug from a particularly Brave
and eager d-class has caused it to cry a bit more
quietly once it is finished crying after several
hours of non-stop weeping it'll lie down on the
ground and not cry anymore for weeks at a time
for a time scp-6415 was considered to be lacking
human intelligence and its containment procedures
were changed to reflect that it was held in the
standard humanoid containment chamber in the light
containment wing of site 619 with soundproof walls
because it displayed no threatening behavior
it was considered unnecessary to have any
guards placed outside 6415s chamber however after
incident 6415-01 the foundation's understanding
of the creature changed dramatically the incident
occurred when several d-class Personnel were sent
into 6415's containment chamber to feed it and
they found a harrowing sight on the wall of the
chamber The Entity had scratched a message with
its fingernails its fingertips were bloodied and
torn its hands noticeably wounded from what
must have been a great deal of effort it did
not acknowledge the Personnel that entered the
room instead it just sat on the floor staring at
its work on the wall cradling its injured hands
and crying its shoulders shook with the force of
its sobs and its tears fell to the ground pooling
around it the d-class Personnel were later unable
to report what they had seen without beginning to
cry themselves but eventually calmed down enough
to report what the creature had written please
bring them back it was a desperate plea for the
foundation to somehow reunite it with its lost
family they had previously thought the creature
to be a simple animal incapable of understanding
its own reality or communicating through clear
language this proved that the creature understood
very well what had happened to it and was feeling
the loss of its loved ones fully one d-class
officer noticed a scrap of paper likely a piece of
butcher paper from one of the creature's previous
meals with a picture drawn on it it was a crude
sketch but its subject was easily recognizable it
was the southern Congo River where 6415 was first
discovered with three features splashing in the
water the largest one resembled as cp6415 and it
was swimming alongside a slightly smaller adult
of its species and a much smaller creature that
appeared to be a juvenile of the same species
context clues indicated that this was a drawing
of scp-6415's family its partner and their child
at first the foundation researchers were uncertain
who exactly the creature was referring to in its
initial message but this drawing made it perfectly
clear it wanted its family back it is uncertain
whether or not the creature is aware that its
family is dead but it clearly feels their absence
just the same and believes the foundation might
have the power to end its suffering Foundation
Personnel who were exposed to the details of
the incident became inconsolable falling into
a deep bout of depression brought on by a sense
of Shame and responsibility when counseling
sessions proved ineffective the emotionally
affected staff were given amnestics to wipe their
memory of the incident and of 6415 altogether one
employee research assistant Cheryl Cruz attempted
to release the creature from its containment
insisting that it deserved to roam free however
when she opened the door to its containment
facility the creature made no move to leave it
just stared at her tears in its eyes as if it knew
that it had nowhere else to go research assistant
Cruz was given a powerful amnestic and relieved
of her position at the foundation her current
whereabouts are unknown in order to prevent any
more Reckless Behavior from sympathetic staff
the message scratched into the wall was painted
over and the sketch recovered from its chamber was
destroyed but even if the memories and evidence of
the creature's pain are gone anyone walking
by its chamber can still hear it weeping it
is uncertain what the containment procedures
for scp-6415 will become it is not simply an
animal and clearly understands language though it
appears to be incapable of speech if it could talk
whatever it said would surely be heartbreaking
for now the entity remains in itself serving as
a grim reminder of the guilt that weighs on the
foundation's conscience no matter what they do
with 6415 they cannot take back what they did
they cannot lift the weight of the creature's
grief or bring back its lost family it is the Lone
Survivor sitting in its foundation's cell weeping
for its broken heart and begging the foundation
for the one thing it can never do bring them back
the SCP Foundation is no stranger to containing
dangerous entities capable of Taking Lives without
discretion but some of those entities aren't just
Mindless monsters they're people with feelings and
desires stuck in an unfortunate circumstance
granted unnatural abilities by fate or chance
for a lot of human anomalies contained by the
foundation it's not a stretch to say that they
most likely wish they were ordinary like anyone
else that they didn't have to be locked up in a
containment cell for the rest of their lives as
the years have gone by the foundation much like
any organization has changed a lot more facilities
have pushed for ethical and Humane treatment of
anomalies some going so far as to integrate
safe anomalies into the command structure of
the organization itself with groups such as the
Ethics Committee keeping the foundation's most
Hardline normalcy supremacists from mistreating
or mishandling the objects that are supposed to
contain it's hard to imagine that anything would
slip by the ever watchful eye of the foundation's
surveillance network but in an organization this
large incidents are still bound to happen while
anomalies can be dangerous the foundation as a
whole backs the ideal then they should be given
ethical treatment at least as much as they can
afford for safer less dangerous anomalies this is
a lot easier to enforce to suggest Rehabilitation
efforts and recreational privileges to be given
to an anomaly capable of ending human life at a
moment's notice raises a lot more eyebrows even
in the most Progressive sex of the foundation that
line becomes blurred when dealing with intelligent
entities what defines intelligence sapiens what
distinguishes as cp682 the indestructible lizard
with a massive disgust for all life from scp-239
and ultimately innocent little girl with world
breaking reality bending Powers this is the sort
of argument that divides the upper ranks of the
foundation is the integration of these anomalies
the answer or should they be sealed away forever
should they be uniformly treated as monsters and
freaks unfit to ever leave their cells aside from
being used in testing fortunately for the
anomaly rights activists in the crowd the
modern Foundation is much more lenient than
it had been in decades past as research has
proven that even dangerous anomalies when
given friendly treatment and basic right
are more compliant happy and feel less Strife
about their situation they can even be useful in
some situations take scp-5595 a sentient sarcastic
gumball machine located at site 322 whose affinity
for mathematics and harmless nature earned it a
position at the site's accounting department as
part of a larger Foundation initiative called the
integration program which focused on integrating
harmless anomalies into the site itself in fact
scp-5595's accounting skills were so great that
it reduced site 322 spending costs overall and
opened the higher-ups to the idea of integrating
more anomalies across the organization if you need
another example as cp999 the adorable orange blob
lovingly nicknamed the Tickle Monster has been
used as a therapy object at site 19 for years
but there is one side of the debate that Spurs
more controversy than any other using anomalies
as Living Weapons the foundation is long abided by
the directive that its objects are to be contained
and studied instead of used in the field as an
uncontrollable object is more dangerous outside
of a cell than in but the directive has changed
especially in recent times the chaos Insurgency
one of the foundation's greatest foes utilizes
anomalies As Weapons to achieve their goals as do
many other groups of interest when trained human
soldiers just aren't enough to contend with all
the enemies the foundation deals with it's no
wonder they begin to explore other options and
that's what brings us to the subject of today's
video The Tale of scp-4793 an anomaly trained as
a brutalizing soldier who never really wanted to
fight this is the story of Andrew Cleese a warrior
with a blazing Savage Fury in his body but with a
gentle tender longing in his heart it all started
during a foundation raid on a chaos Insurgency
operation located in a mount cave in the southern
region of Greece the deadly Insurgency always
on the prowl for more anomalous weapons to use
in its unending battle against the foundation
had hired a team of mercenaries to scour the
region for potential anomalous activity they came
across something buried in the mountains they were
certain was anomalous and after communicating with
their superiors decided to dig it up and see what
it was about naturally word of such a discovery
travels fast and with how many Undercover
operatives the foundation keeps embedded inside
the Insurgency in order to keep tabs on what
their enemies are doing it's no surprise that the
foundation mobilized its forces to get the drop
on whatever this anomalous excavation site was the
mission was simple enough MTF Upsilon 11 nicknamed
Avalon's wake a team of combat Specialists led by
the skilled Captain Holly Shore would infiltrate
their camp and seize any anomalous objects in The
mercenary's Possession getting past the relatively
unguarded entrance was a cakewalk the task force
took out a single guard and were able to slip
deeper into the cave undetected inside they found
a massive pit surrounded by colorful stalagmites
and flowing waterfalls at the center of the
pit next to a smattering of camping supplies
and bright floodlights was a large Stone Steely
a type of pillar most often used in ancient times
that would be carved with important messages or
Stories the details were grainy from a distance
but the team could make out an engraved image of a
Spartan hoplite soldier on the pillar surrounding
the Steely were five mercenaries armed and in the
process of digging out the pillar from Beneath The
Rock Captain Shore knew that this was most likely
the big object the chaos Insurgency were after she
and her team took cover waiting for the opportune
moment to strike but their weight wasn't long one
of the mercenaries shoveling the ground near the
Steely let out a scream they had cut themselves
splattering a small amount of Blood on the stone
monument The Mercenaries panicked readying their
they weren't sure what was going to happen next
but with enough experience in the field they knew
that introducing an anomaly to human blood often
had severe consequences and their suspicions were
proven correct a flash of light surrounded the
cave and from the Steely emerged a warrior clad
in the same armor as the Spartan soldier engraved
on The Monuments carving The Entity was clearly
confused and asked in English if the mercenary
spoke Greek instead they thrust their guns forward
screaming at the soldier to not move the soldier
was compliant but one of the mercenaries feeling
it to be a cruel way to establish dominance over
their new anomalous toy shot at the soldiers
exposed leg what happened next was a whirlwind
of swearing blood and combat The Mercenaries
opened fire on the soldier who retaliated back by
using powerful hand-to-hand combat for whatever
reason bullets just couldn't seem to harm the
soldier he tanked dozens of open shots across
his body the rounds deflecting off his armor as
the soldier picked up a mercenary by the throat
the Kevlar vest he was wearing suddenly flung
itself from the man's body and integrated itself
onto the Soldier's armor the mercenary immediately
recognized this as one of the soldiers anomalous
abilities but was powerless to stop it as it was
slammed against the stone wall falling to the
ground the foundation task force watched in awe
as the soldier took out each of the mercenaries
one by one Captain Shore seeing that the soldier
was continually begging The Mercenaries to stop
shooting at it the entire time sense that there
was a peaceful Humane side to the entity a stark
contrast to the acts of brutality it used to
dispatch The Mercenaries Shore told her men to
move forward but with their weapons lowered the
soldier holding on to a knife it grabbed earlier
stood on guard but surrendered without question
when he realized the foundation operatives were
not there to fight him Captain Shore introduced
herself and her men as part of the foundation
and the soldier clearly upset and distraught
over the Carnage he caused introduced himself
as Andrew glis the team promised Andrew Cleese
they would take him somewhere safe and he complied
little would he know that his journey with the
foundation was just beginning Andrew Cleese was
given the designation as CP 4793 an initial
assessment found him to be anomalously strong
with the ability to integrate any solid material
into a weapon either as a piece of armor like it
did with the mercenaries Kevlar vest or as a
weapon itself such as turning the steel leg of
a chair into a sharpened sword though this ability
did have its limits as Ender Clay's had difficulty
incorporating firearms and complex Electronics
As Weapons or armor on top of that scp-4793 was
extremely durable and able to heal any wounds
on its body almost instantaneously coupled with
its highly trained fighting skills and raging
Fury Andrew Cleese was a true warrior capable of
great power and might but his Wild Side seemed
to disappear when the heat of battle died down
one of site 20's senior researchers Dr Fitzpatrick
was tasked with interviewing scp-4793 weekly and
she discovered that scp-4793 had a completely
different element to his personality he was
intelligent kind gentle and hated fighting
he couldn't remember much of his life from
thousands of years ago but he knew that he was
a great warrior who caused mass destruction with
his power alone Andrew Cleese didn't want to be
someone like that he had an interest in history
in books and learning why he woke up what the
world was like now and why it had changed Andrew
Cleese wanted to know why there were metal
birds in the sky and Horseless chariots on
the ground Dr Fitzpatrick found him to be a
remarkable person and commended scp-4793's
Behavior with access to various literature and
history books so he could learn about the things
he desperately wanted to know but most of all
she was taken back by how averse he was to be
becoming his past self a heartless Warrior who
killed indiscriminately it seemed as if Andrew
Cleese was so traumatized by his past actions
that he sealed away those memories to forget
about them as best he could but site 20's
director Jack Hargrave saw Andrew Cleese as
a mere tool something he could use to achieve a
nefarious goal he had been planning for a long
long time Hargraves wanted to use scp-4793's
raw power to benefit the foundation from his
office he sat back Imagining the Unstoppable
force that a trained Ender Cleese would be
if he could force him to fight and he knew he
could then the foundation would have a deadly
weapon in their hands something that would surely
even the odds between the chaos Insurgency and
those other pesky groups of Interest director
Hargraves forced scp-4793 to train his combat
abilities in a variety of sparring sessions
with Captain Shore the task force Captain who
discovered him in the mountains Hargraves regimen
was brutal and he often threatened to blow up the
explosive collars on scp-4793's neck and wrists
if he held back against Shore or disobeyed his
orders Andrew Cleese could take the explosion
but Shore would surely be caught in the blast
killing her andracles hated hard rays but
cared about Shore who showed him kindness
and understood his difficult position over the
next two years enderclees would train weekly with
Shore sparring with each other using a variety
of weapons from swords to Firearms scp-4793 still
held back not wanting to fight and wanting even
less to accidentally injure Holly Shore who he
was growing to see as a friend in the meantime
Dr Fitzpatrick continued to interview scp-4793
weekly also growing a friendship with the entity
but for as much as she cared about enderqueles she
couldn't help him the way she wanted to Hargraves
was set on making scp-4793 a functional weapon
and he was growing impatient waiting for results
Hargraves was pushing Andrew Cleese Beyond his
comfort zone switching up his sparring partners
from Shore we trusted deeply to other individuals
or changing what weapons he had to use Andrew
Cleese hated this not because he was scared
to fight but because he was anxious about what he
could become if he let loose he never wanted to be
the monster that he knew he was capable of being
he never wanted to hurt someone in the meantime
Hargraves began to have doubts about Andrew Cleese
his humanity and reluctance would slow him down in
the field keep him from being the perfect super
soldier Hargraves wanted him to be so he began
development on another project codenamed x06
this mysterious weapons program was kept Under
Wraps Limited in knowledge to only Hargraves and
his most trusted men if he couldn't have Andrew
Cleaves he would simply have to do better and he
knew he would while Hargraves worked in the shadow
the scp-4793 research team uncovered a section
of Andrew clee's past that he had forgotten the
Steely he was trapped inside had an inscription
on its front written in ancient Greek when it was
translated and sent to Dr Fitzpatrick this is
what it read gather around me children I will
tell you the story of sweet androcles Fierce as a
pride of lions and as cunning as a pack of wolves
he lived for nothing but battle he was beloved
by his countrymen and feared by his enemies so
much so that Aries himself strolled down from
Olympus to challenge him to single combat for
10 days they fought a terrible duel their blades
cutting Earth into islands and the Sparks turning
mountains into forges for Hephaestus impressed he
granted Andrew Cleese a boon so long as he fought
he would never know defeat or age and by mixing
his Igor with Andrew clean's blood aerys declared
him kin to the gods themselves as he came to bear
on the world he met his match in a woman from a
distant land with skin of white as sand covered
in Blues from the ocean she blazed in his eyes
like helios's Chariot together the mountains bowed
before them but even as eros's Arrow brought them
together an arrow split them apart for jealous
Aries saw his favored love something other than
himself with his guiding star gone and turkeys
tore the bones of the Earth itself with his rage
and lust for battle extinguished he turned the
battlefield into twin mountains with his purpose
lost he was in Thunder forevermore Andrew Cleese
was shaken by the revelations of his Warrior past
and in the present he couldn't shake the feelings
that Captain Shore reminded him of his past lover
the feeling was so strong that during a sparring
session Andrew Cleese passed out overwhelmed by
how much she reminded him of her the woman who he
remembered to be his wife Arabelle Andrew Cleese
continued to confide in Dr Fitzpatrick about his
feelings about Captain Shore and especially about
fighting for the foundation he didn't understand
this strange new world or what exactly he would
be fighting for and the stories he heard about
previous attempts to utilize anomalous soldiers
in battle terrified him the story of scp-076
Abel killing his entire Task Force Team after
losing control haunted him at night he never
wanted to become that but hargraves's secret
project reached its completion before Andrew
Cleese could be molded into the perfect Warrior
little did Hargraves know however that Fitzpatrick
was keeping tabs on all of his Shady behavior in
hopes of one day exposing him for the monster that
he was to the Ethics Committee or maybe even the
overseer Council still she took the job wanting
to see what monstrosity Hargraves had created
as a result of his experiments Fitzpatrick was
shocked to see it hargrave's secret experiment
was a black winged clawed creature with way too
many teeth from behind its containment cylinder
it grinned and chuckled an inhuman life Hargraves
was truly creating monsters as Hargraves explained
the creature had near human intelligence and could
reproduce asexually meaning all it took was one of
them for it to multiply with this new anomaly
he could revolutionize the foundation's ways of
Waging War a perfect Soldier one that wouldn't be
held back by human emotion Fitzpatrick voiced her
concern but was cut short by Hargraves suddenly
panicking he noticed that there was only one
x06 entity in the cylinder when he was sure there
were two and suddenly from the ceiling one of the
entities fell to the ground flapping its wings and
screaming in the researchers faces the worst had
happened the x06 entities had broken free and if
they weren't stopped soon they would run rampant
to oversight 20. the two fled for safety but
the horrifying creature chased after them Andrew
Cleese and Captain Shore soon learned of the
Containment Breach as well after their sparring
session was cut short by a creature breaking into
the room Andrew Cleese made short work of it but
it was too late site-20 was overrun with Hargraves
as beasts there were hundreds of them and those
numbers would continue to grow they infiltrated
the entire facility leaving Andrew Cleese and
Captain Shore with one option to fight Andrew
Cleese didn't want to do it but this was different
he needed to be a hero and save the people still
trapped in site-20s facilities it would have to
use Force but if he was helping others then
it was justified he reluctantly told himself
still he hated it as Captain Shore and her task
force as well as scp-4793 moved through site-20
taking out one entity after another Andrew Cleese
realized how hopeless the situation was looking
there were simply too many of them they needed
to focus their efforts on getting people out of
the site rather than hoping to fight While most
Personnel were slaughtered in the Carnage at the
site's d-class block the team found a holdout of
guards and d-class who were conveniently relocated
to an above ground elevator that could escort
them safely out of the site Andrew Cleese made
the decision there to let Captain Shore and her
men as well as the survivors get to the surface
where he would stay below and fight he didn't want
to do it but Andrew Cleese had a plan Shore didn't
want to leave him behind but she had no choice
after parting In the Heat of an x06 ambush on the
Block Andrew Cleese was alone while the survivors
were on the surface fighting without holding back
andracles tore through hundreds of x06 entities
going deeper and deeper into the sight his plan
was dangerous but it would save everyone at the
expense of his own life hendrickley's knew how
dangerous those x06 entities could be if they
were let loose into the world and that was why
he decided he would blow up sight 20's reactor
destroying both himself the site and every single
creature as he was about to do just that Andrew
Cleese found director Hargraves in the rubble
of the reactor room Hargrave was heavily wounded
and Andrew Cleese felt such rage and anger towards
the man especially when he revealed that the
x06 creatures were genetically engineered from
androgly's own blood but he didn't hurt him he
was better than the monster Hargrave saw him
as instead hendrickley set hard Graves up on the
elevator to the surface knowing that the overseer
Council would serve a far worse punishment than
he ever could before blowing up the reactor Andrew
Cleese recorded one last message he addressed
it to Holly Shore the captain who had shown him
so much kindness I was born to a farmer and grew
into a warrior I battled Aries to a standstill I
won War single-handedly then I met my wife we were
set to claim the world to Immortals who wanted to
bring a chaotic World some semblance of peace and
then Aries killed her and I lost everything and
now I'm here alone adrift a stranger surrounded
by even stranger things but within you I see the
spark I saw in her a burning desire to make the
world better it makes me want to be better and I
don't know if you feel the same or whether I'll
get out of here but I will fight for you die if
I have to I love you and with that Andrew Cleese
one of the greatest warriors the foundation had
ever known sacrificed his life to blow up site
20's nuclear reactor destroying the facility and
saving the world from hargraves's deadly creatures
to those who knew him especially Captain Shore he
will never be forgotten because true heroes
never really die the perfect childhood school
is out shoes are off you're sprinting across the
hot sandy beach smiling for no apparent reason
because back then you didn't even need one did I
mention there's an orange cone on your head where
did it come from why is it there what is the point
do not think too deeply about it there's no room
for symbolism in the summer there is no use over
analyzing the antics of teenage youth it's just a
cone and you're just a kid doing things for no
other reason than that you want to you're busy
living doing your thing responsibility is still
years away such a pretty picture where painting
isn't it but this is SCP explained so of course
by now you figured out this is all a misdirection
didn't you well here it comes watch closely look
at you run moving towards nothing as if it means
everything look at that smile the wind whipping
through the Gap in your teeth soak it in into
20 years your face muscles will have forgotten
the movement look at you live yes go on soak
it in you will be chasing this feeling your whole
life while moving further and further away from it
depressing isn't it we think so too but here
is the Silver Lining something you'd be wise
to celebrate at least you have this moment to
look back on the memory is with you forever not
everyone is so lucky not everyone had a good
childhood furthermore not everyone even has a
childhood at all some live beyond the expectations
of age Imagine a 14 year old forced to be 40
that's not to say they have to pay taxes or can
run for Senate no this level of force maturity
that I'm speaking of transcends the scope of
average adulthood so let's not imagine a kid
going through the mundane life of a cubicle junkie
filing papers pretending to work and answering
phone calls instead let's do this imagine a kid
going to war imagine a kid carrying out stealth
assassination missions imagine a kid being
locked in containment living with little human
interaction and freedom is all to say imagine a
kid not being a kid at all now this is more like
an SCP explained this is the sad story of someone
who had to say goodbye to the joys of adolescents
earlier than anyone ever should have to in fact
they didn't even get to say goodbye at all this
is the story of scp-105 now to be clear scp-105 is
not a bloodthirsty demon living in the shadows it
is not an unsquishable spider dancing across your
hardwood floor mocking the soles of your shoes as
they stomp down with no success it is not a grand
piano in a hotel lobby absorbing the DNA of all
who touches its keys and it is not a freezer
that tempts late night snackers to reach deeper
and deeper towards an Ever elusive hot fudge
sundae until they are sucked in frozen solid
sold for millions and displayed as decorative
ice sculptures atop the center of punch bowls
at parties for Rich politicians no we'll just
have to get to those later on on a different
day because scp-105 is just how do I put this
a girl yes a small unremarkable looking girl at
the time of acquisition she was just 1.5 meters
tall and weighed 50 kilograms even those of you
listening with little to no instinctual senses for
converting meters and kilograms to feet and pounds
can still understand this is no frightful giant
we're talking about lining up a class by height
she'd blend in somewhere toward the middle and if
you look even closer beyond the shallow surface of
measurements and toward the details of her face
even still you won't find a single Freckle to
fear scp-105 has blue eyes and blonde hair nothing
Coastal Californians haven't seen a million times
over just this Monday formerly known as Iris
Thompson scp-105 has no discernible Oddities
if you saw her jumping rope you wouldn't point and
stare if you saw her at the park playing with your
children you wouldn't pull them away and squeeze
them tight if you saw her walking toward you on a
sidewalk you wouldn't turn around and run away in
the other direction by herself scp-105 is not too
different from anyone else no matter how close
we zoom in on her appearance personality or her
Tendencies there is nothing to see that triggers
alarms if you ask her to spit fire she won't if
you conduct a lab experiment where she has to find
the exit of a maze using only her sense of smell
she will get lost and fail this is all to say if
you look too closely through the microscope at
scp-105 you might miss her anomalous abilities
instead you'd be better off taking a step back
and just watching her live her life and that is
all that she wanted to do live her life is that
so much to ask the first thing you will notice
is that she isn't alone and like in any good
buddy buddy film her counterpart reveals more
to her character so who is standing by her side
who is the co co-star of this film that pushes
our protagonist into the foundation Spotlight
well it's no person at all it's a camera her
camera scp-105-b is a Polaroid one-step Express
manufactured in 1982. it does not appear to have
any out of the ordinary physical characteristics
and appears to be for all intents and purposes a
normal Polaroid camera operating as expected for
all persons aside from scp-105 when you point it
at a subject they don't get sucked into the lens
The Flash can't blind an army of soldiers when
you say cheese it doesn't shoot out a brick of
cheddar the camera is nothing more than a camera
that is until it's in the hands of Iris Thompson
what's more unique than the camera itself are
the photographs it produces when scp-105 holds a
photograph taken by scp-105-b the picture changes
from a still shot to that of a real-time image of
the person location or object photographed
regardless of the subject of the photograph
the image will convert itself into what appears
to be a handheld live stream of whatever was
pictured imagine a photograph of a waterfall if
held by a cp105 you do not just see the image of
a waterfall but you will physically see the water
falling splashing down onto the Rocks below it is
similar to holding your cell phone and watching a
gif however instead of just watching iris is able
to interact with it in a way Beyond any technology
has ever allowed scp-105 is then able to move her
arm through and into the photograph and manipulate
objects Within Reach of the original point at
which the photograph was first taken Yes you heard
me right scp-105-2 doesn't just offer Iris quick
prints of memories it gives her much more granting
her access to a new dimension although this is
clearly a unique situation for Iris it doesn't
mean that iris is the only one affected by this
anomaly when she engages with the photographs it
actually affects the world attached to them that
is to say there are consequences to her actions
every photograph she has ever taken is essentially
a portal to a world of problems Witnesses who
have been on the other side of the photograph
while scp-105 was manipulating it reported seeing
her hand reaching out from an invisible portal and
carrying on whatever actions she pleases once
her arm is inside the photograph she has the
freedom to control the image as she wishes this
ability has obvious benefits for anyone imagine
being able to carry around with you a photograph
of your oven then whenever you get that paranoid
feeling that you forgot to turn it off you can
reach into the Polaroid and turn the dial how
you please but the peace of mind is just a small
benefit of this power and it's easy to assume that
anyone would be tempted to use their abilities
from far more than just controlling at home
appliances while on vacation the foundation
specifically concerns itself with bigger more
ambitious uses of anomalous power and the power
in this case wasn't just in the camera while
105-b helps Iris use her powers most efficiently
she is still able to manipulate objects through
photographs taken by other cameras though not
quite as well as when she's using her favorite
camera noting that 105-b and the photographs taken
by said camera have no unusual properties when
used by any other person except for scp-105 it was
clear to the foundation who the greater anomaly
in the situation really was the tool wasn't of
their interest but rather the person wielding
it but how did this all come to their attention
is the foundation really investigating the life
of a girl playing with a camera in her bedroom
while some moments are just too big to be bound
by privacy scp-105 was brought to the Forefront
of the foundation's attention shortly after the
murder of her boyfriend promptly after his death
the police investigated the scene and looked for
answers and when looking for answers they started
Conjuring up questions one of which put Iris at
the center of their search where were you her
response wasn't so straightforward she wasn't
there but then she was the police pressed further
not understanding scp-105 explained that she was
at home but once she learned of his death she
hurried over to him this left the police even
more suspicious as there was no way she could have
been informed of the Murder By an outside Source
she must have been there all along seeing the
skepticism in their faces scp-105 scrambled for
an explanation she took a deep breath and got
her story straight she claimed to have been on
the phone with her boyfriend at the time of the
violent attack and once she heard the commotion
it prompted her to hurry over to his location
where she saw him dead this excuse made logical
sense and so the police dropped their suspicion
after all Iris was just a small innocent teenager
however just as quickly as the police move on from
Iris they returned to her this time with tangible
proof of their doubts the telephone records did
not correspond to her story she was never on
the phone with her boyfriend that night it was
then that scp-105 had to confess she informed
her lawyer that she had in fact been there for
the murder well not there but kind of there she
explained how she witnessed the murder through
a photograph she had taken with her boyfriend
several days prior the attorney in question
disregarded the story and recommended that the
subject plead guilty Iris however refused to do so
she was sticking to her truth no matter how crazy
it made her seem she went forward and told her
story in court it was met with derision the judge
and the jury didn't even entertain the possibility
of any of it being true Iris was flustered she was
a young teenage girl fighting for her Freedom her
only weapon being the truth but the room wasn't
participating in her reality they dismissed her as
crazy and so when Iris offered to demonstrate her
ability it was the last straw the judge wouldn't
allow Iris to waste any more of anyone's time she
was she was sentenced to a psychiatric ward Iris
was determined to get out of there she knew she
didn't belong luckily someone else Knew Too that
she didn't belong and because of this in a matter
of days she was out of there but home wasn't where
she was heading no it wasn't mom and dad picking
her up from the psychiatric ward but rather the
foundation breaking her out stealing her for
themselves and bringing her to site 17. there at
site 17 Foundation Personnel began their mission
which started with trying to convince scp-105 that
they were on her side they began by retrieving
scp-105-b from scp-105's home and replacing it
with an identical model only then to give it to
her under the lie that it was the original the
lies wouldn't stop just there they'd continue
to pour over her reality until it was impossible
for her to recognize one from the other scp-105's
parents was informed that she was killed during
the botched Escape of another patient while both
were in the custody of a psychiatric care facility
in truth though the foundation wants nothing more
than to keep scp-105 alive however they are not
concerned about the quality of her living Iris
was a tool for the foundation she was an asset
she was a secret weapon she had powers they
could have only dreamed of only now they existed
but before shooting their shiny new weapon they
needed to learn how to use it properly but with
what manual how do you learn how to use another
human well having seen enough Marvel movies they
knew they would be better equipped with knowledge
if they understood her origin story so they began
questioning Iris trying to get to the root cause
of her anomalous attitude she was either 10 or 11.
she remembers because she was looking at a picture
of the ocean and she noticed that the waves began
moving her parents said that she just had an
overactive imagination when she first was able to
move objects in the photos she was 11 12 maybe her
family took a trip to the Grand Canyon she looked
through the photo album after they got home and
she brushed her hand up against one by accident
when she did she pushed a rock over the edge
falling into the canyon she could actually hear it
clatter on the way down she became fascinated with
photography after that most of the time it didn't
work with photographs she took but her parents got
her a Polaroid one-step Express camera that she'd
been begging them for since Christmas after she
got the camera the photos got easier to interact
with after hearing her story the researchers made
her an offer she'd be allowed certain freedoms
if she agreed to use her powers to do them a few
favors she could at least in some capacity act her
age socialize and do things a girl her grade would
normally do but in exchange she had to First
do things that nobody any age should ever have
to do Iris agreed and it was in this agreement
that we see just how desperate she was during
her childhood she was willing to risk everything
for something as small as a quick conversation
with a guard five minutes of jump rope or simply
a few minutes spent under the sun she was assigned
to be part of Mobile task force omega-7 to carry
out a wide range of missions and if the fate
of the first humanoid SCP recruited to mobile
task force omega-7 was any indication how this
might play out Iris was in a lot of trouble the
Pandora's Box initiative had a history of failure
their previous efforts under team able ended in
the death of absolutely everyone however team
Iris began on a more hopeful note They carried
out different missions than team able instead
of violent attacks their primary missions were
reconnaissance and intelligence gathering however
just because there were no swords and blood drawn
the missions were not so harmless despite team
Iris carrying out over 20 jobs in cooperation
with the bow commission swiftly and without
incident their streak eventually had to come to
an end the first disciplinary incident for scp-105
involved the escalation of Team Iris missions
from reconnaissance to assassinations yes this
teenage girl with not a violent bone in her body
was tasked to kill to kill not that her only Power
is that of manipulating photos in her mind this
is nothing more than a party trick it was a gift
she was born with and she was always aware that
it was unique but never did she expect it to be
a curse she liked being able to straighten books
and photographs of libraries she liked being able
to read into photos and hug her teddy bear that
she no longer has she liked being able to help
heal and embrace history not alter it scp-105
violently opposed the use of her abilities to
carry out assassinations they wanted her to murder
people and like any girl of her nature would
she resisted but they kept pressing while some
teenage girls are pressured by parents to play
sports they don't particularly care for this one
was pressured to kill during these events scp-105
became emotionally distressed and attempted to
deceive Foundation Personnel into believing that
her anomalous traits had disappeared she claimed
that she couldn't carry out the missions anymore
her doctor after submitted a report recommending
that scp-105 be reclassified as neutralized
undergo amnestic treatment and be released
to the public with regular monitoring after
further investigation the foundation realized the
doctor was prioritizing as cp105's emotional state
over the goals of the foundation they had built a
friendship he was the one telling her to pretend
not to have powers anymore this was all found out
thus his recommendation to release Iris was denied
with nothing to lose at that point the doctor
even helped Iris try to escape the foundation's
custody but this failed she was captured and the
doctor was promptly discharged at that point Iris
had to start over again to regain the trust of
the foundation and yet another compromise she
re-demonstrated that her anomalous abilities
in exchange for the restoration of limited
privileges nothing more than occasionally being
allowed to jump rope getting a lollipop every
Thursday and being informed of the recent
Trends on Tick Tock and so this is where
her to be continuously making sacrifices in
exchange for tiny teaspoons of Teenage life
all the while she is growing older and older
unfulfilled by the years she passes and so while
it is easy to look back on our childhood with lust
and longing at least it was there and is still
there now safely stored in our memory stored in
the protection of the past for Iris this is not so
her childhood is both behind her and in front of
her it is something she moved on from too quickly
and it is a future she fights for every day even
when she is 97 gray decrepit and on her deathbed
she will be sacrificing her freedoms to feel 15.
and so we have to wonder is scp-105 a danger to
anyone at all I leave you with a question are we
more likely to be attacked by a dog or the master
holding its leash it has been often said that dog
is man's best friend and Avi obviously that isn't
just exclusive to men ask any pet owner whether
they own a dog cat rabbit hamster or soul-sucking
interdimensional parasitic monster with too many
tentacles and they'll all tell you the same your
pet can be your best friend they can give you
the most unconditional affectionate form of
love possible and as long as you treat your little
buddy right they'll be loyal to you for the rest
of your life and theirs it's not uncommon for
a pet to outlive their owner especially if they
belong to someone who's elderly and that might be
a sad thing to think about for some although it is
important to remember the positives like how much
happiness and companionship that animal would have
brought an aging owner in their last years of life
even someone younger who dies unexpectedly might
have had their quality of life infinitely improved
by owning a loving pet to make them smile but on
the other hand there's the negative downside that
now some pets have to live on after a tragic death
not fully understanding where their beloved owner
went so often we hear stories of dogs that waited
for their Master to come home only for them to
never walk through the front door again and it's
equally hard when things pan out the opposite way
and an owner loses their pet the one silver lining
is that we as human beings have a far greater
understanding of death and the grief it causes
we know that eventually despite how hard it can be
to adjust to that initial heartbreaking loss it is
possible to move on and for things to one day get
better but what happens when someone can't accept
the death of their beloved animal companion when
the unconditional love of their pet is suddenly
missing from their life how far will a person go
to recapture that feeling how long does it take
for grief born out of love to become an unhealthy
fixation and what is the true price of obsession
well the answer involves scp-589 both what it
can give and just as easily take away for as long
as she could remember and even further back than
that Aaron and her dog Pancho had been Inseparable
ever since her mom had first adopted that scrappy
little Jack Russell Terrier Aaron had fallen head
over heels in love with that little rascal loving
a pet is different from loving another person
because they just can't help showing how much they
love you back humans for all their good qualities
are so nuanced and not everyone is honest with
each other all of the time but a pet especially
a dog even though they can't speak a bark or a
whimper or excited wagging of a tail can easily
tell you how they're feeling and Poncho was no
exception Aaron and her mom Cleo lived alone who
was just the two of them for quite a long time
and while Cleo had little problem with that she
couldn't help but notice how isolating it was for
her daughter from a young age Aaron had always
been quiet kept to herself at School her mom kept
expecting her to make some friends asked to invite
them over or vice versa but it didn't seem to
be happening it didn't seem to be bothering
her daughter but Cleo was worried that it was
giving her the wrong idea and being on her own
was somehow better so in an effort to give Aaron
at least one source of companionship Pancho joined
the family brown patches dotted over his white
fur he was the perfect pet an excitable and loving
little puppy that Aaron was immediately smitten
with when Cleo told her he was hers to keep being
only seven years old Aaron broke down crying with
tears of joy her mom had let her pick out a name
for him and she'd quickly settled on Poncho at
first Aaron had men to say it differently in order
to name the pup after a friendly character from
her favorite animated movie but had mispronounced
it in her excitement at meeting the energetic dog
for the first time the name quickly stuck though
and as the years went on and Pancho got bigger
her Aaron bought her four-legged best friend a
little Poncho of his own to wear when it started
raining over the following years Pancho became
Aaron's most constant and loving companion even as
she grew up moving through her childhood and found
making friends a little easier with every passing
year there never came a time when she didn't need
her best friend when Aaron had her first breakup
in high school and came home with floods of Tears
In Her Eyes Pancho could sense she was upset and
came wandering up to her sitting in her lap to
make her feel just a little bit better then a
few years later when her mom got sick Aaron had
to take care of her a task that would have been
much harder without Pancho there to alleviate that
stress and lift her and Cleo's spirits and when
Cleo eventually passed the little white and brown
dog sat quietly with his owner as she said goodbye
to her mom now that it was just the two of them
Aaron and Pancho were living in a tiny apartment
it was crammed for one person and a dog but Aaron
was just grateful to have a place to live and the
company of her favorite pop besides Pancho wasn't
a puppy anymore in fact he hadn't raced around the
park or chased a ball for quite a long time with
the numerous stresses of her everyday life least
of all holding down two jobs in her desperate
attempts to make enough money to pay rent Aaron
had hardly noticed the signs Pancho was showing
his age it had been happening gradually in the
background over the years he wouldn't chase the
ball or really move around much and when he did
it was little more than a lethargic plot around
the apartment perhaps it was because of such
a measured slower Pace change that Aaron was
unable to acknowledge it she could see her old
friend was getting more tired sleeping longer his
tail really wagging as much as it used to but by
now that felt like Pancho's normal behavior then
again given how important her dog was to her it's
just as likely she didn't want to accept the truth
that unfortunately nothing lasts forever he was
almost 15 in human years which by all accounts
is an impressive age for a dog especially one of
Pancho's size and breed it was on a day that Aaron
was out working her morning job when it happened
the faithful adoring Jack Russell Terrier who had
spent his years being nothing but loved and giving
back only more love in return curled up on Aaron's
bed the apartment was still Silent not a sound
to be heard save for those last tired few breaths
laying there maybe the dog wondered if he'd ever
get to see his friend again if she would make it
back from work in time he closed his little brown
eyes and peacefully drifted off for one last sleep
during the break between her shifts after the end
of the one at her first job and before starting
her second Aaron had just enough time to get
home usually she had just had enough time to eat
and get herself ready for the changeover then
quickly check on Pancho before having to dash
back out poking her head into the bedroom she saw
her dog laying right there on her bed there was a
Stillness to him that instantly made her stomach
drop his ears didn't move when she called his name
he didn't react when she stroked his fur he was
gone and the moment she realized it Aaron felt
like her whole world had come crashing down the
loss of her oldest and closest friend heard almost
as much as losing her mom Aaron always felt that
the problem with funerals wasn't just how sad they
were or how it always seemed to rain when she
went to one instead it was more that they could
never properly sum up just how much someone truly
meant nobody could ever condense the year's worth
of love and memories into a burial and it was
worse when losing a pet there was no procession
no wake nobody else there just her and Poncho
saying goodbye a final time eventually things
got to be too much the Heartbreak of Pancho's
death was another struggle in the lifetime of lows
that had all left their lasting wounds on Aaron
that coupled with this stress of trying to carry
on with a busy life barely able to keep herself
afloat in either of her jobs had pushed her to the
edge of a breakdown maybe that's what summoned
it perhaps something had sensed all of Aaron's
mental anguish and had come to seek her out it
might have been that her wishes for something
some little alleviation to all the pain and stress
were finally being granted or maybe it was just a
gift left by her neighbor the sun had long since
set when Aaron arrived back at her apartment
stepping over the envelopes that littered
her doormat a few with words like overdue and
Urgent notice printed on them in red ink passing
through the hallway Aaron paused as she always
did hoping to hear the gentle patterning of Paws
against the floor her therapist had dissuaded her
from doing that saying it would only make moving
on from losing Poncho worse she didn't care she
wanted her dog back and opening the door to her
bedroom it seemed like someone had been listening
sat on her bed was a stuffed animal right in the
spot where she had found her little friend on that
horrible day it had been made to look like a dog
specifically resembling a Jack Russell Terrier
with brown patches over its white fur the plushie
was even wearing a little rain poncho the side
of it was enough to cause Aaron to break down in
tears weeping in heavy sobs as she dashed across
the bedroom to hold it in her arms hugging it
tightly her tears seeped into the soft fur as
she felt it against her face she didn't even think
to question where it had even come from all she
wanted to do in that moment was hold the stuffed
animal close for the first time in what felt like
years a feeling of relief washed over Aaron it was
as if everything was melting away the stress of
work and the toll of her tiring shifts gone all
the pain from losing Cleo and Pancho dissipated
too in fact it felt like she now had her beloved
dog back now it was better than that it was almost
as though everything about Poncho his energy his
spirit the way he made her feel so calm and loved
was all distilled into this stuffed animal and
now it would never grow old never age and die
causing her more pain Aaron gripped the soft toy
tightly the longer she held the hug for the more
her stress and sadness faded her face was still
wet with tears although her sobbing had gradually
become low gentle Chuckles soon giving way to
appeal of uncontrollable laughter rising in volume
it was as though she had taken something and the
Very chemistry of her brain was being altered but
after so much hardship it felt good to the point
where she was almost lightheaded laying down on
the floor of her bedroom arms locked around the
plushie that reminded her so much of Poncho Aaron
continued softly giggling to herself her entire
body relaxed so much so that every part of her
felt like warm butter as if she was about to
start melting through the floorboards although
she didn't know it or probably wouldn't have even
cared her dopamine levels were spiking flooding
her with the bodily hormone that relieves stress
and makes a person feel good in fact right now
she was feeling better than she ever had every day
that followed Aaron would come home to our stuffed
animal her Poncho too as she'd like to think of
it it didn't bother her how childlike anyone else
might find it for a grown woman to rely so heavily
on a plushie for Comfort at any rate it wasn't
something she was advertising to anyone else after
every shift at both of her jobs she'd race back
to her apartment right to Pancho too and just sit
there just basking in the way it made her feel it
was the most all-encompassing sense of euphoria
and relief reducing her stress so much that she
felt like she was floating her body lighter than
air that feeling was all that mattered to her
some days she wouldn't even eat Poncho 2 was more
important to her than food gradually she started
to become addicted to that feeling having to wait
until the end of her work shifts to feel that Rush
of happy chemicals flood her brain was too long
of a delay she started to Crave it while working
unable to focus feeling erratic and Restless
without Poncho 2. of course she couldn't risk
bringing it to work with her what if someone took
it or she dropped it her boss might see her with
a stuffed animal at her desk and fire her on the
spot or think that she was absolutely crazy the
only safe place for her source of relief was at
home but Aaron knew she needed something to bridge
the gap while she was working the only substitute
that worked was taking a photo of Pancho 2 on her
phone then blowing it up and printing off a copy
Aaron could carry it around portably keeping it in
her pocket and taking it out to look at it every
few minutes while she worked the head of positive
chemicals it gave her wasn't quite as strong as
getting to hold her stuffed animal after all it
was just a grainy photo from her phone essentially
acting like a patch to tighter over until she
could get back home to the real thing however
it didn't take long for Aaron to start taking
Pancho with her anywhere that wasn't work to the
grocery store to visit her mom and her dog and of
course to therapy I'm rather concerned about this
pattern of behavior Aaron's psychotherapist Dr Lee
stated when her patient explained what had been
happening sitting across on the opposite side of
her office on a leather couch Aaron had Poncho
too pressed tightly against her I don't care
she sighed her brain already Awash with hormones
that kept her calm I like how it makes me feel so
I don't care Aaron look at yourself Dr Lee urged
you aren't properly dealing with your grief it
seems to me you're channeling all your desire for
positive emotion into this stuffed animal Poncho
two Aaron corrected her without taking her eyes
off the soft brown and white dog in its little
cloak listen to me the therapist insisted trying
desperately to get through to her Poncho your dog
your real dog is gone you lost him six months ago
and her mom Cleo she passed away 2 2 you have to
process and come to terms with those things as sad
as they might make you feel that's how we move on
but what you're doing right now isn't healthy
Aaron it's becoming an obsession Turning Away
Aaron press Poncho 2 up against her face I don't
care she repeated by now Aaron had become fully
dependent on Pancho II showing up late for both
jobs just so she could spend longer feeling those
endorphins and hormones that hugging the stuffed
animals seem to bring it didn't take long for her
to start skipping entire shifts for days at a
time and canceling any and all other plans just
to sit at home basking in the relief brought on
by her apparent Obsession her apartment became a
mess untidy piles of mail by the front door the
walls plastered with hundreds of photos of her
stuffed animal fueling her Obsession her evening
job was the first to fire Aaron citing her recent
absences as the grounds for her dismissal even
then she still didn't seem to care the fact she
might not be able to make rent barely registered
returning home after her other job called her in
to tell Aaron she would no longer be working there
either she instantly looked around for Poncho too
but it was nowhere to be found all the photos on
the walls having faded Aaron checked her phone
all the original copies of the pictures were gone
too instantly racked with fear so addicted to the
plushie that she could barely function without it
she began tearing her apartment to shreds looking
for it she wrenched cupboards off their hinges and
tipped over her refrigerator flipping her mattress
Aaron sliced the fabric open with a kitchen knife
searching high and low for Poncho too but I'm able
to find it anywhere she became frantic erratic
pulling her hair out in a fit of uncontrollable
despair where had it gone had someone stolen it
Dr Lee the paranoia had already set in convincing
Aaron that her therapist must have taken Pancho
too she was the only other person who knew about
it and had been so critical of her using it to to
make herself feel better marching into Dr Lee's
office utterly enraged Beyond Reason all Aaron
could think about was getting her stuffed animal
back no matter what she had to do the effect it
had on her was so powerful so potent and addictive
that living without it was worth anything even
another person's life little did Aaron realize
as her hands grew wetter coated with more of
Dr Lee's blood after every bludgeoning strike
her therapist had no idea where Pancho 2 was in
fact she had nothing to do with it Vanishing in
the first place it had disappeared all on its
own along with all the photograph copies Aaron
had printed arriving somewhere miles away scp-589
was ready to begin the whole cycle again on its
next victim it would take on whatever shape it
needed to appease the desires of the very next
person to find it preying on their vulnerability
and making them totally dependent on it that was
what it did everywhere it went leeching off people
that it could easily manipulate its presence and
interaction would calm scp-589's victims helping
to alleviate their stress or make them feel better
about their deepest insecurities before long
these helpless victims would be able to think
of nothing else feeling as if they were unable
to live without their ups session doll and every
time that was when scp-589 would make its cruelest
move it would vanish leaving its prey in a state
of intense withdrawal with a calming influence of
scp-589 absent from their lives all of a sudden
the infected people would suffer from a variety of
potential psychological symptoms manic depression
psychosis uncontrollable despair Dementia or an
Aaron's case paranoia and a heightened sense of
aggression that caused her to murder Dr Lee that
was one of the earliest in a Spate of similar
incidents that had been reported as scp-589
traveled from town to town its influence spread
leaving entire populations dead in its wake all
the while the stuffed animal fed on the mental
anguish that it caused its victims making them
pay the ultimate price for their Obsession Dr Jack
Bright is a man known by many names and whether
that name is oh God no or just Jack if you've
spent any amount of time here on SCP explained
you've surely at least heard of the good doctor
once or twice he's a high-ranking senior staff
member at site 19. one of the foundation's most
notable facilities and has served as a director
and important member of the foundation's upper
ranks for decades of course you wouldn't be able
to tell that by looking at him because depending
on the current circumstances Dr bright might
not look a day over 13 or 80 or 90 or he might
just be a chimpanzee this is because Dr bright in
his younger days came into contact with scp-963 a
metal amulet that gives its wearers Consciousness
immortality when the amulet is moved from one body
to another Dr Bright's Consciousness moves with
it allowing him to occupy a variety of bodies from
animals to old ladies Dr bright has been them
all act Bright's body swapping abilities have
even proven themselves to be incredibly useful for
the foundation so the guys able to get some actual
work done when he's not goofing off in undercover
operations Dr bright has been used to infiltrate
areas that the foundation would typically have
trouble reaching or when clandestine operations
are the best course of action in the 2000 United
States election Dr bright briefly occupied the
body of George Bush in order for the foundation
to investigate political opponent Al Gore's
activities without suspicion but that mess is
a story for another day today we're going to
be taking a look at a different side of Dr Jack
Bright one that isn't so overt one that's lurking
behind the joking facade and silly antics so
commonly associated with Bright's identity
this is SCP explained and we'd like to welcome
you into the complicated dramatic and ultimately
tragic world of the bright family specifically
the story of scp-590 your Consciousness being
Immortal certainly has its perks for one UK can't
die on the other hand you can't die we all know
the old cliche about immortality how your friends
and loved ones will grow old and die off while
you'll stay the same age how centuries will start
to feel like months how your mind will eventually
crumble under the weight of countless years and
experiences because no man was made to live this
long but while it is cliche for us it's reality
for Dr bright he's painfully aware of how futile
his situation is and behind closed doors it scares
him Dr bright struggles intensely with existential
depression and for good reason too right now he
might be fine but in the relatively near future
he'll start experiencing that cycle of death and
Rebirth of those around him and himself and over
time that cycle will just keep repeating body
after body friend after friend tragedy after
tragedy in the long term Dr bright knows that
his life cannot have happy ending it's most
likely because of this biting inevitable future
that bright makes the most of his time with those
around him in the foundation making himself known
as a Charming goofy personality brimming with
quirks and xaniness the part of bright that
makes others laugh does so because deep down
bright needs something to take his mind off his
situation he wants the same type of familiarity
and comfort that he brings to other people but
Bright's public-facing Persona is often torn to
shreds in private on top of being an undying Soul
bright has to contend with an even more stressful
experience his family the bright family is
a colorful assortment of old blood that has
run the inner circle of the anomalous world for
Generations there are members of the bright family
that were there when the first administrators
signed the policy that created the SCP Foundation
members who serve time on the overseer Council and
even those who operate outside of the parameters
of the foundation Dr bright is just one among many
other individuals of major anomalous significance
in his bloodline and it's only fitting that every
family has its issues for the brights all strong
personalities who hold positions of power in
various places across the anomalous World Unity
isn't exactly a strong point in fact most of the
family isn't anywhere near each other each member
existing in their own bubble working towards their
own individual goals that often do not align with
the rest of their kin but there are occasions when
the bright family all come together to sneer at
one another from across the table and enjoy a
nice loving reunion though these meetings are
often called out of necessity and are far and few
between this Gathering of anomalous individuals
is deemed important enough by the foundation to
have its own designated security term nicknamed
Code Brown when a Code Brown is issued it can only
mean that the brights are locked away in a room
convening arguing and scheme aiming over something
of great importance to them and the rest of the
world should stay out of their family business and
when Jack Bright got his latest call for a family
meeting from one of the family members he was on
speaking terms with he could only think of just
how bad of an idea that was it had been quite some
time since bright saw the rest of his family and
he didn't particularly look forward to when they
would meet again in the time since then Wright
had been taking care of TJ his younger brother
whose story is nearly as tragic as Jax don't
worry we'll get back to the events of the family
reunion soon enough for now let's have a look at
TJ bright TJ was a product of the cruel brutal
attitude the early Foundation took out on the
objects it contained needlessly cold containment
procedures that denied basic needs for human
anomalies pointless tests that often resulted in
death or worse and a general lack of regard for
decency or ethics this archaic era would come
to an end upon the form nation of the Ethics
Committee a board formed in the upper ranks of the
foundation that would enforce a better treatment
of the objects contained by the organization with
severe consequences for those that disobeyed the
new more human Doctrine but in the case of TJ
bright there was nothing the committee could do TJ
who had been given the designation of scp-590 long
ago was an ordinary person who happened to have
anomalous abilities like countless others that the
foundation had dealt with before he appeared to be
permanently 16 years old never aging or changing
an appearance once during his time in containment
the abilities in question that had caught the
attention of the foundation were TJ's inherent
power to cure illness physical mental injuries and
wounds TJ could cure them all with just a touch
of his hand but at an unfortunate cost whatever
injury TJ would cure it would be mirrored onto
his own body a giant gaping wound could be healed
by TJ but the after effects of such such as scar
tissue and any lasting side effects would later
appear on his own body leaving the boy to feel
the pain of everyone he touched and healed the
early Foundation needlessly exploited to scp-590s
abilities and tests and procedures testing the
limits of TJ's body and its abilities this of
course was carried out without the knowledge of
his brother Dr bright who at the time did not
have enough polar power within the organization to
save his brother he could only watch and hope that
one day scp-590 could live a better life outside
of his cell as TJ bright and not a number on a
placard to be experimented with so casually the
foundations experiments with TJ sometimes involve
the use of scp-500 and all curing Panacea
that would fully heal as cp590 and bring him
back to full health a state that would later be
reverted when the foundation started their EXP
tournaments with the boy once again TJ had endured
immeasurable pain and as a result had suffered a
broken mental state over the years as time went
by and things within the foundation had started
to change including Jack Bright's prominence
he worked as hard as he could to push through
bureaucratic red tape and work out a solution that
would leave TJ in a less torturous position and
when the time came it was Jack Bright who made the
call to have scp-590 cure a variety of specific
mental conditions that would leave the boy in
a dulled State unable to fully comprehend the
pain he endures should the foundation ever have
to utilize TJ's abilities again Bryant's decision
to do this to his brother was questionable and a
part of the doctor regrets it to this day but at
the time it seemed like a more preferable option
than having scp-590 be fully aware of what was
happening to him unfortunately the idea that TJ's
reduced mental capacities would prevent him from
standing what was occurring to him was a
misunderstanding and TJ was still more than
capable of perceiving what was happening to him
and that was pain he knew he was being hurt he
knew he wasn't loved and even though his mind was
unlike rights or those who experimented with him
he felt the same things they did by the time of
the reunion TJ was fully in the care of Dr bright
eventually the modern Foundation worked out that
it was doing the poor boy more harm than good to
keep him locked up in a Cell all day and bright
who was now one of the most notable and important
individuals in the foundation was able to pull
enough strings to get TJ out of confinement now
he could truly rest without worry that he would
be exploited and abused safe alongside his older
brother inside the meeting room all of the famous
figures of the bright family while the ones that
were alive at least were there Dr bright sat
alongside TJ who occupied himself with a a
coloring book and a set of crayons from across the
table was mikhailbright better known as overseer
05-6 a former Foundation agent who operated under
the name of cowboy 05-6 was a hardened individual
with a heavy interest in firearms and a whole
lot of luck on his side Mikhail and Jack almost
at the same time both fired out remarks about how
bad of an idea they felt this reunion was the one
who called The Reunion was their elder sister
Claire bright whose aged body felt notably out
of place among the collection of Forever Young
brights whether it was Jack's body hopping TJ's
longevity or mikhail's use of scp-006 the overseer
council's Fountain of Youth to keep himself young
for an extended period of time also present was
Yorick Elroy Jack Bright's grandson as the three
of them discussed the state of Claire Bright's
apparent aging situation Yorick remarked that he
thought she was involved with that incident at
site-23 this Dr bright knew was referring to an
incident he'd rather forget where a reality Bender
contained by the foundation attempted to give the
bright family himself Mikhail and TJ included a
happy ending where they would be cured of their
ailments and allowed to live ordinary lives of
course this was just the product of a reality
band and the fantasy quickly fell apart when the
brights realized what was going on Jack rather not
dwelt on what could have been across from York
was Foundation agent Sarah Argent one of the
youngest members of the bright family who worked
as an overseer council's hand Sinister a special
title granted to an assassin used by the council
to sort out messy business for them the previous
hand Sinister was none other than mikhailbright
whose Pearl revolvers that came with the position
now belong to Sarah Macau was growing impatient
and asking how long it would take for the rest
of the family to show up the rest of the family
being the brides that weren't involved in the
foundation Nation the powerful individuals
who had worked their way into various groups
of interest and aspects of the anomalous World
while some directly opposed the foundation and
its Mission and others were neutral they were all
brights which meant their presence was necessary
while the two sides sometimes worked together
there was always an air of Bad Blood and poor
trust between them Dr bright in particular was
not looking forward to the rest of this meeting
the first to arrive was an individual named nobody
who the foundation had a difficult time keeping up
with nobody was a title granted from one person
to the next who each worked towards a greater
plan that only nobody knew the specific details
of leaving the foundation completely unaware of
the group's larger interests nobody's voice was
impossible to source and her appearance was even
harder to pin down but she was there nobody
circled around the table remarking that the
other side of the family had sent her first to
make sure the foundation Brides were all abiding
by the rules at one point in time nobody did have
another name but in becoming the next nobody she
left her previous Life Behind The Next To Arrive
was Claire luminux II a human with electromagnetic
abilities whose motives were largely unknown when
she pulled back the chair to sit down Sparks flew
in the air briefly startling the rest of the room
after that came David blindman a Gruff sunglass
wearing member of the Serpent's hand a group of
anomalous individuals who worked to free anomalies
from the confinements of the foundation who they
called jailers Blind Men was mikhail's son and
possessed the anomalous ability to see into the
future he was The Unofficial representative of
The unnumbered Brood a subsection of the bright
family consisting of mikhail's illegitimate
children from his Wilder days as a free roaming
Foundation agent and a constant reminder to the
overseer of his past naturally Mikhail was less
than pleased to see his son arrive and then there
was Evelyn navon who levitated into the room
wearing a traditional hijab and dress Evelyn
was one of the original 13 founding members of
the SCP Foundation and matriarch of most of the
bright family unfortunately Evelyn was kicked
off the council for reasons unknown the rumor
has it that it had something to do with her
terrible experiments as a genius geneticist
creating Monsters by splicing the DNA of the
ordinary and the anomalous she sold her work to
groups of interests such as Dr wondertainment
or Prometheus Labs who benefited from having
such fine test subjects to work with her current
activities are largely unknown but as the rest of
the family knew they couldn't be anything good the
final member of the bright family to enter was the
only one who was trusted by all of them and was
a man of many many names who was most commonly
referred to as Tamlin Tamlin was a mysterious
individual who existed for centuries far
longer than any other member of the family
he had something to do with time but no one
was quite sure of what it was that he did but
they all knew that he was important and that he
was the only one who attempted to keep peace and
balance between the various factions of the family
Tamlin took a mental count of the room realizing
that everyone was present and addressed them all
ready to explain why they were there collectively
the family came to realize that the one who called
the meeting Claire bright was not there Tamlin
solely explained that she had passed away and
he had called the family together in her Steed to
present a videotape containing her dying wish the
tape was concocted through Claire and tamlin's
time Shenanigans and featured a recording of
Claire Hood through tamlin's abilities to travel
through and control time was able to respond and
interact with the members of the family in the
room as morbid as Dr brightfelt this was he would
make sure to treasure this final interaction with
his sister Claire's recording contained her will
and with tamlin's help she distributed gifts to
the other members of the family final remembrances
she had collected from across the anomalous world
for them to cherish an egg with a universe inside
of it for Evelyn the literal sword of democles to
hang over mikhail's head jack Bright's first ever
bottle of whiskey that he made so many years
before documents she entrusted to her daughter
Claire II when it came time for TJ's gift however
the boy suddenly grew serious and declined it the
recording of Claire understood and stated that
if he didn't want it then she would instead have
Tamlin give it to someone who needed it Dr bright
could only wonder what it was that she had planned
to give TJ but it seemed like the boy's selfless
nature had won again and he was unable to accept
it after the gifts had been distributed the tape
cut out Tamlin stated that this was all that
Claire had recorded and that she wanted her death
to bring the family together once again to remind
them all that they were family Claire's sincerity
had brought the room to silence each member of the
family engaged in deep thought as Tamlin gave
parting remarks one by one each member left
Mikhail was embarrassed by the ordeal immediately
trying to revert back to his overseer mindset but
he couldn't Blair's loss was already affecting him
in the end there was only Tamlin who left a single
blue rose on top of the VCR player that contained
Claire's recording in remembrance of someone he
felt almost understood him as Dr bright left the
meeting he still felt conflicted about his family
but at the very least he felt there was progress
being made after all they had all been in the same
room for more than 10 minutes without trying to
kill one another he glanced at the boy at his side
wondering if he made the right decision all those
years ago well that much and most of his job with
the foundation was uncertain he knew one thing
for a fact he had to protect TJ you would think
the smell would be the worst part and don't get
me wrong it was far from Pleasant to say the least
that pungent odor a stomach turning scent like raw
sewage it wasn't just dirt and Decay now it was
far more disgusting than that it had that awful
metal Tang to it that meant when that awful stench
crawled its way up your nose it lingered hanging
at the back of your throat choking you on the
sickening wreak that lay thick in the air like a
foul-smelling fog and yet like I said that was far
from the worst part what was well even the side of
what had happened to him wasn't what made me feel
unsettled hardly any of his body was visible
covered in that writhing shifting cloak but
I could see it move each tiny piece of the mass
moving on its own it made me imagine what it must
have felt like to have all those little scratchy
legs and Pinchers Claws and teeth hooking into
skin and that the idea of what it would feel like
that was the worst part about seeing the Vermin
God City life isn't really all it's cracked up
to be ask anyone who lives in a big urban area
and they'll likely tell you the same those bright
lights and Tall spiers reaching up to the clouds
they offer the promise of prosperity opportunity
and even Fame and Fortune for those who are extra
naive but when they uh sticks packed their bags
and moved here to start a new life they realized
that all along they had been sold on a dream a
false fantasy that is just simply too good to
be true of course by the time they get here it's
already too late and before they know it their
knee deep in debt trying to keep up with paying
rent on an apartment that's barely big enough
for one person if you aren't careful a big city
can swallow you up sometimes literally never mind
just desperately trying to make ends meet and keep
yourself afloat there's also plenty of danger to
be found in the heart of the City it doesn't take
much for people to lose themselves in the darker
parts of this Metropolitan hell pretending
it's a Haven and when they do that's usually
where my job starts I've been working as a private
investigator for coming up on a decade my specific
job title had gone through a number of rebrands
and different combinations of terms over the years
Cassius Duke detective for hire then private eye
and freelance investigator after that and don't
fall under the same as sort of assumptions that
most people do when they hear all of those terms
believe me just like the city's promises it rarely
lives up to what you'd imagined it to be like my
life was never high speed chases and gunfights
solving murders and tracking down Crooks that rob
banks and clown masks that was work for the real
police allegedly much higher above my pay grade
now that I had quit most of the time I dealt with
uncovering the various dirty little secrets this
grimy City had to offer more often than not my job
was working as either a spy or enforcer that any
could hire I followed around the rivals of wealthy
businessmen snapping photos of them with my camera
to get any dirt I could that my more unethical
clients would probably use for blackmail or I'd
be warning stalkers to keep away from whoever
they were causing trouble for usually with a
bit of gentle encouragement in the form of some
pretty Stern words and a wrap on the knuckles of
sorts it was ugly work but that suited just how
ugly the underside of this whole city was some of
my clients were often desperate people folks who
the ordinary system of Law and Order had found
when that happened when they had been turned away
by the cops on the verge of losing any hope they
had left that was usually when they turned to me
for hell now I don't work for free of course you
get nothing for nothing everything's got its price
so on and so forth but I wasn't looking to extort
people especially at their lowest moments so firm
but fair I charged them a little bit for my time
maybe a if I happen to come across some dirt that
was really worth some extra cash it was rare for
me to take on a job pro bono as it were without
expecting any pay for my services but when this
case landed in my lap I felt obligated to do
the job for free it was another gray day in a
gray City a knock on the door interrupted me for
my busy schedule of staring at the paint flaking
off my ceiling after I'd called them through the
person responsible for that knock came stepping
cautiously into my office he told me his name
was Martin Jenkins but that his friends called
him Marty sorry I I don't really know how all
this works Martin admitted making no attempt to
mask how nervous he was well why don't you take
a seat first I sighed that's a start oh okay they
replied awkwardly pulling up a chair and sitting
down opposite my desk saw Mr Jenkins what can I
Marty interjected Mr Jenkins I repeated what is
it that brings you here well someone said you
might be able to help with my problem Martin said
sheepishly and what sort of problem are you having
Mr Jenkins I push for him to give me a straight
answer I didn't really have a lot of patience for
anyone who wasted time just getting to the point
it's my brother you see the other Mr Jenkins he
finally confessed he's been missing it's actually
been months now missing persons case is a police
matter I'm sorry but you'll have to go to them as
bad as it felt turning the guy down at a time like
this I had my profession to protect if I wasn't
careful the cops would come down on me like a ton
of bricks I'd already ruffled up some feathers in
that area not long before I'd taken a case where
and I'd accidentally photographed some corrupt
officers accepting bribes one of those pictures
wound up on the Evening News there had been a
Target on my back ever since but detective Duke
Martin began to say Mr Duke I corrected him
I've already tried going to the police they
wouldn't even accepted a missing person's case
when I explained what happened to my brother
I said reaching for my notebook and a pen on the
desk I left the city a while ago after my brother
and I Melvin his name's Melvin Jenkins we we had
an argument and what was it that triggered this
argument I asked dragging my pen across the page
hey it was well a lot of things Martin's side our
father died almost a year ago it wasn't unexpected
but Mel took it pretty hard then the doctors told
us the condition dad had carried a chance of being
hereditary so we both went to get tested I didn't
show any signs of developing it but Alvin did
he took it as a death sentence got very low and
started wasting all of our inheritance on every
Vice he could get his hands on drinking partying
gambling you name it he was doing it and this
led to the argument I broke it did I confronted
him before I left town I was mad that he'd been
using all our dad left us for such frivolous and
irresponsible things Marvin continued his story
almost unable to stop now he's started and he
didn't want to hear any of it said he was going
to die eventually anyway so what was the point
and I told him he was selfish and that was the
last time we spoke when did you notice he was
missing as soon as I came back from out of town
he answered I went to the apartment dad had left
us that too along with all the payments still due
and I found that Mel was gone apparently he had
better in a card game and lost badly I had no way
of finding him nobody else knew where he was let
me guess I stepped in when you went to the police
they said he's most likely living on the street
which would make him a lot harder to find Martin
nodded solemnly clearly feeling guilty for what
had happened although from where I was sitting
it was his brother's own misgivings that had
created this situation I went on to ask a few more
background questions before asking if Mr Jenkins
could provide me with a photo of his missing
brother be obliged handing over a printed picture
the moment I saw it I offered to take the case for
free his brother Melvin I recognized him almost
instantly it was in his mid or possibly late 30s
average height and build in the picture far better
shape and a lot cleaner than when I'd seen him but
it was that same guy that much I was sure of no
amount of unshaved stubble or disheveled clothing
could change that I'd seen him seen Melvin outside
my building a few times sleeping rough on the
sidewalk every day that I showed up to start
another day of work I dropped him a few dollars
anything I had in my wallet at first I told myself
it was for good luck so I didn't attract any
bad karma for myself but when I actually paid
attention to how he was living the gesture became
what it should have been from the start it wasn't
about me or sparing myself bad luck it was just
about trying to help out someone who needed
it when I was in a position to do him a small
kindness at the very least one night I just locked
up my office and I was about to head home as I
stepped off the curb Head Down Eyes on my phone
a truck came speeding down the street I would have
been killed instantly had a hand not grab me and
pulled me back onto the sidewalk Melvin had hold
me out of Harm's Way he didn't say anything to me
and I failed to do anything more than just thank
him verbally before heading home so I figured I
owed him one well I didn't tell his brother this
it had been a few months since I last seen Melvin
outside my building I'd always assume he moved
on or been asked to move by an overzealous cop
of course that meant figuring out where he was
going was going to be tricky exactly the reason
the police had turned Martin away when he'd asked
them for help locating his brother but I had a few
connections that even if they hadn't seen Melvin
might have at least heard something or could know
someone else that had seen him it wasn't a lead
yet but it was a star D was the head of the city's
biggest homeless shelter and a good friend of mine
so she became my first Port of Call I showed her
the photo of Melvin and asked if he come to
stay at the shelter recently doesn't ring a
bell I'm afraid she looks somberly at the picture
sorry Duke I wish I could be more help not on you
I replied taking the photo is she handed it back
to me you mind if I ask around see if anyone here
recognizes him to be my guest decent I spent about
an hour Milling around asking a few down on their
luck folks if they recognize the man in the photo
a few of them mentioned they'd seen him around
here and there sleeping rough in a number of
different parts of the city but none of them could
give me anything concrete no definite location
I'd be able to search next that was until one
of them spoke up he was an older guy but dabbled
clothes and unwashed hair with a thick beard who
had been craning his neck to try and sneak a look
at the photo when I'd been showing someone else I
seen him the man Clarence said matter of factly
you recognize this man I asked to verify said
I seen him he repeated looks different now though
well that's to be expected I replied I don't mean
he's gotten skinnier because he ain't been eaten
Clarence said in retort I mean that he don't even
look like he's human no more but what does that
mean I questioned looking back at the bearded man
in confusion that Batman right there stopped being
a man no idea when or how it happened but last
time I saw him it was already too late nowadays
he's the Vermin God I didn't really have much of
an idea of how to respond unsure if Clarence was
pulling my leg and deliberately wasting my time
if there was some truth to this bizarre urban
legend at any rate it was the only real lead
I had so far albeit a tenuous one at Best so I
pressed the old man to tell me where he'd seen
Melvin of This Vermin God as he kept calling
him there's an abandoned warehouse down on the
waterfront Clarence had explained I knew the place
he meant it used to be a go-to for people who were
sleeping rough lots of us used to stay there but
that's when the pests got bad busts what kind of
pests all kinds rats roaches you name it man just
we were having to deal with them the company that
owned the building sent cops down to clear us out
told us it was unsafe and we should move on it
was sitting there empty for ages so I decided to
chance it head down there and see if we could stop
use in the place again but when I went to look he
was there waiting in the dark and he wasn't alone
he ain't ever alone they're always with him all
around him I chose to ignore clarence's attempts
at unnerving me getting him to confirm once again
that it was in fact Melvin he had seen my next
call was following up on this wild story so so
I hopped on to the next bus across town huddled
together with commuters holding on to ceiling
rails swaying with every turn of the bus like
we were meat hanging in the back of a butcher's
van I walked quite a bit from the bus stop towards
the docks most of the area was restricted off
limits to members of the general public given
how hazardous it could be I wasn't concerned in
my line of work I usually had to get into places
I wasn't supposed to be pulling a pair of wire
cutters from my jacket pocket I snipped through
the chain link fence that surrounded the warehouse
Clarence had directed me to the place wasn't
guarded after all it was empty lifting up the wire
mesh and slipping underneath through the Gap I
grabbed my flashlight and headed in the warehouse
was well and truly deserted previously used for
storage but now just an empty space that was being
left vacant wasted in its lack of use all around
was silence occasionally broken by beads of water
dripping from the Skylight into a puddle on the
ground suddenly I heard a new noise a crunch of
something being squashed under the sole of my
shoe I lifted my foot and Shone my Torchlight
downwards looking to see what I just stepped
on it was a cockroach far bigger and fatter than
anyone I'd ever seen smashed to Pieces underneath
my shoe I stamped the rest of it off a little
disgusted as how everyone gets when they see a
roach dead or alive that's when I noticed another
sound a low dull buzzing my initial thought was
that it was electrical maybe a generator that was
still running I started searching around for the
source of the sound thinking that if I could
flip the switch it might turn on some lights
in here that would make searching for Melvin
a little easier suddenly as I turned a corner
the buzzing sound got louder it wasn't just
closer it was angrier more intense what was
worse was that I'd walk directly into a cloud of
something or lots of some things tiny flies were
whizzing past my ears the noise of their wings
so close it was almost deafening meanwhile even
more were zipping around my face landing on my
skin and rubbing their little germ-coated legs
together waving my arms wildly I tried my best
to disperse the Swarm clearing a few of them
away as I tumbled into the next room my flashlight
clattered to the floor as I crawled over to pick
it back up blindly swatting more of the insects
away in the dark that's when I saw him the Vermin
god with no light in the room only the beam for
my flashlight I hadn't noticed it at first the
second the light fell over the writhing Mass it
shifted as a matter of fact it didn't stop moving
not once it was a seething assortment of vermin
mostly black rats their fur wet with I could only
assume was water straight from the sewer but there
was more worms huge spiders thick roaches dropping
off of the huge shape as it turned it stood up a
mass of animals and insects standing like a man
lumbering towards me creatures were falling off
with every step only to crawl back in and join
the rest I pushed myself back on the floor trying
to get away from what I assumed to be a horrific
monster something controlling all the rats and
Vermin making them form around it like a cloak
of pure filth and Decay the stench of it as well
that foul unclean smell hanging in the air and
lingering at the back of my throat made me want
to be sick it was so repugnant that it kept me
crawling back until my back was pressed up against
the wall trapping me between it and the Vermin
God it leaned closer reaching out an arm covered
in Grime and cockroaches all crawling over each
other I turned away and closed my eyes yelling
out into the dark for anyone to come and help a
voice said weekly I looked up at it panting and
shaking in fear with trembling fingers I lifted
my flashlight higher right up to the head of the
Vermin God beneath the mass of rats crawling over
it and the bugs wriggling about below them a
pair of eyes glinted in my flashlight's beam
human eyes they were eyes I'd seen before the
same hopelessness behind them is when he used
to ask for change outside my building it was
Melvin that's when I started to see beneath the
Vermin coating his body catching brief glimpses
of his arms and chest just as one rat moved but
before another slipped in and took its place his
skin was pockmarked with bites and scratches some
fresh and still bleeding others that had started
to dry beneath the shroud of crawling insects and
rodents his face had gotten gaunt coated in the
thick layer of dirt he wasn't controlling these
things if anything the Vermin seemed to be using
him as some kind of host just as I edged a little
closer to him considering the idea of reaching
into the the mass and pulling Melvin free one
of the rats spit me I dropped my torch at the
pain of the tiny needley teeth piercing my skin
and started to feel more of them crawling up my
ankles I turned heel and ran all the way out of
the warehouse by the time I was far enough away
the rats that had left onto me had crawled back
off heading back inside into their Vermin God
now go and check out scp-1025 Encyclopedia of
common diseases and scp-3760 like a doll's eye
for more sickening stories of other anomalous
illnesses that are guaranteed to make your skin
crawl or maybe that's just the rats you're feeling